e
on House Bill 437 and here from the
prime sponsor representative
boy good
morning representative
Bo good morning Mr chairman thank you
for having me and Mr chairman through
you to my esteemed colleagues of the
Commerce and consumer affairs committee
uh for the record my name is Bill Boyd I
am a state representative representing
District 12 the town of marac home of
the tomahawks and I am the prime sponsor
for House Bill 437 which seeks to
provide Curative measures for
undischarged
mortgages I've handed out my written
testimony to the committee and I've
actually provided an exhibit of what the
bill seeks to accomplish um what I can
tell you is I the conversation started
immediately with the New Hampshire
Bankers Association and worked with the
New Hampshire Bar Association the New
Hampshire realators to uh get their Buy
in on the bill I we also reached out to
the Attorney General's office and the
banking Department um the AG's office is
not taking an opinion however the
banking Department did weigh in with
some clarifying language in the bill
that I do want to bring to your
attention because there is a grammatical
error in the bill on line
18 the word action is missing it's
between the words further and the number
five on line 18 and when you read the
context of the bill you'll see that the
language without the necessity of any
further action are in all three sections
just section three is missing that word
action um and I would hope that the
appropriate correction would be made to
the bill where do you want the word
action I'm sorry sure the word Action
Line 18 Mr chairman line 18 without the
necessity of any further five years an
action needs to be inserted between
okay okay so the in in brief the the
legislation um House Bill House Bill 437
seeks to shorten the amount of time it
takes for an undischarged mortgage to
become
unenforceable uh right now the statute
has a 50-year statute of limitations for
private mortgages the law is silent as
it relates
to public mortgages banks credit unions
and mortgage mortgage companies so the
bill before you uh would um replace
section
47928 with completely new language the
language is going to mimic what the
Commonwealth of Massachusetts has
specifically mortgages with with an
expiration term or a maturity date would
be voided five years after the date of
expiration if mortgages are filed
without an expiration term or maturity
date um generally speaking in
Massachusetts the law is 35 the bill
proposed 35 years so no expiration date
that mortgage would be unenforceable
from the date of recording plus 35 years
so that's the proposed law in a nutshell
um I have um um Michelle R coffin my
colleague Mary hackin Philips one of the
co-sponsors and we have Susan Cole from
the real Association who are also going
to be testifying to speak firsthand
about some of the other problems that
they've experienced uh with with these
obsolete mortgages I've been I've been I
started pulling books in a registry of
deeds when I was 13 years old I'm 56 and
I'm still doing this line of work and
then this is kind of the bane of my
existence when I get title work down to
Massachusetts and I see an unenforceable
mortgage I can I can write it off by
Statute down to Massachusetts but in New
Hampshire I can't I have to report that
um so that the conveyances and maywar to
do what they need to do to try and
remedy the issue and the te the
anecdotal testimony that you'll hear
today will amplify uh why uh this bill
actually is going to fix a problem it is
it's going to provide a necessary remedy
to um consumers and attorneys and
conveyancers that have had this
particular problem
with obsolete mortgages so in in
summation this is really it's a it's
it's a consumer bill and it'll make
it'll make the mortgage and conveyancing
Industry a little bit easier in terms of
how we reconcile obsolete mortgages so
well all that being said uh thank you
very much chairman for your time and I
certainly would enjoy the opportunity to
answer
questions any questions see none thank
you very much thank you Mr CH okay uh
Phillips good morning Mr chair and
members of the committee uh for the
record I'm representative Mary hacken
Phillips serving Handover and lime in
Grafton 12 I'm so pleased to be with you
today speaking as a co-sponsor in
support of HB
437 so my day job while serving in the
New Hampshire house was practicing as a
real estate attorney here in conquered
and as part of the my scope of practice
um it included helping resolve real
estate titles for clients who had an
interest in clearing title
irregularities attached to their
properties so more often than not the
case originates because when you're
preparing to close a real estate
transaction an undischarged or
improperly discharged mortgage would pop
up on the title search and this is known
as a title
defect these defects or irregularities
trigger the need for the current owner
of the property or the title insurer to
go through a timec consuming practice
and financial expense of finding the old
mortgage lender and getting them to
complete a formal discharge that's
proper and then record it or in the
alternative it's finding an attorney
like myself to file a petition in court
to have the undischarged morgage cleared
or quieted from the title uh and you do
that by getting a judge's declaratory
order in my experience neither remedy
was either efficient or fast in fact the
latter example um when you have to hire
an attorney to clear title these court
cases take several months and thousands
of dollars to complete and after proper
notices and weeks of waiting more often
than not a judge would enter the order
discharging the old mortgage because no
interested party holding the old
mortgage came forward and no one
contested the actual property ownership
interests so it's really a one-sided
court case that takes a bunch of time
that doesn't really um you know have any
contested issues in in the court so it
let me just be clear it is stable work
for attorneys and property law but I
think you'd be hardpressed to find
anyone else who believe that they
benefit from this process sure it def it
definitely gives the actual mortgage
holders time to come forward and to
claim um that they still are holding on
to an unpaid loan but in my years of
practice I never saw that happen so um
that's why I believe that this proposed
statutory process for wrapping up these
expired mortgages and title defects can
be a benefit to our legal system and
clearing unnecessary docket clutter uh
and we all know that our court systems
could use a few more resources for you
know tackling the most pressing issues
before our state but I also believe that
the proposed statutory process could
benefit our title examination standards
in a way that helps home buyers and Loan
customers while fairly balancing those
interests against mortgage holders and
banking institutions so as a formal
commercial lending attorney I can also
speak to the perspective of lenders who
will need time to adjust to the proposed
statutory process changes that we're
proposing here um this law will put
mortgage holders on notice that they
must more frequently update their
recordings to extend a mortgage um and
those leans on properties but um I
believe you know they're going to have
have adequate time um to prepare and
then when they do have this new process
process they will appreciate having the
system in place because it will continue
to protect their interests as well um
and I think that's what we call a
win-win when both parties win so for
these reasons Mr chair and committee I
urge uh your members to move a to pass
on HB
437 and thank you so much for your time
and attention if you have any questions
I'd be happy to answer them okay I do um
so
representative boy in his day job and
you stumble upon one of
these and he say oh it's past five years
is there I don't see that there's
actually notification to whoever was
left on the record that your your that
their mortgage is now going to be
treated as discharged even though it
wasn't in other words you're you're
talking about how it puts people on
notice that they need to pay attention
but I don't really see that language in
here I'm seeing is that you know it
could have been 10 years later and the
bank is probably could have been long
gone the people who were involv gone but
you're but there's no responsibility of
sending out of notice and say oh by the
way we just noticed this wasn't properly
discharged and and but under New
Hampshire law we have the right to
discharge it but there's no
notifications right am I missing
anything I don't see that in this bill
so I think we're um just talking past
each other a little bit about the term
of art under the legal system as notice
so we are a notice State uh which
requires any transactions for Real
Estate to be recorded at our local
County registry of deeds correct so
that's the actual legal notice of
transactions in our in our state that we
currently recognize so this law proposes
that mortgage holders would have to
legally record more notice
every 5 years to extend their mortgages
um now in terms of the obligations of
mortgage holders to notify their own
clients of you know that they didn't do
it or they forgot to do the renewal uh
so actually I think it the interest is
that the obligation is on the lender to
to do the notice at the recording office
I'm just saying so let's say the lender
screwed up yeah okay and forgot to do it
happens quite a bit
actually so um there are it's not so the
banks under the bus yet well um you know
there some of the issue is that
mortgages can be reassigned as you all
are aware I'm sure and so um many times
large institutions from out of state
will have new assignments and not that I
very on timely basis for re-recording or
extending those mortgages so um very
often what happens if you're you know
someone in the know of how this process
works you can contact your lender and
let them know they need to re you know
um like update their mortgage um
assignments or they need to re U if
there's an error in the actual recording
they need to go back and you know take
corrective action and make a new
recording so um yes that is um it's
technically on the onus of the mortgage
holder but but as practice and many
people here will speak to the reality in
practice is that that gets delayed um
okay so what you're saying is is that if
if if the bank really did the mortgage
holder really did screw up and didn't
keep the keep it up they didn't keep
their book straight and they didn't do
it and then you know after the 5year
period 10 years later when someone wants
to REM you know Mor the property and
find this defect um they have no
obligation to notify the bank they
screwed up because at that point that
bank is probably already written off the
mortgage in the first place already
they've already done it or something
like that but anyways it's tough bananas
for them there can't there's no no they
have no legal right to say oh wait a
minute we we made a mistake us out I
mean they do have a legal right to
contest it for sure and so um that is
what this law would ensure is that um
people have lenders or mortgage holders
have noticed that they have a new
obligation to do this more timely and if
someone were to cont where do they have
that notice how would they get well
that's how this law would change the
proposed law the RSA the fact that law
is on the books that means they should
be paying attention to it yes and so but
but those who would contest it right so
if there is a bank that is holding a
note that is not paid in full but forgot
to extend their mortgage right if they
can contest this in court if someone
were trying to make a sale or you know
without paying the lean on on the
property so you know your full due
process rights are still available as a
mortgage holder as a lender you can
still go and you know contest the sale
or contest you know the right to pay off
the loan um th those rights don't change
so that's why I was saying it's a
win-win it just provides um both parties
a little more equal um share on the
responsibility for what is out on the
books in terms of the recording process
spear I am a total neoy in this area so
I just have a
question and excuse me if it's it's a
dumb
question are we talking about mortgages
that have been paid off but they haven't
been cleared or are we talking about
ongoing mortgages that are still have
money on them well a little bit of both
yeah really yeah so there are many um
instances at least in my practice that I
saw where private individuals or
institutions may have had a small
balance on the books but it wasn't
really
worth uh the the legal ramifications to
go through another recording or actually
fully discharge
um the loan in some cases the mortgage
so um but there are also instances where
the loans were totally paid off but
because of like um for instance the 2008
2009 Financial um crisis Across America
many
institutions um traded hands were
Consolidated and you know those assets
were all moved around and mortgages got
you know the paperwork got disrupted and
so it was never discharged even though
someone had paid the loan in full but it
was a new ownership interest and they
didn't follow the correct procedure for
whatever reason so it can be it can be
both okay representative M um correct me
if I'm wrong if if let's say a mortgage
was a 10-year mortgage um five years
beyond that though is not contestable by
the the bank that's the way I read
this no I I don't believe that is right
um so if a if a loan is not paid off and
the mor mortgage is not discharged the
mortgage the lean remains on the
property but once F I like five years
passed oh under under the new proposal
yes um it would be deemed expired so I'm
sorry if I didn't okay you're asking
about current law thank you yep
representative
Gibbs thank you Mr chair and thank you
for coming to testify uh this morning um
so um I had a mortgage that I paid off
long ago and it had been transferred to
a bank in Florida um that had no
understanding of New Hampshire law um
and I do not know whether um the bank
ever recorded the fact that I paid it
off but under this uh bill it is the
bank's responsibility to record the fact
that the mortgage has been paid yes that
is correct M thank you
m thank you very much thank you for your
Cuffin good morning good morning thank
you Mr chair thank you members of the
committee I really am grateful to have
the opportunity to speak to you today
this is a very important bill for me um
and I really want to touch upon
something after the last testimony what
this bill seeks to do is is a little bit
different than what we're sort of
focusing on at the moment often times
99% of the time what happens when you're
doing a let me give you sorry a little
bit of background I owned a title
company and conquered New Hampshire for
18 years I have been in uh the real
estate industry since
1989 and I'm now a title insurance
underwriter I've also been bitten by
this twice and have had to have two
Quiet Title actions um at the time I did
them they were 5,000 and now it's about
10,000 $8 to $10,000 hire an attorney
for quiet title action what we're really
seeking to resolve here is a little bit
different it is that usually what
happens in the course of a title search
when someone's either selling their
property um the buyer's lender is going
to require a title search uh the title
insurance company that's going to be
writing the policy for the lender and
the buyer is going to require a title
search when you're refinancing the
lender is going to require a title
search during the course of that title
search you'll see a mortgage that's on
record that has not been discharged or
has been incorrectly discharged by the
wrong entity right and so these
mortgages you know that they've been
paid they're so old um uh their their
mortgages that have been on record if
the lender had any sort of a uh you know
payment due by this time typically they
would have filed a foreclosure action
and so these mortgages are obsolete
they're ancient they're old they should
have been discharged but the correct um
entity to discharge them oftentimes is
no longer in existence and if an entity
that discharged it was the as KN well
there's a missing assignment and the
assignment needs to come from that
lender who held the mortgage who is now
no longer in business right and so we're
seeing I'm seeing constantly the the
biggest title defect I see as a title
insurance underwriter and I saw in my 18
years of owning a title company were UND
charged mortgages that were clearly paid
we're not talking about that and if that
something has been paid and there's
unjust enrichment the bank has an
opportunity to file a petition in equity
you know that's not what this is seeking
to to do this is seeking to clear up the
clouds upon many people's title and
we're talking about the consumer of
mortgages in real estate right so we're
trying to clear this up because it is
extremely costly to go and hire an
attorney to do a quiet title action for
something that should just be
automatically discharged after a certain
period of time that's what we're hoping
to do here that is what we are hoping to
rectify and really I've said this before
I've have I've sent you all testimony
and I highly encourage you to read some
of the online testimony if you haven't
already particularly the attorney who
had to do my quiet title action Patrick
mcnicholas who was supposed to be here
to testify today but is in Florida where
it's warm lucky him um and uh Gary
Bernier uh I would encourage you to read
their testimony uh because it's actually
fantastic and and and um I think it
really gets the point across of what
we're trying to do here but this is a
consumer bill that is just a consumer
protection issue that's long overdue for
a remedy and I really hope that I
encourage all of you to support it and I
thank you for your time today and please
if you have any questions certainly
happy to answer them I think we're all
set we we get it okay thank you very
much uh Susan Cole from New Hampshire
reals
good morning Mr chair and members of the
committee thank you very much my name is
Susan Cole I am broker owner of Susan
Cole realy in Lev in New Hampshire I'm
also the 2025 president of the New
Hampshire Association of Realtors
Realtors are supportive of House Bill
437 as a realtor I've seen the
challenges that some borrowers face when
attempting to obtain a timely and
accurate mortgage discharge during a
title examination we do see fortunately
too often an undischarged mortgage
sometimes the mortgage has been paid off
but the bank either has not issued the
discharge or it has not been recorded
the current process the consumers must
go through when a mortgage was not
discharged properly can be burdensome
cause unnecessary delays and at times
become costly placing unnecessary
hardship on responsible homeowners
addressing these issues will provide
much needed relief to homeowners
streamline real real estate transactions
and ensure a fair and transparent
process for all parties involved
mortgage discharges should not be a
source of stress or financial burden for
homeowners who have fulfilled their
obligations I have clients um that have
experienced this issue themselves
recently I had a seller who was selling
a home that had been in the family for
many years um multiple Generations at
some point in that chain there was a
mortgage that was was not um correctly
discharged and we had to go through
unfortunately it was uh we went through
all of the contingencies within the
contract the buyer was very excited to
proceed this was found on the title
examination and in the state of New
Hampshire the sellers are given 30 days
as part of the contract to repair and
remediate uh a title issue something
like this that requires quiet title is
takes much longer than that so at the
end of that 30 days this particular
buyer decided I don't I'm not sure how
long this might take they decided to
terminate the contract for my seller who
then had to continue to march on to try
to get this quiet title remedied um it
was a lot of expense um for attorney
fees the time not to mention the
emotional turmoil that that caused them
the buyer meanwhile moved on after a
couple of months I reached out to the
buyer's agent and said okay we've got
the clear um title the title issues been
remedied the buyer said okay I I'll come
back I'll resubmit an offer guess what
that meant for the buyer the buyer then
had to start from the beginning redo the
appraisal and start those uh that
Financial um obligation to get their
loan satisfied started over essentially
so both the seller and the buyer
incurred EX extens of expenses that
should not have been necessary in this
situation it clearly had been paid off
they just didn't have what was recorded
properly so the time the aggravation the
cost this should be something that's
addressed for the consumers of our state
Realtors hope you will support HB 437
thank
you Ryan Hill from New Hampshire bankers
wasn't planning to two minutes I'll be
one
minute well thank you uh for the record
uh my name is Ryan hail vice president
government relations for the New
Hampshire Bankers Association uh we
represent 40 member banks that employ
6,000 um employees um I just want to
first of all thank representative Boyd
for reaching out to us early on in this
process um we vetted this language
thoroughly I presented it to our
mortgage committee receives uh feedback
that um the feedback that I did receive
they were fine with this proposal uh we
had many discussions with our policy
committee and our board um we did
suggest a few changes and one thing I do
want to point out since it was mentioned
is about notice um we did ask for an
extension on when this would become
effective and you'll notice um it says
January 1st 2028 is when this will
become effective um that was the request
of New Hampshire Bankers to ensure that
our members have adequate time to make
sure that um it the the dischar that the
maturity dates on their mortgages that
they hold are properly recorded um I'll
stop there and happy to answer any
questions but I know you heard from the
experts
already thank you very much you're very
welcome we'll close the public hearing
on
4:37 and we'll open up the public
721 representative
start no
like going back watch the videos later
oh yeah the public loves
it loves it um thank you very much Mr
chair um my name is Juliet Harvey bullia
and I represent belac District three and
I'm here to introduce House Bill 721
FN um the golden silver legal tender Act
of New Hampshire I passed around um just
some graphics and and what not but um I
just want to say that this bill is a
bipartisan economic Justice bill which
will help everyone even people with
little or no means to hold their wealth
and be a hedge against uh inflation what
I mean by um it's bipartisan just a
historical note that in
1896 the um the Democrat the Democratic
party platform Foundation was a a gold
based Foundation they were their
nickname was literally the gold
Democrats um because they were Jeff
Jeffersonian and they were for the gold
standard uh so just keep that in mind
please be open-minded about the bill um
it's not uh for one party or the other
but the big reason for passing
legislation like this which would um
establish golden Silver's legal tender
is basically there three T's trust taxes
and taking and we want to address those
um with this sort of
legislation um for trust that gold is is
very trustworthy it is known as a hedge
against inflation it is actually um
according to the banking industry a tier
one asset established in 2019 they
established gold as a tier one asset um
so it is not um sort of a relic of the
past um and a lot of of states are going
towards this legislation they're
actually expanding on this is just a
basic definition but there as you've
known from representative ammon's um
bills in the past that it is becoming um
more of a a platform a banking platform
uh to use gold and
silver um and then we have taxes um and
I've at the bottom of your sheet I've
listed some um taxes how tax structures
work in the in our neighboring
states um Maine and Vermont just tax
gold and
silver regardless of of any of any um
sort of um thresholds in
Massachusetts they if you are trading
and buying gold um for more than
$1,000 then uh you are exempt from from
taxes but under a th000 then uh um you
have to pay the sales tax and that is
because as you probably heard before
gold and silver coins are considered
collectible and they're not considered
money even the US minted coins because
they have like an intrinsic value that
is over their face value um and so that
is shocking to some people that think
that it is um that is real money but it
is not considered um actual money by the
IRS or some States obviously uh so you
have to pay taxes on your money um so
this sort of thing we can't get away
from with the federal government at this
point although I hear that there is
legislation to establish a
minimum um so that if you're you're
buying and selling in small amounts that
you would be exempt um but
um we want to establish what you know
what we're doing is
um you know right now we're not taxing
gold and silver and we're not we we
don't um but you know in the case that
we do establish the sales tax at some
point in the future I think this
exception is there something
wrong you try to shock
oh yeah thank you sometimes in the
future there may be you know God forbid
we have a sales tax um this could be a
carve out so that we don't end up like
Massachusetts Main in Vermont um where
it's there's there's sales tax they tax
it like any other consumable
item um okay so and then as far as the
taking um you know on April 5th 1933 FDR
told Americans in the form of executive
order 6102 that that they had less than
a month to hand over their gold coins
bullion and gold certificates or face up
to 10 years in prison or a fine of
$10,000 um God forbid that happens again
but this is a sort of thing where we
want to reinstate we want to um you know
make a declaration that we see gold and
silver as legal
tender um so it's a constitu
constitutional issue um um it's also a
hedge against
cbdcs um and it would promote Financial
Independence um where I see this going
is you know look at the map here that
I've I've given you all the lighter
colored States either have passed gold
or silver legislation or it's pending
it's enormously popular now throughout
all the states Utah is even considering
that so Utah's done a study Florida has
a big study going about uh gold and
silver legislation Utah is actually
considering paying its state employees
with
Golds and
um uh you know they they're Florida and
is considering using up so in Texas they
have a depository as you well know from
representative ammon's bills in the past
and you know and that is state-owned or
state sanctioned in Florida they're
considering a third party uh custodian
of their banking their gold and silver
banking I think they're going to use
Brinks and Brinks has agreed to um sort
of be the custodian and do the business
end of things um and that's where I hope
to see this going in the
future um this is sort of the Florida
latest legislation to deal with all the
uh definitions and transactional pieces
here um but right now I mean I'm kind of
hoping that the committee will see fit
to at least declare gold and silver
legal tender and I realize so there's a
part in the
bill you know and it says gold and
silver is legal tender for all
transactions um in order to use gold and
silver um the buyer and seller must
agree to a fair market value so I put
this in um and I have since learned a
lot more about it um mostly what people
are doing is using these if you look at
your page there's two like credit cards
down here so this can easily be I I made
my my I made an account myself you can
make these accounts you can buy gold and
silver um it's super easy to do I just
did it yesterday in fact and there's a
GL there's an app called a glint app
glint card and this is
actually a vault in Switzerland so you
buy you you know I just bought $50 worth
of gold um you can you and they're going
to send me a credit card and it's almost
free and you use use it like it's a
debit card so you just use it anywhere
like a debit card so I don't know if the
committee is open to hopefully um
putting in this sort of
um language about declaring golden
silver legal tender for all
transactions um possibly they you want
to eliminate the part about coins
because this isn't the future of using
gold and silver is in these apps and in
these credit cards where it's held you
can monitor you could buy small amounts
you can add to it it's very versatile
it's accepted everywhere everywhere like
a Visa card is um and that way and the
advantage of this is you know you you
could buy your gold in times of uh
volatility and high
inflation you can put some you can put
your cash in this and it's it's over the
long run it's as stable as gold is which
is a great store of value just a quick
um little anecdote about
inflation um during the Biden years you
know we went up to 8% inflation which
was horrifying to a lot of us um and we
didn't know where that was going to go
and a lot of people who had cash in the
bank were looking for like what what
where do I put my money here because I
don't know how how much longer this uh
inflation is going to go on so so you
know my family we decided to buy a
tractor and we're not Farmers or
anything but we could use the tractor so
um that's what we did and there was a a
a waiting lot everybody else was also
thinking that this was a great idea
because they were there was quite a
weight for the
tractor um and I was talking to
representative Bean also from belnap
County and we were talking about the bad
inflation and he said I didn't know what
to do this inflation is is alarming and
when we went and bought a
tractor and um yeah and he's not a
farmer either I was talking to another
state representative about this was over
a year ago during our high inflationary
period uh from the dairy area um and she
said her and her husband had just bought
a an excavator or tractor I forget which
it was was a piece of heavy equipment um
so this is what people are doing to to
run away from high volatility inflation
whatnot and I'm you know hopefully we
won't see that sort of 8% crazy runaway
inflation again uh but it's going to
come back and someday we'll have that um
but instead of buying tractors you know
this is this is a a good investment this
is a good Financial tool for everyone
people can instead of buying um tractors
or thinking about buying gold coins
which I thought about buying gold coins
but you have to work about them being
real and um you have to worry about um
theft and storage um and then they're
not exactly easy to break into smaller
denominations you know you have to spend
a lot of money for that um so that's
where I'm you know when I think about
using and having like uh people paying
their property taxes with gold and
silver I'm not thinking about they're
going to take a sack of gold to um the
Town Clerk and say here you go and then
forcing the town clerk to you know Chomp
down on the gold and see if it's real or
not I this is this is the future of gold
and silver
usages um through these through these
digital platforms so with that I'm um um
here okay so uh we are sure on time here
I I was kind of hoping this was going to
be a quickie but so let's not ask too
many questions but if you really got a
specific you know that you can Target
into so representative Sal you have a
question thanks for taking my question
um I have two questions I'll make the
first one quick is this currently
illegal now if somebody I mean is there
a ban for somebody to to willing parties
to exchange in gold or
silver like I mean is there Outlaw it's
outlawed right now is what you're
telling me no I mean I'm not saying it's
outlawed it's um thank you for the
question it's um it's it's the the
classification by the IRS that gold and
silver is not it's a
collectable um in it's tax that's a
federal federal that's a federal thing
and
so you know the danger is we we don't
really have a classification as far as
I'm concerned here in New Hampshire for
it and so that is why I wanted to codify
it and classify it as such um sort of
going forward to protect and to
reestablish that we
can um establish you know go forward and
and for possibly explore things like
they've done in Utah Florida and all
these other
states um to expand upon gold and silver
as legal tender and if if the treasury
is holding gold and silver as legal
tender you know I'm kind of
investigating this but I don't know FDR
I I've heard that FDR did not confiscate
States
gold in still silver stores back in the
30s but I'm still looking into that if
that's true we want to we want to come
out and um declare it legal T further
question really quick further question
me inquire you you have this picture
here of the Visa card or Master Card
that's backed by gold so I'm
assuming if like these are already in
existence
it sounds like this might not be
necessary because if I have a Visa card
that is backed by gold I can presumably
you say you have one now use it now to
go buy something at Walmart or wherever
um so right it it seems this seems
unnecessary and I don't understand what
problem this is actually solving so am I
missing something with that because you
said this is the future but it sounds
like the future's already
here right thank you for the question um
it it I mean practically speaking it
wouldn't change anything from you know
we passed it right now to the next year
um except for the trust
piece and the idea that you know
possibly we're we're having the
treasurer hold gold and silver as as an
asset for two and possibly the idea of
bartering and whatnot and the other
thing about sales taxes I mean again
it's something that possibly in the
future we'd have a sales tax and then
this would be a carve out so that you
wouldn't tax everything at long
um so that's that's where I'm going with
that thank you okay any other
representative
Gibbs thank you Mr chair
um I don't really understand this bill
and I'm going to tell you why I'll try
and be as brief as I can we will have a
subcommittee so we can get into the
detail so if you want to keep it at a
very high level you know but I I think
she's going to I'll keep it as brief as
I can I can reach out to you too
represent um okay I understand about
holding gold my father did it but not as
a hedge against inflation he did it
because he and his parents were refugees
from the Holocaust um okay so that's a
would you believe question that's that's
not okay she's not really answering that
what is the specific question about the
bill that you want we have a lot of
people we got I'm I'm sorry I screwed up
I have too many bills today so I I'm
really really if it's going to be a high
you know kind of my point is I don't
understand why I'm trying to explain why
I don't understand
why
okay that's that's fine we we we get it
that's a would you believe question yeah
okay may I proceed Mr
chair shall I proceed I I think I think
you asked your you made your point you
don't understand the purpose of the bill
and she's just going to repeat I don't
understand why I understand like I
understand but she's just going to
repeat what her testim I don't think
there's any new thing that going to do
to highlight for you I'm sorry I can't
hear
you I think I I'm trying to just move
this this hearing along okay bear with
me on this one well it just seems
incredibly cumbersome and it doesn't
make sense to me and would you believe
well I'm trying to ask you why would
just exactly would you believe that's
credibly csome that's your ask that's
your question and she doesn't have to
answer the question because she doesn't
really want to go through the thing all
over again well I wish you would we will
do that in
subcommittee all right represent
Hammond thank you for letting me ask a
very quick question um I guess it's a
would you believe when we started
talking about this two years ago gold
was $1,900 now it's $22,900 so it's gone
up 50% just in a few years we've been
talking about
this it's not because the gold has
changed it's because too much money was
printed so if I hold an ounce of gold I
bought it for 19900 it goes up to 2,900
and I sell it I have to pay capital
gains on
$1,000 but it's not really gains it's uh
I'm holding value and the the value of
the money has gone down and yet I'm
taxed on that g on that supposed gain so
if States declared at legal tender it
would eliminate that tax if the federal
government would would respond respond
to the state's prompting so would you
believe that that would be my
explanation for why the bill might be a
good
idea I know I know representative hunt
doesn't want me to say anything no you
could say yes I totally agree thank you
very much representative Ammon if it's
also a hedge against if all the states
are going towards this adoption of of um
legal tender and pursuing these other
means of bringing gold into their
economies then it's a competition for
the Federal Reserve and also yes it is
not that the gold is going up but the
dollar is not holding its value perfect
answer
represent thank you Mr chair would you
consider uh prior to our subcommittee
meeting making an amendment so that you
go beyond the description of coin or bar
form since you're already talking about
cards credit cards and I know that gold
also comes in like a foil
yes form as well so that's it exactly I
was thinking along the same lines it
probably needs an amendment but that's
what OSS kind of bump through towards me
thank you very much thank you very much
sorry for being so Rush about that okay
thank okay uh chair we'll call on sarin
Association he good morning my name is
Sarah Burke Cohen I represent the New
Hampshire Municipal
Association the New Hampshire Municipal
Association opposes this bill um as it
is written if it gold and silver could
become legal tender although I
appreciate the sponsor discussion about
using Visa cards if gold and silver as
written becomes legal tender then people
could bring their gold or silver to um a
town clerk's office to pay their um
property taxes municipalities aren't set
up for security for gold and silver um
nor are they set up to um be
metallurgist and determine um the sort
of the grade of gold and silver um it's
impractical for both parties um in this
circumstance for with regard to
municipalities um so I'm going to keep
it real short representative hunt New
Hampshire Municipal Association opposes
a spill I'm open for
questions okay so you're pointing out
that where it has the definition of
legal tender it just talks about um is
agreed upon by the buyer and seller but
not as as is that the town is being
forced to take it as as right even if
it's agreed upon because of the
volatility of gold that um
representative Aman uh spoke about the
municipality could take gold and perhaps
it would go up or perhaps it would go
down so between the time it would secure
it in a vault that it doesn't have
currently and then bring it to to sell
or however it disposes of it okay
representa spe
just thank you just based on what you
just said would the municipalities have
any way to establish an exchange rate
since you have to report budgets and
dollars and things like that and pay
salaries and dollars would you have any
way to even ex uh establish an exchange
rate I I I wouldn't know the answer to
that but my conjecture would be probably
not okay thank you very much thank you
hos turn so you had to push your mic yep
okay good morning joar from
gilmington uh I was uh just like the
representative over here wondering what
this bill was and I'm glad I listened to
it and I do have a few comments and one
of them to start off is the last speaker
on the nhma of the uh municipalities
having to restructure their system I
will remind her if she hasn't read it
before and you all too you you take an
oath of office to abide by the
Constitution and in New Hampshire it's
article 97 the value of money how
computed and when you look at The
annotation it goes to the state versus
Fleming case I learned this from dick
marel as you know Mr
chairman yes I was for him too what's
that yeah I was here when he put this
bill in yes and uh I went to archives
and I researched that it said that the
New Hampshire consented to the coinage
act of 1792 in
1794 uh it's in chapter 28 of the laws
of New Hampshire Volume 7 uh no volume 6
page
155 so if you all want to read that I
mean even Bill Burns there was a front
page story in the union Le back in the
1980s he said that that's what he wants
to pay the town and the town is not
cooperating so he's not going to pay
anything but you know what I say in that
you put the money in the bank and dare
the town to take it under RSA 80 colon 2
as a
distraint and I did that in bosquin I
dared them they never took it so then
they took my property uh by tax deed and
that's being contested in the courts
well the courts Superior Court if you
want to read it ha versus Mar uh town of
Bosa Incorporated but what I wanted to
get at is I was over in May it's not a
federal issue only it's over in Maine I
went to a coin shop and I you know
so-called I wanted to
buy a silver dollar or two and he said
that'll be 5% tax to the governor and I
said no come on you're actually buying
commercial paper you're the one that has
the money money is minted not printed
the Constitution says to coin money so
that's uh you know all this
stuff this has got to be rewarded and
subcommittee would be nice thank
you thank you very much it's nice to see
you again Joe same it okay got one card
LIF uh natch gra from Bia in opposition
Bill thank you Mr chair members of the
committee n Grace for the business and
industry Association Statewide chamber
Commerce uh we do oppose this
legislation um mainly because it's
unclear if businesses can refuse payment
in um coin or bars of gold and silver um
we'd like to be able to do so if this is
if you want to legalize uh gold and
silver um basically because our econom
is really not set up at this point in
time for acceptance and trade of of gold
and silver and I understand that's the
intent of this but um realistically many
of our businesses do business out of
state um they're going to need to
convert this to cash it appears that
agreeing on the fair market value involv
some conversion to US Dollars um and it
would simply be easier for us to if they
want to continue using US dollars so
that's the basis for objection happy to
take any questions the committee may
have thank you very much thank you uh
with that I will close the public
and open up the public hearing on
454 um I spoke to the
sponsor and the sponsor was unable to
come in today because he uh has to work
uh he his comment to me was well I know
you'll just kill the bill so that we
don't really know big deal and I told
him no um that uh this committee has in
the past past
historically uh always kept a bill that
was an issue that was hanging out there
and we would want to send the message
that we certainly hope we don't need to
pass such a bill and the best way for us
to do that is to retain the bill and
hold on to it and just keep an eye on
the marketplace assuming that nothing
funky happens in the marketplace and
that all of a sudden
um that that this product appears that
um at this point this is an old issue uh
we've had legislation in the past but I
think by retaining this bill um we will
hope that we won't see this
problem so having said that is there
anybody feel compelled to
testify seeing none perfect thank you
very
much we close the public caring on 454
the next bill is House Bill 517
repealing the grand State Family Leave
plan and I have representative turcot's
card
here
good morning representative good morning
Mr chairman members of the Commerce
Committee I am representative Len turkot
I represent the uh towns of barington
and straford that is straford District
4 um I am here for HB 57 which is to
repeal uh the fmli program um I'm going
to give give you just a quick brief
history because I think for those of you
who weren't around when it was
implemented uh the history of this uh
issue has been going on for a very long
time um during my second term I uh I was
on labor for three terms and during my
second term Senator feltus actually
introduced a bill that would have
implemented a .5% tax on all wages
within the state although he didn't call
it a tax
um that would have forced every New
Hampshire employee to pay into the
system um that was not well received but
when the option of opt into a system
voluntary system was suggested it was uh
near universally agreed that the only
way to make a Statewide fmli system work
was by forcing everybody in the state to
contribute that was uh ultimately failed
then we moved up to uh would have been
in
2021 uh when the current program was
brought
forward um for those that were here you
might remember what actually happened
was the
fmli uh the house uh we were against it
but it was being pushed by then Governor
sununu um what happened was this fmli
program was snuck into hb2 two during
the committee of con conference in
2021 Against The Specific Instructions
of house leadership at that time I was a
senior adviser in house leadership and
also a member of the committee of
conference um long story there that
stunt resulted in the chairman uh the
chairwoman of Finance actually being
removed under threat that the hb2 would
not get
passed that was done uh a little bit
after that and she resigned from the
house The house's position on fmli has
been consistently against the program
because it's not a fiscally Republican
idea I will see uh say on that
hb2
um in my five terms on the in the house
I've not voted on Two Bills in that in
my entire time here one because I was
introducing a bill in the Senate the
other one because even though I was a
member of leadership and expected to
vote for hp2 I refused to vote for hp2
solely for the reason that FMI had been
snuck into
it as I said FM certainly not a
republican issue after it passed it was
Hush Hush nobody ran on it in their
campaigns no Republicans ran on it uh
the governor the Senate speaker
everybody was kind of crush hush hush
and that is because it's not a
republican issue it in fact to social
entitlement the first attempt to repeal
was in 2022 and that was before it was
up and running the house passed it the
Senate killed it because at the time it
was the governor's
program so here we are again and
hopefully for the last time so what what
actually was the result of the fmly
program so what it did is it instituted
a law yet or into law yet another in
Social entitlement program the biggest
sing single issue is that all the state
employees 5,000 uh 10,500 at the time
were given this fmli to them without
negotiations at taxpayer expense in
other words everybody here or any
anybody anybody who pays taxes in New
Hampshire is
funding this program for 10,500
uh state employees at taxpayer expense
the reason that was done is they needed
to create a a a base pool otherwise the
program could have never got off the
ground what's happened since then is
other public sector unions or what I I
predicted what would happen would be
other public sector unions would demand
the same kind of a deal uh that because
the state workers would given the
program for nothing um for the fmli
actually turns into a public sector and
employment uh employee entitlement plan
paid for by the taxpayers and actually
I'll get into some numbers but that is
actually starting to happen uh the some
of the data I got through a 91a request
says 23 public employers have actually
program um I will be passing out a
very detailed package for everybody and
it's got a lot more information and I'm
not going to go through the 23 public
employers that have actually signed up
for it yet I will say one thing I'm not
I haven't been able to determine in
these these PL uh public employers
whether or not the taxpayers paying for
it or the individuals within the
Public's um employee groups are paying
that has not been determined but we do
know 10,500 state employees are having
their uh fmli Insurance paid for by the
taxpayers
so why is fmll failing I I know you'll
hear testifying uh that we'll say it's
not I I can guarantee you uh with the
numbers I'm going to give you it'll
prove that it is in fact is failing
um during some of my previous testimony
I stated that private employers are not
going to pay premiums for
employees and incentivize their
employees not to work and the re recent
covid experience was a prime example of
that we have a very high very low
unemployment rate and businesses are
unable to find working workers as it is
why would an employer pay for a program
private employer pay for a program that
gives his
employee um P paid time
off and many employers already offer
some form of a paid leave or a
combination of personal days sick days
vacation days so they don't need
fmli so here are the numbers
this was received from the Department of
administrative services this past
December so
10,500 now keep in mind this program's
been up and running now for three
years number of state employees paid for
by New Hampshire taxpayers
10,500 public sector employees that are
part of the plan
244 private employees and EMP or
employers and employees 276 six
employers for a grant total of
5,800
employees private individuals
1152 now the state has a total employed
of somewhere around
753 th000
people the private individuals which was
fmli they wanted they used the base of
the state tax uh the state employees to
get private employers and private
employees to sign
up after 3
years the total
program less than 2.5% of the state's
employees are covered by this
1.4% now state employees I'm sorry 1.4%
the private employees less than 1% less
than 1% of this the state after a total
years costs well the original uh RFP to
get the program up and running $1.9
million advertising alone $1.9 million
I'm sure many of you have heard ads on
the uh radios talking about this and
somewhere around $2 million annually uh
for the unnegotiable
benefit for the state
employees for the 1100 IND individuals
private sector that they've enrolled so
far just on the advertisement and and
getting
this program up and
running works out to about $3,300 per
employee that's a heck of a lot of money
to spend on a program um to get
1152 private sector
employees into a
program going
forward private insurance already exists
for those who want it and that's called
short-term
disability the other option employees
can
self-insure this requires savings and
fiscal dis discipline but uh for many I
guess it's easier to get somebody else
to pay for it and that's what this fmli
program has
become my favorite option would be to
Simply remove all the taxpayer funding
for the state employees let them pay for
it if they want it but again as I
mentioned before this won't work because
that would be an opt opt-in si uh system
and without forced taxpayer involvement
it simply won't work and that leads us
to the best and fiscally and most
fiscally sane option and that is simply
to kill a program and get the taxpayers
fully off the hook for this
entitlement
program going to conclude with just a
couple more
points something to keep in
mind um I don't know how many online
support or against you've seen on this
but I can I can tell you from recent
experience that those who are talking
about this many of them I'll use the
word ignorant because they're not dumb
they're not stupid but they're ignorant
of what the actual FMLA
is and I'm going to give you the example
that I got into a discussion with on a
Our Town Facebook page theyve in the
individual said how can you dare remove
this
program if as my husband experience
during covid he was out of work for six
weeks without this fmli program we would
have not had the money to sustain our
food our
housing and I said well there's only a
one little problem with this fmli was
know and she goes well my husband my
husband actually received benefits I go
well who did your husband work for if
he's under
fmli and at that point she decided to
depart the conversation well it was
discovered what she was actually talking
about was unemployment
insurance so uh I would just caution um
when you hear individuals talking about
this program it's a very detailed
program I've been dealing it with it
since the felus days along with uh is it
full commissioner labors now or it's
Deputy I know Deputy
Commissioners since 2017 2018 so
um again the only way you make a program
like this is to either Force everybody
in uh the op just don't simply don't
work um the the packet I'm going to hand
out has a lot several past news articles
in it uh they're in chronic
chronological order so you can see the
progression um I'll call it the hopes
and dreams of many and how this was
going to be a great system and it's
turned out to be a total failure
um we also note that any testimony you
hear today from the deputy commiss or
any employee of uh any of these
departments is currently covered by this
mind exec one of the quotes I found in
here from executive counselor Joe Kenny
I think it's perfect and he made this
during the initial funding debate uh
debate and vote and he said New
Hampshire is small enough and Nimble
enough to take a kind of Quasi pilot
pilot program to see where a program
like this could go we'll see how it goes
we hang on to good things and we let the
bad things go this is a bad thing it's
time to let it go it's time to squash
the program let's get New Hampshire's P
taxpayers who have already paid $8
million at a minimum so far into this
program for a failed idea let's get them
off the hook and with that I'd be happy
to take any
questions representative Sullivan thanks
for taking my question so I'm just um
not super familiar with this
you said that there are approximately
1100 private sector employees that are
covered under the plan is that correct
Statewide I think you should 1100 a
little
over private individuals
1152 and uh private individuals under an
employer plan it's all this will all be
in here so you can look at it of 5800 so
you've got a total of 6,000 in the
entire state after three years of the
program another question
further question me inquire so okay I'm
just um is this because I'm I'm confused
you said that this would not work if
everybody if it was opt in is is the
reason it's not working is because it is
currently opt in with the exception of
the the the state which is G giving it
to everybody that's correct if you
didn't have the
10,500 uh state employees being uh using
that as their base pool for the entire
program again being paid for the state
taxpayers without that the the amount of
money that each of these individuals
pays or the employer pays on their
behalf would not sustain the program
it's impossible to do one one more
question for question inquire um okay
so if we're looking at the private
sector what you're saying is is the vast
majority have chosen not to
participate that would be the case okay
thank you I I will I will also say one
one of the fiscal notes in there is
pretty interesting we would actually
increase the state's Revenue because
under this current program a portion of
the business Enterprise tax that a
business plays they pays they get a
credit if they um sign up for the
program and there are 276 employers for
those 5,800 employees uh so we would
representative
Gibbs um thank you um I have another why
question um and that is why you would
you want to make it difficult to
impossible for
workers to care for family members who
are ill I'm thinking of elderly parents
I'm thinking of young children um and
I'm thinking of PE workers who live
paycheck to paycheck and therefore could
not possibly
self-insure and of course disability
insurance covers your own disability it
doesn't cover uh when your elderly
parents or your young children are sick
so why would you want to make it
difficult to impossible for people to
care for their families thank that's not
the intent of the legis of my my bill my
bill is to repal the bill the fmli
program so taxpayers aren't on the hook
for for for 10,500 state employees at a
cost of over $2 million a year that's
do representa Ammon thank you Mr chair
thank you representative turot for your
testimony um if if we hypothetically if
we did repeal the program are there
private options that the state could use
to have the same coverage for their
employees actually there are um I think
I mentioned in the testimony and
actually jog my memory on something um
yeah uh private insurers actually offer
short-term disability insurance you know
the the level of what they do is
proportional or what they cover is
proportional to what your rate would be
you know in those back during the feltus
attempt uh we had a member on our
committee at the time who was actually
had his own uh insurance and I think at
the time he was paying like $60 every
two weeks weeks for the program or $120
a month now that gives you an idea
somebody asked about um you know the the
the individual employers and without the
us paying for the tax uh with taxpayers
for the state employees why the program
would fail and that's because the
private some of these private
individuals are only paying
$5 every every week for a program that's
$240 a year you take $240 a year that's
20 uh somebody gets into a program they
can pull out I forget the number we've
looked at it at one time it was like
five grand or something you know put in
very little money so without the the
pool um that happens also in the packet
that I gave you is a letter from
somebody in the insurance department at
the time when this uh fmli was being
discussed and it talks
about um she was saying she didn't say
we don't need need the fmli program but
what she was saying was we already have
uh Insurance um agent uh insurance
carriers looking to provide short-term
disability so yes that that does exist
and there's a great letter in there for
you representative meler uh thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question sure um I think the way you are
presenting the taxpayers paying for this
I think it's somewhat misleading if my
understanding is the taxpayers are not
paying the premiums the benefit we're
probably paying for the administration
of the plan so could you make that clear
that taxpayers are not paying uh Joe
Smith's premium for his family leave
that's exactly what the New Hampshire
taxpayers are doing we're paying for
their premiums for the program
absolutely that's exactly what we're
doing just a little bit for the question
he he is
correct so if you're going to follow up
on this question yes that that it is uh
in this case their
employer is the state of New Hampshire
okay and just like it's an opt-in plan
for
employers yes we opted in for our state
employees in Senate bill to okay
representative
sharesa thank you for taking a question
so is my assumption correct that uh is
my assumption correct that uh
most of the employers who participate
they're only state employer and not
private
employers
275 employers have signed up I heard an
ad on NPR coming in this morning
private yeah that's correct 200 uh
chairman Hunt is correct 276 employers
have signed up over three years of
advertising
for a total of 5,800 employees which
represent less
than 1% of the total employees in our
entire State followup question okay for
the question so one of the reasons why
you want to repeal is as you mentioned
that you this will remove the business
Enterprise tax credit for the plan so if
the business Enterprise tax credit is
that the question then only a fraction
of the employers are enrolling in this
how much the state will gain
by not having that this is very the tax
revenue question that that I don't know
I don't know the actual dollar figure
thank
you okay so just to answer that the idea
is that an employer can deduct as an
expense the payroll expenses which is
could be health insurance so you're
treating this as an health insurance so
that too is allowable to be
deducted representative Gibbs thank you
Mr chair uh those short-term disabil
those private short-term disability
policies that you mentioned do they
cover short-term disability of family
members I I think it would depend on the
actual plan I I'm not an
insurance expert so I'm not sure I'm not
so I'm not going to say yes or
no so with that we thank you very much
thank you okay um I have only opposition
to this Bill yes and so before I invite
you all up to speak um I will have the
tag team departments here evidently you
guys both fill out a card or maybe uh so
rich lovers and and DJ and kathri Keane
and
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee for the record my name is DJ
bonc Court I am the commissioner of the
New Hampshire insurance department I'm
joined here at the
table by my other Amigos Cassie Keane
over at the department of administrative
services and Rich labors who you heard
is the Deputy Commissioner of Employment
Security I am here today and on behalf
of my department am officially opposed
to this legislation I've tried to
intersperse throughout my testimony
a number of clarifying points to the
testimony that you just heard and
Corrections so hopefully by the time I'm
done we'll have addressed the questions
and concerns that you may have so as I
said Mr chairman I come today in strong
support of the Paid Family and Medical
Leave program and in opposition to any
effort to oppose it I would say at the
outset Mr chairman that the sponsor
mentioned that all of us are enjoying
this benefit I would highlight Mr
chairman that I'm an unclassified
employee I have as much time off as I
need I don't need this benefit thank you
very much I still do my job so I want to
clarify that at the outset and look you
know I have great respect for
representative turot we've worked
together on a number of different issues
he and I simply have a fundamental
different definition of success and
failure you know I approached this issue
through the lens of individual liberty
personal responsibility and the
fundamental tenets of economic Freedom
those are principles that as you know I
have long championed as you also may
recall given the history of this issue
you know this issue for two decades
finding a viable Paid Family Medical
Leave program for New Hampshire was an
unresolved puzzle there were a lot of
proposals there was a lot of controversy
over that period of time and the state
in the N the past several years took a
trailblazing approach which really
followed the New Hampshire tradition of
tackling policy issues in innovative
ways while also avoiding the missteps or
problematic practices of what other
states have done in this area and again
I think that this program
exemplifies that commitment so I want to
just briefly and as I said I'm going to
hit these points as I go through here in
terms of the quote unquote cost to the
state so it is true that we are
providing the benefit to State Employees
the state employees form the basis the
foundation of the risk pool the reason
that you did not have prior to this
program a private sector if you will uh
range of options for this coverage is
because insurance carriers could not
adequately determine what the takeup
rate of a voluntary Paid Family Medical
Leave product would be and so because
they did not have a basis of what that
Foundation risk pool would look like
they could not derive actuarially
appropriate actuarially sustainable
rates given that uncertainty and so by
having the state employees approximately
10,000 in number serve as the foundation
of that risk pool the carrier was then
able to go through that Actuarial
analysis to derive that rate and then to
make that benefit available to all who
want it and not fo it upon anybody who
does not want
it so first and foremost let's recognize
the essential purpose of this program
Paid Family Medical Leave is designed to
provide critical support during some of
life's most significant moments events
that in many cases are unforeseen and in
many cases are incredibly difficult for
individuals and families to go through
as insurance professionals we understand
that personal and economic risks are an
inherent part of our society and that
appropriate coverage is necessary to
address them this program is founded and
grounded in solid risk management
principles it pulls resources delivering
voluntary support to those in need while
protecting individual insurers and
businesses from overwhelming
costs this is fundamentally a free
market approach that Fosters stability
allow allowing our partner in this case
metti who the state contracted with a
large well-experienced insurance company
that is partnered with the state to
administer the program to create
competitive pricing models based on real
data and let me say too the benefit of
having MetLife administer this program
and Contracting and partnering with
MetLife is that MetLife retains all of
the risk of the
program so again I disagree with
representative turkot that this program
has been a failure but let's assume that
the experience which by the way has not
in any way borne out to this point let's
say that the experience begins to go
sideways that the premiums become
inadequate to cover the claims that's
not a risk that the state of New
Hampshire is bearing that is a risk that
metti is bearing we are not on the hook
should for any reason and again it's not
happening but for any reason if the
program begins to wobble financially
MetLife owns that problem not the
state so again this is a structured
program that promotes healthy
competition which we have seen we have
seen it through other carriers offering
supplemental products offering certain
pieces of this program while not doing
the whole package and meti just two
weeks ago offered an additional benefit
for mental health within this program so
they're innovating even within the
confines of this
program the result of all of that has
been to keep the premiums low and
affordable for both employers employees
and individuals you know it's
interesting when we began this program
one of the big concerns we heard was
that for individuals the premiums were
going to be poten po too expensive for
them to afford those who are on the
lower socioeconomic end of uh the scale
in our state and so we capped the
premiums for the individual pool at no
more than $5 per pay
week and I thought to myself at the time
well I know exactly what metti is going
to do they're going to go right to the
cap they're not going to do the
underwriting practices that would
traditionally go into setting a premium
for these people but okay we created a
mechanism to make sure that that $5 per
pay week was going to be sustainable
well I was wrong MetLife has gone
through the appropriate underwriting
process and the average premium in the
individual pool is actually below the $5
per paye cap so again I think it's
speaks to the financial viability and
experience of the program thus
far Mr chairman repealing this program
would inject uncertainty into the
marketplace now that consumers and
businesses have come to rely on this
coverage and I think the sponsor did
speak to that that there are people who
are relying on this coverage it could
potentially lead to increases in claims
on short-term disability I'm going to
talk about short-term disability in a
moment because that was brought up quite
a bit and potentially Workers
Compensation Insurance causing premiums
uh to incre increase for those two
products and I do not think that we can
afford to be increasing that burden on
our businesses or our families let's
talk for a moment about short-term
disability so I think as a number of you
brought up
previously short-term disability is a
different benefit than what this program
offers short-term disability is for you
you as an individual get sick again not
hurt on the job that's workers comp
that's a separate matter you get a bad
diagnosis you get hurt in a non-work
related incident the short-term
disability covers you it does not cover
your ability to take leave to take care
of a family member who is ill or the
result of having a child or adjusting to
a military deployment that is not
covered under short-term disability
there was some concern at the time that
this program was was created that it
would eviscerate short-term
disability and instead what would happen
is everybody would gravitate toward this
program didn't happen short-term
disability coverage in the state remains
very very competitive and in fact the
program is flexible enough that
employers can keep their current
short-term disability coverage and work
with MetLife to get a skinny down
version of this program
that will cover just the coverage for if
you need to take care of a family member
and we have a prominent business in the
state who has done exactly that and the
cost for him to add this coverage on top
of his short-term disability benefit is
unbelievably affordable very very
affordable working very very well for
that that business I also want to be
clear that New Hampshire's approach here
is being mimicked but at the time it was
UN paralleled in the nation while other
states were imposing mandatory programs
that needed to be subsidized with
punitive taxes we carved out an
Innovative approach in a market oriented
path that supports our Workforce without
strangling those employers with new
costs it's no accident that my phone
frequently rings from the offices in in
Governor's offices and legislatures in
places like Florida Governor desantis's
office was calling me every other week
for a good period of time wanting to
know how we designed the program how the
experience was going thus far uh before
she became a cabinet secretary Governor
gnome in South Dakota was calling us
quite frequently we'd also heard from
the governor's offices in Iowa Kansas
and Louisiana all wanting to understand
how we had approached this how it was
going high degree of interest on their
part to potentially bring this model to
their state
I would also mention that the program
serves as a strategic tool for
attracting top talent in retaining top
talent and as you know in today's
competitive job market companies that
offer these types of benefits stand out
I will tell you from personal experience
I live in Salem to borrow a phrase I can
see Massachusetts from my
house and our Employers in
Salem in all of the communities along
the New Hampshire border have a really
tough road to hoe because they've got to
compete with Massachusetts they've got
to compete with the Boston
Market now there are obvious and smart
benefits to working in New Hampshire
versus
Massachusetts but this current
generation of Workforce has different
expectations and values different things
than the generations of the past you
know my parents and my parents
generation they stayed with one employer
their entire career they collected a
pension they retired this current
generation values work life balance they
want a wide diversity of benefits to
take advantage of they're a little bit
more Mobile in their careers and I think
that this program has served as a
valuable tool to the business Community
to be competitive for Workforce to again
retain and attract uh this critical new
generation of Workforce that they're
going to need in order for not only them
as a business to be successful but
economically for the state to continue
to be
successful there's been a lot of talk
about the tax credit component of this I
want to bring Clarity to that issue the
business is entitled to a business tax
credit for 50% of the premium that they
pay for their
employees for this benefit so I just
want to be clear about that
so the the cost we have not seen hit the
general fund in any significant way thus
far I think if it had you'd probably see
Dr here in the room and they're not
here so again Mr chairman repealing this
program would jeopardize in my opinion
our state's economic Edge as businesses
evaluate where to invest and grow and
why are they looking at this benefit
well again it's about retain retaining
and attracting Workforce but as the
representative mentioned uh a number of
businesses are self we
self-insuring this particular benefit
and so this program has allowed them to
get a financial benefit as a result of
that which I think is a good thing for
our business Community allowing them to
enjoy some of the benefit of offering a
coverage that their employees want and
need so in summary members of the
committee the pat Family Leave program
strengthens our economic
situation here in New Hampshire and
supports individuals and families it
embodies our commitment to community
resilience while driving a competitive
Insurance
Market um interestingly I heard that
there was a concern that other public
employers were suddenly motivated to
offer this benefit because the state was
doing it I assume the term public
employers means
municipalities uh to which I would say I
a a strong adherent to the de Hampshire
tradition of local
control and so if communities want to
make decisions as to what benefit
offerings they're going to extend to
their employees that's going to be up to
them and I'm not sure why the state
would be trying to dictate what they can
or can't offer in terms of benefits to
their employees so the local control
piece for me Still Remains quite
prevalent as it pertains to that
particular point
the last point that I'll make and I'll
turn it over to my colleagues is the
idea of enrollment so let's remember at
the end of the day that this is a
commercial product this is not a
mandatory program we have not had to
employ an army of state employees to run
this
program it is available to all who want
it it is not forced upon any who do not
so therefore it is fundamentally a
commercial product and so I've asked a
number of insurance carriers to look at
the enrollment numbers for this program
and I have asked them if you were
rolling out a product for the first time
and you had this type of
enrollment how would you feel about that
and their response was for a firsttime
program and by the way the numbers for
the employer side of things yes the
program has been in existence for three
years very important to note that the
first of the program it came online I
believe in December or January and for
those of you who have owned or operated
a business you know that you've made
your decisions in terms of what benefits
you're going to offer to your employees
well in advance of December and January
you've probably made those decisions in
September or October so I think in terms
of the employee the business enrollment
you've got to Discount I think that
first year of the program so what you've
left with in terms of again the employee
the employer side of that is really a
two-year experience but again back to my
point I've said to those insurance
carriers if you had this enrollment
within a two to threee time period how
would you feel about that and they have
said that enrollment is
phenomenal it's phenomenal for a
commercial product being rolled out for
the first time in that period of time
that enrollment is incredibly strong so
at at least from an insurance
perspective here again representative
turkot and I and I say this respectfully
have very very different definitions of
success and failure so with that Mr
Kean good morning my name is Cassie
Keane I'm the um Deputy Commissioner of
the Department of administrative
services and uh commissioner beton court
is in charge of the insurance department
and they implemented rules to establish
the commercial product that he's been
talking about but it was the department
of administrative services and the New
Hampshire Employment Security Department
that were charged with implementing the
benefit Statewide and I'm going to talk
to you a little bit about how that
benefit works and rich is going to talk
more about enrollment numbers that the
committee has been interested in um so
I'll start by saying in New Hampshire
there were four state employees who
worked on implementing this benefit it
was rich it was me and it was two other
um individuals at the department of
administrative Services um we did have
consultant support we do have a
marketing vendor because the law
authorized us to uh enlist that support
and required us to promote Outreach and
education about paid family medical
leave as um commissioner beton Court
said this is a unique model for a paid
family medical leave in in our country
this issue is being debated from state
to state and our model is different from
most other models it's voluntary the way
the program works is it requires the law
requires that the state provide coverage
to all state employees to create a
market so that an insurance carrier will
come in and provide this product in our
state thereafter participation in Paid
Family Medical Leave is completely
voluntary an employer can choose to
participate or not to participate an
individual whose employer does not
provide the coverage can choose to
purchase their Pro the coverage on their
own through what we call an individual
pool so that anyone who is a New
Hampshire worker has access one way or
another to Paid Family Medical Leave
coverage it may interest you to know
that there is a federal bipartisan
working group working on paid family
medical leave and one of the models that
they have adopted for presentation and
debate is the state of New Hampshire
model that's what they call it and quite
frankly we're quite proud of that um so
we um the law passed it was House Bill
two right so it passed in June of 21 we
opened enrollment to employers beginning
in December of 22 for coverage and and
employers can enroll at any time and we
did our first open enrollment and
there's an annual open enrollment for
individuals who want to participate
under the law it's a 60-day period in in
in 2022 we we did um open enrollment
from January 1st till 60 days later
sorry can't remember the date now
um we um let's see under the law we were
required to um
cover state employees there are just shy
of 9,000 state employees who are today
receiving that coverage by the way for
state employees in the law it was
actually um designed I think quite
specifically to take into account that
state employees already have that
first-person coverage that the
commissioner was talking about we
already provide a form of short-term
disability income protection for state
employees so state employees only have
paid family medical leave okay that
means that they can um submit a claim if
they have a family member who has a
serious medical condition and they need
to be absent from work or if there is a
deployment in their family either to
help someone prepare for that deployment
or in the event of illness or injury it
their their um absence from work and
their wage replacement benefits go into
effect so they can help take care of
that family
member um we as I mentioned charged with
promoting this um this product
throughout the state and um we worked
very hard we have a very wonderful
website if you go on nh.gov on the top
left you'll see a nice big button it
says New Hampshire Paid Family Medical
Leave You click on that that brings you
out to our website on that website you
will Prof find copious information about
paid family medical leave and we also
provide that information to a um to an
individual whether they are seeking
coverage for themselves or whether
you're an employer we have employer tool
Cuts we tool kits we have individual
tool kits we have um worked very hard to
promote the plan through um uh we have a
television commercial maybe some of you
have seen it on Channel 9 um I tend to
see it on Saturday Sunday mornings
before a closeup and um we've also
promoted it through radio spots radio
interviews we've spoken with the
business business and industry
Association we've gone to many chambers
of Commerce uh we're on social media
we've at we've attended and had um
sponsored fishercat games uh thrown out
first pitches um and um we have also
been at the Glendy and um I'm even one
out one major thing we did
uh um job fairs job fairs and we we
recently went to the municipal
association annual meeting and had a
breakout session on paid family medical
leave so we've worked very hard very
diligently to meet our responsibility
under the law to get the work out and um
we are proud of the enrollment in this
plan and what it reflects is that it's a
voluntary plan and that's what we chose
for our state and we believe it's been
quite successful so I'm going to turn it
over to Rich for him to cover the
to dance here um Mr chairman I had a
handout I'll hand over here and we can
commissioner um so I I'll quickly and
again Richard L's Deputy Commissioner uh
with the New Hampshire Department of
Employment Security tasked along with
admin services and operationalizing the
program so I'll talk to enrollment on
what we've seen um and um can obviously
answer any questions about that I know
that some of the numbers that
representative turkot have has provided
uh will be different um but I think uh
they're obviously point in time numbers
um but also some of his numbers might um
uhu not represent exactly what he was
describing them to represent so um any
discrepancies between those two would be
more than happy to address
that um one other state um uh that is
also um uh borrowed in and stealing what
New Hampshire has done is our neighbor
to the west uh Vermont um is now doing
um exactly what New Hampshire has done
um including creating an individual
option so um uh that's uh the the best
form of flattery um when someone steals
your good ideas so um as those handouts
make it around um I'll just again just a
few slides here with numbers the first
one uh just a chart showing our current
enrollment the number of workers with uh
New Hampshire Paid Family Medical Leave
available to them you'll see that we
have just over
23,600 New Hampshire workers who have
this coverage available to them this
includes the 88 um 100 State of New
Hampshire employees that have it as an
employer provided benefit um as the
sponsor had uh described um but but we
also have just over
13,300 um workers with both public and
private New Hampshire employers that
have chosen to voluntarily sponsor
coverage and make this benefit available
to their workers um lastly in this chart
you can see just over
1,400 individuals so uh in New Hampshire
we have the individual plan where you
can purch purch your own coverage we'll
get into that a little bit more um but
we have 1,400 individual workers who did
not have this coverage available to them
through their employer so they chose to
purchase it on their own at that maximum
weekly amount that commissioner beton
Court had described of $5 per week so th
those are the current um numbers for New
Hampshire workers that have this
available to them when we flip the page
there's a little bit more detail on the
employers that have chosen to sponsor
coverage um we have um 308 New Hampshire
employers uh that have sponsored
coverage U
85% of those uh employers that have
sought this out are smaller employers
meaning they have fewer than 50
workers the uh information on the bottom
of that uh page you'll see in the bar
chart um you see some detail on the
individual benefit um one of the I think
the real uh wins for the New Hampshire
program is what New Hampshire has been
able to provide to those workers who
have no other option in accessing this
type of coverage and so you can see here
a little bit more about those
individuals that have chosen to purchase
coverage and what we have um experienced
thus far with those 1,400 individuals
that have that have chosen to purchase
they are largely women uh they are
largely young women and it should come
as no surprise that these young women
who have no other option for paid leave
from their employer who chose to
purchase this they are by and large
taking this in order to spend time with
a newborn child so 75% of those
individuals are women uh 67% under the
age of 45 and nearly 80% of them are
utilizing this leave which they have
decided is important to them they are
using this to bond with a newborn or
newly adopted
child when we flip the page for the last
um um two charts you can see some
detailed on utilization across all three
coverage types so both the state of New
Hampshire workers um and how they are
currently using it very low utilization
for the State of New Hampshire workers
um you'll see how the individuals who
have purchased this how they're
utilizing the benefit again 80% of the
leave is for bonding with a newborn
child um and then in the employer
sponsored coverage at the bottom of that
chart you see a little bit more of a
balanced picture for what individuals
who have the coverage through their
employer and how they're utilizing the
benefit so there you've got 46% of those
workers are utilizing it or 46% that
file a claim again utilization very low
in the employer sponsored um uh Market
um but 46% of those claims are for
bonding with a newborn child and
23% of those are for caring for a family
member so commissioner beton Court had
described that another type of coverage
that is not available to a worker who
might have short-term disability
coverage available through their
employer again that's only first person
coverage you don't have the ability to
take that leave with some um um wage
replacement um in order to care for your
spouse for your child for your parent um
all of those are options that are
available through um if you have an New
Hampshire Paid Family Medical Leave
coverage and you can see how that breaks
down yeah I S interrupt you but I'm
having a little trouble because it looks
like two colors is the same I know I
apologize that Mr chairman sometimes
sometimes Adobe and PowerPoint don't
behave so I'm going to just take it as
the lower one so like for instance the
state of New Hampshire coverage the 66
is actually child bonding correct yeah
um and then in I should have mentioned
in that in state of New Hampshire you
only see two types of leave being taken
because it's the individual as Deputy
Commissioner Keane had mentioned that's
all that New Hampshire provides to its
employers because we an existing
short-term disability um program thank
you sorry um and then and lastly and
again sorry about uh that blending of
the colors um and then lastly you see in
that bottom slide um just some
information on the individual open
enrollment that we just completed so
every uh Year from uh the beginning of
December through the end of January we
do as the law requires we do a 60-day
open enrollment for individuals again
these are individual individuals who
work in New Hampshire they do not have
comparable coverage available to them
through their employer and they are then
eligible to purchase that coverage on
their own so that 60-day open enrollment
that we just completed we had nearly a
thousand applications come in and we now
have an enrollment picture in that
individual program that is going to
likely be north of 1,800 individuals so
some some of those are still being
reviewed by MetLife they need to confirm
what types of coverage the employers
have to confirm that they are in fact
eligible um but again nearly so you got
a thousand individuals who came in
during a relatively short window and we
have an enrollment in that individual
benefit of over 1,800 individuals um
that are now able to have this coverage
so um we thought that you know seeing
some of those numbers and what that take
up has been in a purely voluntary model
um would be helpful as you uh evaluate
the legislation that you have before you
thank
[Laughter]
you okay representative Sullivan start
with you thank you Mr chair uh thanks
for taking my question so I think I
think what I'm I I understand the
sponsor of this of this legislation I I
think his issue with it is that the
people people the approximately 8800
people from New Hampshire are getting it
for free and that seems to be what is
upsetting him
um but I'm I'm curious one of the things
he said is without them this program
would not be viable so is this the Crux
of the issue that we're dealing with or
is this something that could be rather
than throwing out the whole bill maybe
it could be tweaked to make them have to
pay some share or something like I'm
curious what the options are here and
and and maybe you could answer if if
there weren't 8800 people let's stick to
the that that fundamental question let's
we have everybody else wants to ask
questions already noon let's try to be
short and sweet I guess to really narrow
the question down for someone who was
around when this legislation history of
this
legislation how many of do you know how
many of the employers are actually
paying it directly or actually deducting
it from the employees
paycheck so rich probably has those
numbers just very briefly Mr chairman to
representative Sullivan's Point yes it
is in fact the case as I described in my
testimony the approximately 9 10,000
state employees are necessary for the
program to then be offered to the rest
of thetical mass yes you needed that
foundational risk pool for what
eventually became metti to be able to
then
derive an appropriate actuarially
sound basis to to set premiums at so you
need those individuals again to make the
rest of the program work I appreciate
the fact that he objects to the to to
this being paid for for those
employees I would mention that I once
did the numbers and Cassie can probably
uh correct me if I'm wrong I once did
the math and it represents somewhere in
the range of 0.3 to 0 6% of the total
cost of the benefits that the state of
New Hampshire offers to State
Employees I understand that the state is
working through a difficult economic
time I don't know that you're going to
solve a ton of problems with that 03 to
0 6% savings at the expense of the
benefit that this program offers to the
state but that's my opinion thanks for
the uh answer um and Mr chairman to
answer your question the employers that
are sponsoring coverage 70% of them are
paying for the full premium so that's 24
of those sponsoring employers uh 20% are
are having their workers pay for it um
in any situ in any time the employer
sponsors but has the worker contribute
any portion to the premium the workers
have a choice whether they want to do
that or not oh really cuz that wasn't
part of the original plan no so they
have a they they choose to opt in or opt
out yeah so that's another layer of this
how this is voluntary okay great um and
then the other 10% are split that's a a
shared model shared model where the
employer and the worker are each picking
up a part but again those workers would
have the choice great and then the a
number of employers that offered um a
short-term disability plan um that are
now offering this um or rather the
employers that did not offer short-term
disability coverage is about 66% so
two-thirds of the sponsoring employers
had no short-term disability prior to um
deciding to offer this and I can almost
guarantee you that if you're an employer
and not offering short-term disability
then you probably do not offer a family
caregiving benefit either so new
coverage for all those workers great
represent walls did you have your hand
up seemed like everybody over there had
their hand up thank you Mr chair uh
representative Sullivan covered some of
it but as a follow on to solve this or I
I'll reword it how what is the taxpayer
dollar amount that is being paid for for
this the
8,826 uh state employees that receive
this benefit for free do you have that
number I I do um in I have the fiscal
year 24 total expenditure was 1. 1452
million to cover all state employees all
government okay representative
Speer okay representative
buroughs okay representative M I'm just
GNA go around uh yes just to I think
what I asked my question earlier of
Representative turot turo I didn't quite
get it through so it's true that
taxpayers pay 100% of this benefit but
they also pay 100% of their salary and
everything else so this is not that much
different would you believe would you
believe thank
you okay thank you Mr chair thank you
for your testimony today uh just
focusing in on the advertising budget I
think I heard the number 1.9 million is
that did I hear
right and and so just question about
that is there are you tracking Roi on
your advertising uptake versus spending
and is there you know trends that you're
you're tracking can we see that data
so so um I I'm looking at my budget
numbers from fiscal year 22 and 23 which
are our implementation years um we had
an appropriation of of 700,000 in22 and
1.7 million
in23 um we we actually only spent 1.3
million in in 23 that's what I would
call Administration um representative
mcclear was was referring to as I
mentioned we worked with a consultant
during imp
mation um and we do have a marketing
vendor that's helped us place the media
that I mentioned just quick follow
question uh and so you're tracking uh
the uptake for dollar spent and it's the
state spending the money not the carrier
the car so you're advertising a product
for a a private company it is correct
that the state is responsible and paying
for the marketing and Outreach yes we
are TR we are tracking how many
individuals we reach with different
kinds of um initiatives the TV
commercial social media that kind of
thing and then ultimately we have our
enrollment data that rich referred
to yes it' be great to have that
great representative yeah thank you for
um taking my question so I was wondering
now that the program is up and running
is there any um interest desire or um
next steps to have employ employees the
state employees contribute to this
program so I want to make sure I
understand they're not contributing
they're contributing zero for the
benefit now in the future is it possible
to ask them to start to contribute to
this benefit is my question is it
possible sure that would have to be
hashed out in a collective bargaining
negotiation which again speaking to
representative Sullivan's point the
reason we simply offered the benefit to
State Employees was because we wanted to
get the program up and running and and
we didn't want to potentially get bogged
down in that collective bargaining
process so if you have a desire to see
the state employees begin to contribute
identify the members of the negotiating
team on behalf of the state and you can
put a bug in their ear on that my memory
was that when we did it the the state
employees hadn't had a raise in like
four or five years but prior to this was
actually sort
of of a raise it had been quite some
time time to my recollection and
obviously in the last
race and didn't calculate this I guess
representative Gibs did you have a
question um just um to uh clarify um at
the time when this was when this came
into effect um the state employees had
not had a raise so this was in in effect
in L of a
raise no I don't think that's exactly
that is true it is not it was not in L
of a raise it was just happened happen
stance but and it was just the beginning
of Co
too okay representative sharesa so uh
thank you foring a question uh my qu
this seems like a excellent program my
question is that as the representative
who sponsor the bill he was mentioning
that only 5% of the private employers is
participating currently so can you throw
some light why the enrollment is so low
from private employers and what can be
done to make it more appealing to the
private
employers um yeah thank you for that
question you know the the downside of
having a voluntary program is not
everyone makes the choice that you want
them to make right um and what you want
them to make not what I wanted to make
when we had this bill um so we we've
done as the law has required and we've
toured the state talking with as many
chambers and um employer associations
and small groups and large groups as we
as we can um to talk about this program
that's available to them so um employers
make their own choices um they decide
what's important for them for
Recruitment and Retention and um those
employers that um have uh U decided that
this would be um a good tool for them to
help attract and retain workers have
purchased the coverage others are
looking into it they might offer a
short-term disability um and you know
they will uh continue to be education
and Outreach that is done um and that
number will continue to grow um what it
will grow too I don't know um but that
again that's the uh the um the the part
of it being voluntary um we'll be
continue to provide that education
employers will continue to make their
own decisions on what they want to do
thank you represent okay we're all set
oh yes representative said uh thank you
chair for taking my question are you
adding the cost of the the person is on
long-term leave okay during this benefit
so somebody else is doing that work are
we adding that cost also into the
calculation because somebody else is
doing the work that person will not do
any other
work yeah I I think think I think
employers when they when they look at
sponsoring this type of coverage and and
providing paid benefits in general they
weigh that right um so here we're
talking about six weeks of coverage uh
for most plans employers that do sponsor
they can increase that to um mirror the
FMLA protection of 12 weeks um but I
think most employers look at this um and
they balance the cost of the employee
not being there uh to the cost of losing
that employee when they go out to have a
baby to bond with with a new child to
care for a family member I think one of
the Lessons Learned in Co was not
wanting to to lose that connection to
your employees and this helps them
maintain that
connection yeah I would say that when we
took up this legislation that issue did
come up um in terms of you know that you
know the the employer you know and that
was one of the reasons why this
committee insisted this be a volunteer
plan rather than a mandatory plan but I
would say do have in a statute that um
you can't fire an employee who is taking
leave because of having a
baby right and now the job protection is
only that which is already in place for
the federal family medical leave this
doesn't expand that or change it any
exactly didn't but that was already on
the books so be clear okay thank you
very much
okay um needs to say uh we're we're past
the the lunch hour um I've have the last
bill you know he's going to come back
later um so uh every one of you here uh
is opposed to this bill and we certainly
understand that um this committee did
you know to take the position uh that
that it wanted it was supported the bill
on the circumstance that it was
voluntary um so uh having said that I
guess is please you know when you come
up and testify because we always want to
let everybody have an opportunity to
speak
but if you can find something new
otherwise you can get up here and say
you know please do not do this you know
don't pass this bill that would be good
too but that um I mostly your two to
three minutes and if we do that we're
going to be here another half hour so so
uh Laura milin New Hampshire hungry
Solutions and have written testimony
you have to push the button there you
afternoon chairman hunt and honorable
members of the committee my name is
Laura milikin I'm the executive director
of New Hampshire hunger
Solutions uh we are a small
nonprofit um we are one of the private
employers who uh gladly pay the premiums
um for the New Hampshire the uh New
Hampshire plan we um
are able
to hire and retain employees because we
can offer a competitive benefits package
we could not have been we would not have
been able to afford it uh without this
plan being in place um we have eight
employees uh we offer them 12 weeks of
leave through the plan we pay all of the
premiums um and we think it's a good
deal um because it allows us to attract
excellent employees um and uh to date
three employees have used the benefit
two of them were uh young women who um
took the leave to care for their
children um both of them had
complications during their pregnancies
and also needed to be able to heal
during that time it was absolutely
critical um and then my one other
employee um had to take leave to take
care of her mother who got cancer um and
they were able to get through those
those Hard Times without worrying about
uh being able to make ends meet um and
that was uh absolutely critical for them
uh and they came back and that was what
was absolutely critical to us um so uh I
will just say that the plan is um very
important to nonprofits like mine um and
to the health both of our employees
throughout the state so I urge you to
vote uh in expedient to legislate on uh
HB
517 thank you very much thank you uh
Nancy
Glenn thank you shair and members of the
committee my name is Nancy Glenn I'm
from Sutton New Hampshire I am also a
select board member for my town this
kind of feels like a Deja Vu moment for
me because the first time I ever
testified on a bill was for Paid Family
Medical Leave thus I would like to think
that I would not be considered ignorant
when it comes down to what this bill
looks like um I shared my story publicly
including with Governor sununu um about
my son who is going to be 13 in April
god um who was born premature and he
experiences chronic health conditions
and a disability I also shared a story
about my second son who unfortunately
passed away shortly after he was born he
was also premature and I had some
complications during birth um this is
affected me in my family drastically um
both physically and mentally but
thousands of people right now in New
Hampshire currently stand to lose this
program um many local municipalities
like mine um we offer um we were able to
offer this to our employees to help keep
our local property taxes down it's an
incredibly affordable program we have 26
employees in Sutton thus we do not
qualify for the federal FMLA job
protection coverage um we spend about
$6,6 per year to be able to cover all of
our folks we did the buy up plan to 12
weeks and we cover again the entire cost
and this equates to just cents on the
dollar for our local taxpayers a couple
months ago we had an employee out
because of side effects from a brain
injury that they received from a car
accident and they were able to utilize
this program right now we have a
transfer station employee who is on
leave because he had to get surgery on
his eyes and he also has access to this
program and in a few months Our Town
Administrator will be taking it to be
able to care for their wife in
newborn all have the option to utilize
this program um I just wanted to amplify
that small business in small towns we
can't afford this on our own and our
wages really aren't that great because
of how high taxes are and having
affordable benefits like this helps us
to attract Workforce which is Again
difficult for small towns and um a
younger Workforce for that matter um
that are more likely to accept a lower
salary for more
benefits my personal story clearly
motivated me to want to make sure that
my town employees had access to paid
filing medical leave and I'm incredibly
grateful that the state has created a
program that people like me could have
accessed this back in the day when I was
when I had my
kiddos but I just wanted to sit up here
and just say like let's not remove
something that does good for Granite
State Staters and something that helps
local municipalities like mine be able
to offer a benefit to their employees so
I am here to ask you to also vote in
expedient to legislate on
um 517 thank
hi chairman hunt and members of the
committee my name is Devin Quinn I'm the
director of policy at the New Hampshire
women's Foundation uh we uh also oppose
this bill but um I would like to um read
to you uh portions of a letter from two
employers who couldn't be here today but
wanted to make sure that their voices
were heard as well um first um from Jack
Savage the president of society for the
protection of New Hampshire Forest
writes in um and I'll read a couple
portions not the whole thing the society
for the protection of New Hampshire
Forest is proud to offer the New
Hampshire paid and Paid Family and
Medical Leave program as a benefit for
our eligible employees Forest Society
pays the premiums for this program so
there's no cost for employees um and the
way they've sent it up is that this pres
prevents an employee from depleting
their health leave or PTO balances for
these qualifying life events the annual
premium we pay is $16,000
in 2024 two of our employees utilized
the benefit which amounted to $118,000
in
wages excuse me both the benefit to our
employees and the security of stable
insurance premiums has worked well for
our organization and employees the
forest Society has 40 employees enrolled
in the program our employees report that
this is a huge financial relief to some
who have who would have been made to go
without pay our employees have a level
of comfort knowing they have this option
and as an employer we use this program
as a recruitment and retention tool we
feel this program is not only beneficial
to the individuals who use it but the
organization uh by promoting staff
longevity and loyalty this program is an
important motivator of younger family
starting staff and potential staff who
want to live and work in New Hampshire
rather than seeking employment out of
state as a nonprofit We PRI pride
ourselves on making efficient use of our
revenues which include promoting High
staff retention rates the loss of this
program would set us and the state back
in attracting the best and brightest to
live and work here respectfully Jack
Savage president Society for the
protection of New Hampshire forest and
secondly a letter from Amanda goni osar
the owner and chief Vision officer of
gpon
Automotive uh we wish um we are writing
to express gron automotive's strong
support for New Hampshire's PID family
medical leave program and our opposition
to HB 517 which would repeal repeal this
program gpon has 375 employees or team
members at our bow and conquered
locations and the pfml program is very
important to our team team we have 148
team members who participate in our paid
leave and paid medical leave program
additionally we advertise Paid Family
and Medical Leave benefits on our job
postings and it's part of our robust
benefits package we offer that help us
recruit and retain our excellent team
members we put in much thought into our
benefits program last year to align our
disability insurances with the Paid
Family Medical Leave program we
terminated our short-term disability
program and changed our long-term
disability program to align with the
paid failing medical leave program so
that no one will have any lapses in
their coverage between the two
plans from when we started the program
in September 2023 to today 17 team
members have already utilized or are
currently utilizing the program we also
anticipate two more team members taking
time away in the next few months for
medical leave if paid failing medical
leave were repealed and the program
ceased to exist as early as this year as
hb7 517 prescribes we do not know how we
would accommodate the sudden loss of
benefits it would leave gpon scrambling
to find a new benefits plan and there
would be significant financial
repercussions for our company since we
would honor what we've promised our team
members including those who have already
made plans to take leave uh later this
year our team members are very grateful
that we participate in the program and
this bill would negatively impact our
company and our Workforce it would be a
financial burden to our company and it
would be a huge loss for our team if New
Hampshire's paid forly medical program
ended we ask that you vote in opposition
to this bill uh sincerely amenda gpon
osar that's all I want to read thank you
speeda hello excuse me I don't want to
get in the way of lunch but
um good afternoon I guess now chairman
and committee um I've lived in New
Hampshire since 2017 my name is Adriana
espia I work here I got married here I a
homeowner in nsha and in 2024 I gave
birth to my son here while my employer
does offer some paid parental leave it
does not cover the full 12 weeks of FMLA
um I was exploring options on Google to
cover that unpaid time and discovered
this program I asked my employer to
participate and they did they have less
than 50 employees so I pay MetLife
directly um two of my co-workers have
used it it was extremely helpful to them
I couldn't use it for my first child
since I found out about it too late in
my pregnancy but I've been paying for
over a year since January 2024 in the
hopes that I could use it for future
children I love New Hampshire and my job
but if Paid Family Leave goes away um I
may have to look for a transfer to
either our Boston office or even leave
the state allog together our family
could not afford for me to take unpaid
leave especially with the cost of child
care for my son and our mortgage uh Paid
Family Leave is part of the package of
reason that I enjoy living here in New
Hampshire and working in at a New
Hampshire business um I've been paying
my premiums dutifully I have a reminder
on my phone to do it um just like I pay
my health insurance my car insurance um
and my life insurance uh if this is
repealed then I don't get the benefit or
the product of what I've been paying
into and that is quite frankly not fair
um all those premium payments would be
for nothing and if I had known that this
program was going to go away I would not
have started to pay into it um early
this month my son turned a year old we
celebrated at the common man I consider
him a true Granite stator um so I'm
asking the committee to vote itl to give
me a chance to continue to grow my
family here thank you thank you very
Sears good afternoon chairman hun
members of the committee my name is
Amanda Sears and I'm the director the
New Hampshire state director for the
campaign for familyfriendly economy um I
just will be very brief to say that we
um would ask you to make an itl motion
on this bill um as you've heard there
are you know thousands of granite
Staters who are benefiting from this
program um we in fact believe that what
you should be doing is considering the
opposite um of this bill and expanding
this program so that it covers more
folks um in this and better meets the
needs of New Hampshire families um in
particular I want to point out that this
bill would of course um get rid of this
benefit for New Hampshire state
employees which would be um a you know
again the wrong direction to go to get
rid of this benefit for people who are
relying on it to meet the needs of their
family um as they meet the needs of our
state through their employment so thank
you we do have a question represent
thank you Mr chair thank you for your
testimony are is it your position that
we should consider making this program
mandatory and uh when you said expanding
it what did you mean by that that is my
organization's position
yes she's she's been following this
issue for a very long time thank you
good afternoon chairman hunt and members
of the House Commerce and consumer
affairs committee my name is McKenzie
Nicholson I'm the senior director for
Mom's rising in New Hampshire mom's
Rising is an on the ground Grassroots
organization representing thousands of
moms across the granite state um and I'm
passing around my testimony I'll skip it
because I know we are all excited about
lunch and I'm I'm very hungry too um but
I will share that just hit your inboxes
was is a list of 158 Granite Staters
many from your districts who have
comments about um asking you to please
itl this bill the comments include
things like I work with dementia
caregivers I can I cannot imagine them
losing access to PID leave um comments
from Mom saying Massachusetts already
offers most workers up to 26 weeks of
paid leave what is the incentive for
young workers to stay here so that email
just hit your inboxes there's um 158
people asking for itl from Mom's Rising
in that email and I'm just here to say
that when moms are able to participate
in the workforce because they have all
the other supports and services that
they need everyone benefits our economy
does well um small businesses are
supported and maternal mental health is
boosted which does good things for all
of us so mom's Rising is asking you to
please itl House Bill 517 and I'm happy
to take any
questions I think we're all questioned
out thank you very much thank you uh
hello everybody my name is Lacy I am
from Auburn New Hampshire I am a New
Hampshire native born and raised I will
make this
quick um I am going to go a little
different same with representative suvan
and say
that sorry I'm moving a little past
myself I am frustrated I am frustrated
that a person who who is not impacted by
this bill who himself walked out of here
saying doesn't understand how Insurance
Works doesn't understand how this spill
works is able to just walk in here and
say hey I understand this um I don't
know if it could be better but let's
just cancel it anyway and we're all just
putting it on the table and talking
about getting rid of it this is
obviously a program that people have
been working on for a long time and it
should be invested in and improved we
don't just throw things away when
they're not working we put more work
into them and we don't just throw up our
hands and throw away all the people in
New Hampshire who desperately need this
for so many things especially when we've
just gone through a pandemic and now we
have more things coming up that we're
not watching out for guys we need this
don't take it
away thank you thank you model of
brevity
too uh oh representative Paige Beach him
I'm sorry I didn't realize you get stuck
on the bottom of the pile because you
must have got here a little late
sorry I got stuck at Senate hearings so
I came in late so thank you no worries
uh thank you uh Mr chair and to the
board I'll try to be quick as much as I
can but I'm a talker um no I I respect
it uh I'm kidding uh my name is Paige
bman I represent Hillsboro 3 NASA Ward 4
I'm also a registered nurse working in
the women's Maternal Child Health space
for the last 15 years I am also
certified as a perinatal mental health
specialist by the only certifying board
in the country I'm also a mom of three
me
I oh sorry um I will say that I my
position is that we also need to be
working towards more comprehensive FMLA
if you're not aware and I'm going to
take the position of the moms because we
know there's a large large majority
using them there's a maternal Health
crisis right now this is the most
dangerous country to have a baby we have
the highest uh morbidity and mortality
rates in the country the number one
cause of pregnancy related deaths is
maternal mental health and most of the
deaths happen not in the birth which a
lot of people think but within that
first year postpartum as far as 6 to8
months out now uh New Hampshire has some
of the highest rates of maternal mental
health as well conditions now the risk
factors for that um are are are going
back to work too early Financial
stressors are a huge component that will
increase our risk of maternal mental
health um in addition it uh decreases
other things that we need so uh breast
freeding rates which The Academy of
Pediatricians recommends exclusively for
six months we know when people don't
have enough uh leave those rates
decrease which increases um health
conditions in the baby that leads to
more visits to the pediatrician more
times that parents have to take off of
work uh keeping FMLA will decrease the
rates of perinatal mental health
conditions it's going to increase the
rates of breastfeeding and therefore
actually save money in the long run by
helping us uh with some of the in some
of those other avenues I would like to
also speak to the economic piece I
recently worked at an organization in
Boston uh providing uh resources for
women during pregnancy and postpartum
our product is so much in need that
companies would come to us and buy this
product to improve the pregnancy Journey
for people and I bring that up to show
that this is so important that Women's
Health FMLA these kinds of things are so
important that we're absolutely seeing a
standardization of that um and so people
who are young are looking for this I
gave the example of Boston because as
someone said said people can just go
over the line and we're going to lose
people in the workforce another economic
uh risk here is that we know that when
people don't have enough FMLA they're
actually um less likely to come back to
the workforce so what we're looking at
here is businesses having to take on
what I'm sure you're aware of extra
costs of training new employees so this
not only attracts our ability to attract
but also to retain many many employees
I will summarize here and just say that
it's clear that the program may not be
perfect but we need to be moving towards
FMLA we need to make the program better
and not get rid of it completely uh you
know we need to not throw the baby out
with the bath water pun intended thank
you thank you very much thank you my
position is obviously to itl yes thank
Benfield I think I'm the last one too uh
another one appeared out of nowhere I
thought I was going to be the Clos
hiding back there all right um well good
afternoon everybody for the record I'm
Karen Benfield from um State workor play
New Hampshire we are Statewide nonprofit
born out of the former born out of
former Governor uh John Lynch's task
force on young worker retention as you
can imagine I um uh uh reiterate and
line with everything that my colleagues
and um other experts uh at the table
have said in regards to um uh the
workforce risks that this that um uh
repealing the fmli um present um to our
New Hampshire Marketplace so I will not
repeat all of that um appreciate it
however um however I also was not going
to speak I was just going to drop off my
letter and um be a great audience member
but um I was called to speak to you all
um um because the prime sponsor on this
bill shared an alternate to this program
um as a private insurance um a alternate
program um being uh private insurance
and reference that individuals may just
need to be more fiscally disciplined um
unfortunately no amount of discipline
can eliminate the growing cost burden of
living in this state especially um if
you are considering starting a family um
it takes a lot of bravery and Capital um
to start a family in New Hampshire um uh
this is not very conducive to our
efforts as an organization that's
looking to attract and retain young
young people here in New Hampshire um
nor does this comment really feel rooted
in a reality um that is true for the
majority of young people here in New
Hampshire so um just again reiterating
um commissioner beton Court's uh
definition of success as well um Brands
take a long a long time to um build so
uh I would just uh counter that the
state the state might consider um
partnering with more organizations to
spread the word on this program um State
workor play would be happy to partner on
that as well um and we also would um are
in opposition of this um and um would
move to itl as well so that's all thanks
great thank you so the last but not
least Leon Perez lean
Perez okay
uh I apologize it's my first time um so
I'm going to make this quick um I'm here
in a strong opposition to House Bill 515
um eliminating this vital program will
have detrimental effects on the working
class and consequenc the economy of New
Hampshire my wife and I are expecting
our first child next month and the
existence of this program has been a
tremendous relief to our family it
provides us with the opportunity to bond
with our child without the crucial uh
during this crucial time without the
added stress of lost income the support
is essential for families across the
state that are navigating the
significant financial demands that come
with Parenthood I'm sure you all know
kids are
expensive um short-term cost cutting
will not bring long-term economic
success for New Hampshire this is not a
handout this is a hand up from a
personal standpoint we're fortunate to
have built successful careers in
software engineering and public interest
law which have given us Financial
stability while we could likely manage
the financial burden if this benefit
were cut it would still impose
significant hardship on my wife's
ability to recover from medical trauma
of child birth something I hope uh Chris
Representatives Christine Perez and
Erica Leon and co-sponsors of this bill
can empathize with bills like this it
discourage us from wanting to remain in
New Hampshire long-term pay taxes here
and raise our family in the state that
we currently call home and thank you for
your time
thank you very much having no more cards
I will close the public
hearing and we assess uh
till
1:35
e
we'll open up the public hearing on
House Bill
556 and here from the prime
sponsor representative
perel good afternoon and I apologize for
our
delay caution this morning
Peter yes thank you for that welcome for
the record I'm Lucius parshall of
representing marbor and neighboring
uh thank you for allowing me to
introduce uh House Bill
556 I'd like to think of it as a true in
labeling protection for products labeled
as biodegradable or
disposable in general terms this
proposed legislation is a truth and
advertising measure to ensure the
Integrity of our Solid Waste Management
it does not require policing and
generates no expense within our state
budget neither does it ban such items as
foam cups or plastic bags but it does
ensure that such products are label that
are labeled compos that they meet
certifiable benchmarks before being
deposited within our waste
flow Governor aots proposed moratorium
on new landfills emphasizes our need to
better manage our current landfills the
New Hampshire Department of
Environmental Services estimates that
Granite saders disposed of approximately
165,000 tons of food waste in 2020
accounting for a quarter of our entire
waste
flow and as of February 1st of this year
House Bill 300
0223 requires producers that generate
one ton or greater food waste per week
to divert such waste from landfills to
authorize food waste facilities provided
that said facilities within 20 miles and
the alternative faculty has capacity to
manage
bucks uh we know that nearly half our
landfill waste originates out of our
state but this is one area but this
particular area is one area we actually
export more waste than import when it
comes to compost we have seen small
compost collection business spring up
and flourish in many of our
municipalities but we have only one
instate composting facility located in
summersworth two other facilities one in
Lebanon and one on Star Island are
unavailable to the general public Star
Island that's because it's on an
island um so as a result much of our
compostable waste is taken across the
border to Vermont and Maine I had
visited the dummerston Vermont uh
compost collection this past summer was
part of my cheap date with my wife and
uh and um I've been told there they're
nearing capacity and only be a matter of
time before they can no longer accept
outstate
waste so we need to Hampshire Solutions
in order to man manage our own waste
flow and address our organic waste
stream and this has to be one of the
first steps I feel
when we have generally greenwash we we
have generally greenwash and um sorting
our Plastics in various categories but
this also caus us to lose sight of the
larger components of proper landfill
management much of our household trash
is known to be contaminated with forever
chemical such as past among hundreds of
other potentially toxic
compounds when the waste is combined
with our organic waste our landfills
produce a toxic and complex biological
and and physiochemical soup called leee
these elich hates invariably find their
way into our beautiful streams and
rivers and comp and comp and compromises
not only their health but the health of
every Cien every citizen in our
state so there's a clear cry for
emphasis on diverting our organic waste
into compost and I have full faith that
given time our state will embrace the
proper treatment of our food waste at
least as effectively as we manage our
plastic
Stream So it leads to the question of uh
what solid food waste is actually
compostable obvious banana peel easily
breaks down my backyard uh composting
but me scraps and the other and other um
like they require higher temperatures
that are typically found in our
commercial facilities there's also an
emerging market for products that break
down within the guidelines for of these
uh commercial
faculties the products are fairly
identified to the serviceware that is
commonly found in our takeway Packaging
they're able to be fully composted
without even microplastic
residue there are Laboratories such as
biodegradable products Institute or BPI
for short you might have seen picked up
a coffee cup and seen that on their um
label um it certifies that the products
been independently tested and has been
verified to break down completely in a
commercial Compost Facility after use
the third party certification follows
ASM standards 64 00
d6868 orm d841 standards set forth by
the American Society for testing the
materials again I stress this is a
language Bill and does not require any
restrictions in purchasing habits of our
retailers or consumers neither does it
have any Financial impact I have
circulated an amendment which I would
highly recommend uh it uh contains
suggested language from BMI cleaning up
some of the language that was in the
uh Bill and also uh moves the placement
of this bill under RSA 339 as advised by
the Department of Environmental Services
um so in conclusion as a common sense
provision I would hope PVE the way to
better management of our waste system
and I urge its pass passage thank you
available for
spear not in any way questioning whether
or not this is a good
idea have you talked to Dees or how
would we even know that somebody was
doing this I mean how would we enforce
it I have spoken with the
dees um right now there is no
enforcement because you can put whatever
you want on a package including it's uh
biodegradable compostable or even uh or
whatever but this language specifically
reserves the word
compostable to a process that we can
scientifically test to and say it breaks
down now you're asking about the teeth
in such a bill I gather I'm sorry to say
that again you're asking about what
uh yeah I I I guess that's what it is
because some of these uh some of this
stuff is coming in from uh companies
that are outside the state or wherever
so I I'm not clear on how he would
control any of
it what comes in from the out state is a
little bit beyond our control right now
this bill does not address what people
do in other states this bill addresses
what happens in New Hampshire and it
does not ban anybody from selling a foam
cup it merely states that if you're
going to put compostable on the label
then it has to adhere to a certain
amount of testing or mislabeling and if
you are mislabeling in your product you
are subject to the same fines and uh
Provisions as for any type of Miss
339 does that
help I'm going to have to do some
research because I can't see how we're
going to enforce it I have I can't see
how that can happen yet be would you
believe what would you believe would you
believe represent gibes thank you Mr
chair um the original Bill refers to
product labeled as biod degradable or
compostable and the um Amendment removes
the word biodegradable and refers only
to items labeled as compostable can you
tell us why you made that change I made
this change um on Consulting with uh the
uh BPI Labs the biodegradable products
Institute labs they said that keeps us
in line with what occurs in most other
okay so um yeah we're we're now was
saying your Amendment had some number
number problems on it um and I I so I'm
going to ignore the 399 in the amendment
and look at the 3
339 and uh I have to admit for myself it
was like uh a path down memory lane
because some of those over there's you
this is number 80 so I've been around
for a couple of those and how they are
in the statute and the nature of the
statute I don't I don't I have to look
follow up with whether it's an unfair
trade practice on the consumer
protection act which is 398 so I'm not
not sure I think that's where the 399
was supposed to be but it's it's a
Wonderland so no matter what um every
bill in this committee does go to a
subcommittee so we'll figure a way out
on this one well that's good that's good
the first thing I I guess I want to is
when it says labeling is compostable are
we talking about the packaging or are we
talking about what's inside the
package I would say well we're talking
about both um when I pick up my
um paper cup from my local co-op or from
my coffee shop I can see right on The
Coffee Cup itself that it says it's been
uh tested and certified by BPI to break
down in a commercial facility It also
says it's not don't put in your backyard
but that's another story but it says
that right on that that's in terms of
what I mean now we have to get into the
definition of what's a compostable right
I I think this circumvent the idea of
what is compostable because we're R
relying on the standards uh set by for
the American Society for testing and
materials we're using their standards so
we don't have to worry about defining
the word compostable they've already
done it for us got it
okay thank you very
much I now have another
card from Mike noric from the Department
of
Dees who was reluctant to testify but
I'm dragging him up
here
um uh good afternoon Mr chair members of
the committee for the record my name is
Michael norc I'm here representing new
Hampshire Dees uh I'm in the solid waste
management Bureau and uh happy to we're
not taking a position on HB 556 but uh I
am happy to uh provide any information
or answer any questions that the
committee might have relative to this
bill would you be the enforcement agency
for this
legislation so as introduced the bill
was placed into RSA 149 M which Dees is
responsible for enforcement
okay um we had communicated with the
sponsor about placement in that statute
because the particular location in that
statute was that that was chosen was
around disposal prohibiting disposal of
certain items and this seemed to be a a
bill related
to distribution of products it's not a
disposal ban per se um so that's why I
think representative parall had uh
introduced this amendment to place it in
RSA 339 to move it out of which is trade
and commerce right tra right move it out
so in terms of enforcement as amended I
I'm not clear on who enforces RSA 339 it
might be Department of Justice uh well
attorney it's consumer protection it's
consumer thank you so that's why it was
memory lane for got
you okay um so in terms of I guess I
Before I Let You Go um this I've never
heard of ASM before um do they just
distinguish
between the packaging what biodegradable
is the packaging biodegradable or is it
what's insided by agreable how how do
they distinguish when someone puts it on
the package that's a great question so
this is the those ASM standards are
American Society for testing um
materials method and materials thank
you that's a it's a it's a national
standard uh organization that sets up a
lot of different procedures and and
testing protocols for various
engineering purposes and and other
scientific purposes um this these
particular standards as I understand it
are
targeting what you might call cons
compostable products or service wear
things like spoons cups right that's
what I thought when I read so the actual
not not necessarily the packaging but
the product itself is is intended for
like food service that is uh something
that would break down in a composting
process because I've seen now I had
these plates and actually civilware that
it's looks like wood but they're
supposed that's the idea so these
standards are governing those the
breakdown of those types of materials
and those products
okay all right anybody else have any
questions see none thank you very much
um having no more cards on 556 we will
close the public
hearing and moved on to to the one looks
for
okay so we'll open up the public hearing
on
delay good afternoon
I'm representative Jessica L Montaine
from straford uh District 17 which is
doward
five and here to talk about this bill
three bill this bill does three uh
important things it removes the
exemption of Medicare supplement plans
from the now wellestablished law that
health insurance companies cannot
descript exclude people from their plans
based on having a pre-existing condition
it requires that any insurer of a
Medicare supplement plans offer these
plans based on community rating for the
age of the participant that means they
cannot charge over-the-top premiums to
individuals with pre-existing
conditions it also requires that every
insurer in the state that offers
Medicare Advantage plans must also offer
Medicare supplement or Medigap plans
this is to prevent insurance companies
from reacting to number one and two by
simply not offering Medigap policies in
the State
anymore insurance companies make a lot
of money off of Medicare Advantage
plans so protection for pre-existing
conditions is really important and we
have laws that protect us from being
denied
coverage for having a pre-existing
condition and most Americans take this
first granted now when we buy health
insurance we understand that we don't
have to pay extra for having a
pre-existing condition that's what's
called a community
rating the amount will go up as we get
older but it's also based on and it's
also based on where we live but it's a
shared risk
pool however Medicare supplement plans
do not have these protections which I
only learned recently and I find it
really appalling
there is guaranteed issue when you first
sign up for Medicare at
65 and with few exceptions it's only
guaranteed that first year after that if
you develop a problem on a long list of
pro conditions that include Alzheimer's
cancer congestive heart failure diabetes
with complications or End St endstage
renal
disease there's no guarantee that you
can get another plan if you want to sign
protections so that gets us into the
problem of Medicare
Advantage Medicare Advantage plans are
are not traditional
Medicare that operate on a fee for
service model with the Medicare
Advantage insurers are paid um an annual
fee by the government to cover that
patient
and so they make money by spending uh a
lot less on the individual's Medical
Care than they receive from the
government and I understand how that's
all Insurance works that way but the big
difference is instead of the individuals
paying for that that premium the federal
government is paying that
premium so Congress approved these plans
because they were sold on the idea that
Medicare Advantage was going to save a
lot of money to the taxpayer but the
opposite it is
true um companies like United Healthcare
are making huge profits with Medicare
Advantage and the cost of the government
has only gone up and these plans are
really heavily
marketed you know especially when people
are first turning 65 and eligible for
Medicare or they become disabled and are
eligible for
Medicare and we've all seen it the
endless ads during open enrollment to
buy these plans and they're a little
misleading because you look like you're
given a number to call the government to
sign up for Medicare but you're actually
being calling a private insurance
company that's selling you on this
plan and you know my husband's
75 um every open enrollment he probably
gets 20 calls a day for the months
months on end trying to get him to
switch over to Medicare
Advantage now many people like their
Medicare Advantage
plans they tend to be the younger set of
people eligible for Medicare 65 to
75 and this bill does not prohibit
anyone from buying Medicare Advantage
plan if that's what they want or signing
up for it the government is the one
that's buying it um but the problem is
is once you've passed the initial
enrollment and trial period and then you
develop a major medical condition you
can't get another plan that works better
for
you because of the exemption of laws
that protect the rest of us from being
discriminated against for having the
pre-existing condition so people are
then trapped in insurance plans that are
not working for
them because they often have highly
restrictive
networks tedious and lengthy prior
authorizations and high claim
denials all this keeps individuals from
getting the care they
need and when they need
it nine out of 10 Medicare enroles do
not have guaranteed issue protections to
purchase Medigap beyond the initial
Medicare Advantage trial
period And if these enrollers develop a
serious medical condition they will not
have the coverage that they
need so if we this bill were to pass
will it cost us all a lot more in
premiums probably yes but not by that
much the Kaiser Family Foundation
published research looking at the
average Medicare supplement premium
rates by state and by the type of
rating the Nationwide average for
premiums for all plans is
$217 a month there are 10 states that
have Community rating that average of
all those States is
$223 a month so only $5 more and I
understand that that figure is not
really uh statistically confident
because you need to control for a lot of
other things like how big the state is
and what kind of plan mix they has have
and other things but I don't have access
to that
data um but it does suggest that
Community rating for having a larger
pool doesn't
not um overwhelmingly increase the
premium
rates
um we did meet with the Department of
Insurance on several times to discuss
this bill and just at our meeting last
Friday they gave us results where they
conducted a survey of of 23
insurers um and we were informed that
the responses suggest an average 50
% increase in premiums and that's not
really consistent with the data from the
Independent Kaiser Family Foundation
that shows that you know Community
rating is not 15%
higher of with states that have that
with States who
don't
so I'm a little skeptical about
that but moreover I disagree with some
of the
premises uh stated on
um a fact sheet that the insurance
department um wrote up regarding this
bill I mean one statement is that
Medicare supplements are guaranteed
renewable that's true but only if you
choose the same
plan another is that products are priced
assuming stable
regulations um you know first we have a
lot of time be before regulations could
be adjusted if we were to pass this law
before the next open
enrollment um but I believe it's more
important for the market for the
consumer to have freedom of choice and
flexibility that's really what we're
looking for
here
and another is idea that healthier
people tend to choose two cheaper plans
with more cost
sharing when they get sick people tend
to switch to the more benefit Rich plan
plan and this would increase cost ratios
and drive up rates for all
customers but however that seems to me
that that's that's how we should behave
as consumers right we want to make the
most rational choice for us to make and
if that means getting an insurance plan
that meets your needs that should be a
choice that we're allowed to
make and the existing laws actually
prevent people from being able to do
this and it is true that when people
disenroll from Medicare Advantage plans
and go back to traditional
Medicare they do tend to cost more
studies show that Medicare spends an
average of 20% 27% more on such
beneficiaries but in the first year
after they make the
switch and likely cause for this is that
switchers were unable to get the medical
switch and the fact is that Medicare
Advantage plans tend to cover the
younger healthier set of the people
eligible for
Medicare and that's the main reason
medical insurers Medicare Advantage
insurers are making such huge
profits but my biggest problem is the
statement made that allowing consumers
to join a traditional Medicare plan with
supplements later when they're unhealthy
unfairly causes premiums to rise for all
enrollers that joined when they were
first
eligible but what seems really unfair
about the
situation is right now we expect people
when they first sign up for Medicare at
age
65 to choose the plan that's be for the
that's going to be good for them for the
rest of their lives now who at 65 is
going to say well I know in eight years
I I'm going to have cancer so I need a
better plan then no one can make that
decision though I think it's likely
after the conversation we had in our
committee this morning given how the
access to medical records electronic
medical records the insurance companies
probably could predict pretty well what
you're based on your family history and
I I think that there's a lot of data out
there
that um people can predict how what risk
you have for developing certain
conditions better than we can ourselves
you look really skeptical about that but
well it sound like you just applied that
they have a hippo violation that they're
getting personal information about
people's medical records I'm shocked to
hear that okay that maybe but I believe
that there is a lot of data out there
and that indiv idual
insurers they they can access a lot of
data about our health given the rec okay
but that is supposed to be able to but
maybe if it's not working then I
agree but I think this legislation is
really important because it without it
it leaves so many of our in seniors and
people with disabilities seriously
underinsured when they develop major
medical
problems and this will ultimately cost
the taxpayers
more money in the long run because if
people develop a s serious medical
condition they don't have adequate
Financial protections with their
insurance they will go broke trying to
pay their medical
bills 65% of all bankruptcies in the
country are due to medical debt and if
we leave
our seniors without these protections um
many of them will end up on
Medicaid so this bill will ensure that
New Hampshire seniors and peoples with
disabilities on Medicare have the
ability to choose the health insurance
plan that works best for them they're
not trapped in Medicare Advantage plans
that don't meet their needs and have the
same protections regarding pre-existing
conditions that the rest of the
great um before we take questions um I I
do have a couple of questions Cu uh I
I'm now 68 yeah so at 65 I got the
letter saying that I had to buy Medicare
yeah I had to get it I had to get off of
my wonderful small employer plan and I
had to buy Medicare yeah and I was
informed there are two kinds of of plant
I can buy supplemental plan and an
advantage
plan and I said and then it was made
clear that the advantage plan the
supplement fee was nothing yeah and so I
said what's the
catch well the catch is that if you
choose
Advantage you can't go back to the
supplemental at all now you're telling
me when I'm about to learned here
tonight and you learn something new
every day is that if I really did want
to go back to a
supplemental that then I have to go back
to pre jeen 7 sville you know 7-Eleven
that I have to fill out a medical report
and they can decide how much they want
to charge me for my premium because I'm
making this decision to choose to go
back to a supplemental what is a
supplemental supplemental is well I used
to call it the Gap so if you if you're
within your Medicare you um you get you
know it's it's 80 80 20 whatever 85
whatever and that that remaining amount
you're getting a third insurance company
that's that Gap policy so you can do
away with that if you choose the
advantage plan which doesn't have you
you yes I I'm the only reason I'm in
United Healthcare now is because Harvard
pulled out on me
and uh but I would say is to answer your
question
about
cancer I made sure before I choose that
Advantage
plan for Harvard and for my United
Healthcare I said the only thing I'm
worried about is
cancer and I just wanted to make sure
that both Le clinic and Dana Farber were
in the network and they
were so that's why I chose those prod so
what I'm trying to understand here is is
that the open enrollment
period in what it in November December
that period I thought you can change
your advantage plan with no
consequence and I believe that's what
the department is saying you can change
your plan but if you want to go
back to the supplemental plan yeah the
one that you waved off on yeah when you
choose Advantage out of the get-go you
run the risk of having them
do
underwriting well you may be more
informed than the average consumer of
insurance products well I hope I'm
probably the most informed yet and you
know a a lot of people aren't
necessarily going to be able to judge
their own risks that way and also that
the plans are so heavily marketed and
they'll promise oh we're going to pay
for your gym membership or this or that
and um most people aren't going to be
aware of the issues that they will have
until they develop a serious problem and
they may think oh be I'll be you know
you don't know what the network you'll
be in the network network that you
thought you would be covered by your
plan that might be completely different
10 years later I mean we see that the
healthcare industry is changing all the
time um
but it's the it seems really wrong to
deny people because of one decision they
make one year that they're going to be
have to live with that decision stay on
that plan for the rest of their lives
you know even when 10 years later
they've developed uh renal failure which
is going to be a chronic uh condition
and very expensive for them and they
have no coverage for that
fair enough any questions from the
committee
members thank you very much thank
you oh I have a couple things
co-sponsors well you know I was looking
on the list but okay Peter you you can
come first I was going to do represented
nle he was second but you're you're up
you've been on you've been on Medicare
longer than all of us in the room my
Comm yeah my committee is about to go
into executive session and I will be
brief
because representative lontine basically
said it all but I have been watching
Medicare Advantage ever since I turned
65 which was 22 years ago amazing okay I
like Medicare that's all I've got I my
secondary coverage because when I look
at Medicare Advantage I go like I was I
was born at night but it wasn't last
night and when I hear J JJ J what's his
name JJ
Johnson JJ Walker that's it um or Joe
namoth I remember when Joe namoth was
vlogging Medicare Advantage and I'm
going like this is so good there's got
to be like not one catch I I I I look
quickly and I'm I wear glasses and I
notice that little tiny line underneath
and license insurance agent will contact
you and I'm going like he ain't going to
get
me and the bottom line is we have got to
do whatever we can do to stop this
ripoff of the American public Mr
chairman when you said I probably know
more about insurance and such and such
you've been doing this for what 30 years
right here in this room in that chair um
and you understand insurance if anybody
in this state does so you're not going
to get hornswaggled by some flashing
lights on television and and but
unfortunately a lot of people get hooked
in and then they are stuck so anyway
that representative lontine said it all
and I don't have to beat that nail any
flatter than that but you guys can do
something about this and and that my
colleagues have been working with the
insurance department and I salute the
commissioner for his provision of
staffers to to talk with us about every
aspect that we can think about and and I
think that uh we've got something that
that deserves your thoughtful
consideration so thank you very much for
your time and I will take no questions
because my gang is waiting for me back
in the Next Room okay well hurry hurry
back thank you very much it's always a
pleasure to see you
Peter okay chair we'll call on David
worry thank you Mr chair thank you
honorable members of the committee I'm
I'm Dave Nagel um trying to figure out
how I could add to this conversation um
because pragmatically I'm clueless I
just turned 65 I'm still in counseling
from going to the club yeah and I'm
still in counseling from having to go
through the process so I got a Tremor in
this arm and so I can't hold my needles
quite as well as I used to but um I I
didn't really want to dwell on that I
really wanted to dwell on what I deal
with from my role as a physician um I I
you know I never wanted to be a doctor
believe it or not I I worked in the
tennis industry from the time I was 13
till I was
25 um I had a broad clientele that aged
anywhere from three actually yeah three
years old he went on to be the number
five ranked tennis player in the world
that's an aside but anyways um to 95 I
mean I had amazing experience as a young
kid and the weirdest thing about it was
that you really learned about the
tenuousness of life because you'd be
dealing with a very able-bodied person
who'd be doing just fine one day and
then the next day boom something happens
and everything changes and now they've
got a disability that they didn't have
before and you know now that I'm 65 I'm
in perfect health I'm a dashingly
attractive male and I'm you know God's
gift to mankind I I I'm in full denial
that anything bad could ever happen to
me and that's yeah I'm humble totally I
heard that
I'm just repeating what my wife said
yesterday so anyway so I you know it's
just life is so tenuous and so you know
the reason why I wanted to become a
doctor was not I found out there was a
specialty where we dealt with function
and that's Physical Medicine and rehab
and that's the only thing I wanted to do
and that's what I did and you know used
I'm geriatrics is my thing um I was
recruited to come to New Hampshire by
Easter Seals I created a lot of
geriatric programs and I will tell you
that every elderly person I dealt with
thought they were fine when they were 65
and all of the sudden the stroke
happened the spinal cord injury happened
just to share two stories with you one
um had a gentleman cute onset
quadriplegia um wonderful male um his
insurance was fine till he was a
quadriplegic and then all of a sudden it
wasn't and um this was the worst thing
in my life I mean spinal cord injury is
devastating to the person taking care of
them and as well as to them but you know
we used to have to advise them to do we
had to advise them to get a divorce
because that was the only way they could
get insurance because they would have to
get Medicaid otherwise they would be
destitute you know what it's like to
tell somebody who's been married for a
long time that this is the only way we
can help you it was like really horrible
and we had that's why I don't do spinal
cord injury anymore because I just
couldn't tolerate it
but there's another story that happened
right here last year when one of our
colleagues very able-bodied 70-year-old
gentleman all of the sudden one day is
fine the next day has a
stroke and now he's not so able-bodied
and he said that was a total wakeup call
he never even thought about it so when
he was figuring out which insurance to
get never even occurred to him that this
could happen and he was a very not as
smart as you chairman but he was a very
smart man and he really thought a lot
about you know what but he realized that
what his initial selection of insurance
would be wouldn't be the same so this is
my other concern I I don't have the same
negative feelings about Medicare
Advantage that other people have said I
90% of people are very happy with them
but this is the problem that I do have
we talked about this earlier the bill
that I met with you guys earlier but
continuity of care is the most important
thing that we do for our
patients when you're on a Medicare
Advantage plan you are stuck with a netw
nwor and that Network may be absolutely
wonderful when you're able-bodied and
healthy and whatever but you get this
disability and all of a sudden the right
guy to teal with your problem is not in
your network then what do you
do that's a problem last year we talked
about prior authorization reform I don't
want to say this too loud because the
insurers are behind me they're my
friends but um we do call it Medicare
disadvantage for a reason um sorry but
um the reason why has totally to do with
priority
authorization it's like really hard and
you know it may not be a problem when
you're healthy all of a sudden you're
not you have to deal with that
issue there's a gap here and that's what
this is an opportunity this bill
presents an opportunity we see a gap how
do we deal with people with acquired
disability when their insurance is no
longer working and how do we give them
options that are no longer going to make
them destitute or whatever is this the
right solution I don't know I'm not the
right guy but I am here to tell you that
there is a problem and we need to fix
havee if if I'm on Medicare so mad
and from the time I was like 22 or
something like that until the time I was
65 I saw all these things that you're
talking about we're not talking about
plans for the 22y old we're talking
about plans for 65 and over MH by that
time you've kind of seen a lot of
stuff I I'm not and we see a lot of
insurance things here about people who
we under insure themselves thinking that
they're going to be perfect the rest
rest of their lives and we know they're
not and you read the news all the time
and you know they're
not are we trying to fix something
because people make very weak
decisions I think it you know I I think
this issue was already outlined before I
got up here I
mean a lot of decisions that we make
assume perfect knowledge and we don't
have perfect knowledge and I I was
joking I'm in counseling over this issue
but
I mean I'm a doc I've been doing this
for 40 years I you know I have a brain
somewhere and I've had to deal with
these issues for a long period of time
and I was beyond overwhelmed by this I
also have a disabled son and we're
dealing with another insurance thing and
you know I've deal with people with
disabilities my whole life and I was
overwhelmed by that so if I'm a
knowledgeable person that's overwhelmed
how does everybody else make decisions
when their knowledge is not perfect and
so can you blame somebody because they
make a decision because they don't have
perfect knowledge or perfect whatever
and then this was the other thing that
bothered me a lot so um I decided I
don't know anything so I got a a an
insurance guy that helped me with this
decision and it turned out he was he was
wonderful he was absolutely great and
then I told that to a bunch of people
and they said really and they didn't
believe me that he was really helpful I
said no no he really was they didn't
believe they said for the most part
they're not that helpful so if there's
nobody to turn to to help you where do
you go you know and I mean I think
that's what we talked about the last
time it was here how do we make the
whole system dramatically less complex
so that we can make wise decisions so I
don't think you can blame somebody for
making a wise decision when they don't
knowledge thank you very
much oh represent sharesa sorry yes
quick question thanks for your question
so I understand that l people stay
underinsured or when they're healthy is
because they want to save on premium so
can there a provision something when you
jump from there to the insurance plan
that suits and covers most of the stuff
maybe they can increase the premium and
not deny you know instead they can ask
for more money as a premium and still
can cover and switch to the new plan
something what do you
believe you know what I'm going to defer
that question to somebody way smarter
than me yeah I I don't disagree with
what you just said but I'm not smart
enough to answer it
right always a pleasure seeing you that
wheeler thank you Mr chairman as I walk
up I see scraps of all the dead bills on
the floor here and I hope I hope we
don't have to join that
today so thank you very much chairman
hunt members and friends on the house
Commerce Committee it's always a
pleasure to be here my name for the
record is representative Jonah orrian
wheeler I represent the towns of Peter
bro and Sharon representative Schmidt
says he wasn't born last night well I
can say that I was and I'm still here
today to say that I think that patients
deserve freedom of choice that Medicare
disadvantage is clearly not working
despite the fact that it is so lotted in
our country today and I'm I'm just here
to to say you know it's very simple
freedom of choice for patients that we
have here today you shouldn't be locked
into a network or you shouldn't be
locked into a certain doctor or a
specialist when that spe the other
specialist might be right there on the
neighboring the neighboring network uh
we should make the insurance system and
the Health Care system work for our
patients and not be a boon against the
patients you know when we talk about the
decisions that they make this is a very
complicated system that does not make it
easy to make these decisions and the
television commercials with all their
bells and their whistles and their you
know fancy words and their government
looking websites make it quite hard it's
a it's a charlatan business you know and
human beings are susceptible to
charlatans even the smartest of us all
are susceptible to snake oil salesman
and uh that's in large part what these
plans can become because you promise a
lot and then you don't deliver
so I'm here to say I support freedom of
choice for our patients this very simple
nonpartisan piece of legislation I think
should move forward at least in the
subcommittee process as I know each bill
of yours does uh I'm sure the doctors
and people behind me can answer those
questions a lot more the complex
questions which I don't have answers to
is as a 22-year-old who doesn't
understand the insurance system I've
only had insurance for six months Okay
so I don't anymore well hold on I don't
anymore so I don't know if
congratulations is in order but
uh so that's where we are and I thank
you very much Mr chairman for the time I
hope we'll be able to pass this
legislation for the patience of the
State of New Hampshire and make sure
that the insurance system works for them
in a a coherent simple way that they can
understand fair enough thank
you okay well this is a rare opportunity
to invite my former Vice chairman of
here I I am shocked to see her name we
haven't seen each other in how long this
is uh Jennifer coffee and welcome back
Jen yep you got to push the button yeah
okay there we go good afternoon chairman
hunt and honorable members of the
Commerce Committee I will say it is
surreal this to sit here as I was once
your Vice chair um I come before you
today on a human issue not a partisan
one president Trump and President Obama
have both said pre-existing conditions
should not be held against someone for
the sale of health insurance the law at
the federal level States as such but
leaves out two segments of our society
not by race or gender but by
existence in New Hampshire it's legal to
discriminate against the elderly and
disabled for the sale of Medicare supp
policies we have an opportunity to
change that to close this loophole in
New Hampshire law this aspect of
insurance has been left to State's
rights New Hampshire wouldn't be the
first to even the playing field and make
insurance companies compete for its
members rather than members being
trapped in plans for
life I was sick when I was serving with
you I just didn't know
it cancer has had its way with my family
and I've now beat it twice but I didn't
get away clean after breast cancer in
2013 I developed a number of rare
illnesses I have CRPS small fiber
neuropathy CRPS is complex regional pain
syndrome and it's also known as the
suicide disease it's the most painful
disease known to modern medicine the
level of sheer torture causes 70% of the
people with it young and old to choose
suicide they shouldn't have to go there
when there are treatments available but
health insurance company deny
access when I first found out about the
treatment costs of it it led me to
nearly sign my DNR the doctor walked in
the room and kept asking me if he really
had to bring it
in I made a big
mistake I was at the lowest point in my
life and I gave up traditional Medicare
for Medicare
disadvantage it was supposed to cover
everything Medicare did but that and a
lot of other things are lies should we
be forced to die from one wrong
decision for the first few years of
receiving infusions they allowed me to
end my over two-year confinement in a
bed I paid out of pocket for everything
I sold everything I resorted to G fundme
to continue my treatments because I
didn't want to
die we suffered two massive hits in our
home back to back one of our vehicles
was totaled in a driveby shooting and
then our rent went up $400 all at once
we were on the verge of homelessness so
I started rationing my
infusions I was declining I had reached
a point of talking to my neurologist
about what he calls the drug of Last
Resort and then in an act of desperation
I decided to go after my so-called
health insurance and demand that they
cover my
treatments others had coverage across
the country so why not me
I chose to go public and I joined
people's action care of a cost campaign
I learned countless millions are
suffering due to delays and denials of
care people are languishing in pure
torture while prior authorization
requests are denied or you get the prior
authorization and then they refuse to
pay the bill or worse they simply refuse
to even let your Dr bill for the service
in my case there's a small clause in
their contract that allows providers to
charge cash and insurance to take a walk
on what is life-saving
treatment Medicare Advantage Praise on
consumer ignorance and it and I sit here
after working with all of you and I'm
one of those ignorant
people they sold me a product and said
it covered everything Medicare does but
left out the part about having to fight
to get that care I have no doubt that
every member of this community and this
committee
has heard horrible statistics of
healthcare denial rates what's sicker is
that somewhere around 80% of those
denials of healthcare services are
overruled on appeal but only about 1% of
people appeal because you have to do it
in a 19th century way through snail mail
and writing letters we live in the 21st
century yet when I helped present
demands to United Healthcare in their
own Minnesota
Lobby to create an electronic appeals
process they refused I know United
healthcare's own stockholders are
demanding change as our Americans both
Republicans and Democrats across this
country who are tired of the fleecing of
America my insurer United Healthcare
takes hundreds of billions of dollars in
public money and profits by denying
people care last year they received a
nearly 4% increase in their Medicare
dollars yet they raised premium M's
51 they took away dental care and they
reduced other services this year year so
they could still make over
$400 billion dollar in
Revenue
billion by the way they make 8 billion
dollar every quarter every three months8
billion dollar so they increase their
income and medical services are taken
away meanwhile New Hampshire Services of
all party affiliations are trapped on
Medicare Advantage plans left with
scraps of Health Care and we deserve
better than that chairman hun I was a
Dana Farber cancer patient until United
Healthcare took it away I am no longer
allowed to be treated there my last bill
was half in network half out of network
I had to go to Senator hasson's office
file CMS complaints then I finally got
it fixed so much for the no surprises
act they paid it half in half out and I
was told I can't go there anymore I had
that was my routine breast cancer exam
that I'm talking about nothing difficult
Medicare says it's supposed to be
covered in full I had a
fight and I served with you I got kind
of a clue on trying to
fight about everybody else let me share
one piece of my story though there's one
specialist in New Hampshire that has all
the treatments I need and more
importantly the skills to take care of
my rare diseases he was in network when
I started going there but like all
Medicare Advantage plans they can change
that any day any month any point
throughout the year and we have no
choice we get a month maybe two to pick
for the year what insurance we're going
to take but they can change the rules
Midstream too bad for you for almost two
years now I've had to go to Senator
hasson's office and file complaints with
CMS to get attention from United
Healthcare to grant me a prior
authorization for care then I got to go
back to her often to get them to pay the
bill after they've issued the prior
authorization to
care and then go back again to continue
to get access to that care over and over
and over for almost two years every
month every week every day of of my life
has been fighting to live to live I
don't want to
die I don't understand United Healthcare
honestly
because why do they keep doing this to
me over and over and over again I've
been to their headquarters I've been to
DC I've spoken to White House Healthcare
AIDS they just keep doing
it they had admit now get this they
admit they don't even have a network to
give me the law says they have to
provide you a network for this in
network out of network thing to work
they don't even have a network not only
do they not have a network they don't
have one single doctor to send me to in
the state of New Hampshire not one and
care at this point in the mess they
actually tried to send me to a clinic
that was closed with a doctor that was
retired rather than pay my doctor at the
in network
rate I actually thought they were going
to fix this recently because I just went
back to Senator Hon's office again and
they sent a letter on February 7th
saying they were going to look into this
they were going to work on this they
gave it a case number they gave a phone
number they told for my doctor to call
to finally solve this and put him in
network for me and that was a Friday
Tuesday I got a phone call from United
Healthcare telling me it was being
denied that they had started the process
on January 29th unbeknownst to me or my
provider and since they didn't have the
records they requested they were going
to deny it we could file an appeal so
I've had to go back to Senator hen again
and file another CMS complaint I was on
the phone with this woman from United
Healthcare begging her can't you just
give the doctor one week just one week
to give you the information we only have
the letter he's barely had it for 24
hours can we please one week she hung up
on
me I'll never understand why they don't
deal with this unless the idea is to
stress me out until I'm dead I mean it's
been almost two years of living heck
with all of
this forgive
me at least that's the way it
feels and I can tell you I could have
never imagined this would be my life
when I was a first responder
a very healthy hardworking EMT I worked
emergency room I worked on ambulances I
was a tutor an ex a
high tutor teaching other students
teaching other people how to be EMTs how
to save
lives politicians are told that Medicare
Advantage is so good because of how many
people are on it but what they're not
told is that we're trapped in it we
can't go back I tried can't go back to
traditional medic care nobody will sell
me a supplemental I got laughed at hung
up on and when I called the insurance
commissioner's office they told me to
talk to the federal government there was
nothing they can do the only way to
change this for New Hampshire citizen is
to change this law and we're not going
to be the first there's other states
that have done this Maine's got it New
York's got it rhod Island's got it we
can do it we can choose to do
it the only way to go back for
traditional medic for me is to pay 20%
of every single bill that I get every
bill every lab every doctor visit every
Everything United Healthcare will
probably sit here and tell you that oh
she can go to any doctor she wants out a
network $75 to walk into his office per
visit 50% co-
option everybody in New Hampshire
deserves to be protected against
pre-existing condition denials of
insurance but in New I'm sure the law
literally gives an exception for elderly
and disabled people to be discriminated
against when it comes to Medicare
supplementals if you're born with a hot
condition no one can hold that against
you till you're 65 or if cancer gets you
only in America do people make hard
money choices on whether to eat and buy
medication rationing their care to try
and survive that's grotesque and not the
lives we have all paid in for all of you
have a chance to be Healthcare Heroes
and in this moment you have the ability
to save lives the choice is
yours and with that I'll be happy to
take any
questions so I'm very sorry to hear
about I I guess I only have one question
because my understanding was that the
Open Enrollment every year you can
switch your advantage plan you can
switch your advantage plan but there's
no point in switching it if nothing is
even better all of the advantage plans
are primarily the same for me um and and
at this point I've been through such
heck with them to start over with
another Advantage plan isn't even worth
it well I mean give an example he's not
in network for any of them United
Healthcare he this provider is in
network for United Healthcare except
their Medicare Advantage plans they
don't have them in network for Medicare
Advantage I I hate to do this but how
about Anthem none I got nothing have you
tried it's all the same and then when
you do the chart comparison you get your
my medicare book every year when I go
through
that it's not there's nothing there
that's going to offer me better than
what I have like I'm not United healthc
Care's Insurance could isn't hor
horribly like shutting everything out
but they shut out so much so and all of
them are the same all the Medicare
Advantage plans are the same when it
comes to this
issue you have the co- Insurance the co
whatever so now you're in that situation
you want to go back to traditional you
can't right switching to another
Advantage plan isn't going to solve my
problem I'm still going to be looking at
high deductibles High out- of- pocket
costs coverage well say this my
understanding was that you you you're
saying us Healthcare was telling you
can't go but if you switch once a year
you get the opportunity to switch to
another one and if you switch to Anthem
which is act you know a little more
active here in the state of New
Hampshire you might be getting a better
response one I can I will definitely
look back into it but when I looked at
my mare Medicare book and looked at the
charts and weighed it all out it was
better to stay with what I had and I
actually increased it to get more Dental
because they took away all the dental
that's why I'm paying more a premium of
51 a month so I can have dental care
because they took that out of Medicare
Advantage and they're not the only one
the Medicare Advantage is across the
board they have increased cost you
admitted to the hospital that could be
$400 a night on a Medicare Advantage
plan okay and that's in network rather
another question represent spear so I'm
I'm trying to get my head around all of
this so is is the reason why we need
this bill because there's people that
want to move from Medicare Advantage or
Medicare disadvantage or whatever
everybody's calling it and get back to
Medicare but because Medicare doesn't
let you do do the
supplemental with the pre-existing
condition after you're 65 we want to get
rid of the pre-existing condition so
that you can get back to regular
Medicare correct is that what's the Crux
of this that's pretty much the Crux of
it yes everybody in New Hampshire has
the ability to buy health insurance and
not have pre-existing conditions held
against them except for the sale of
Medicare supplemental there's literally
an exception in New Hampshire law for
Medicare supplemental products follow on
just a quick follow right but then we'll
have the insurance department get up but
my what I was hearing was about creating
a community rating the comments about
Community rating okay so I'm one of the
few people in the room knows what that
means but so you don't so you you keep
like if I try to get a a supplemental
right now and I've tried one they won't
sell it to me but if I can find somebody
to sell it to me they're going to give
me a huge premium and they're still
going to deny coverage for certain parts
of my care for the first six months to a
year imposs back because of that medical
underwriting they're going to they're
going to uh RIS rate the the risk and
therefore the premium would be higher
than if they just went back so so yes
they want to go back to the supplemental
but the supplemental because they hadn't
chose it right from the big get-go is
now going to be potential higher premium
um and the medical r or laugh at you and
hang up on you which is what they did I
think we Bann pre-existing but what I
was thinking with with the whole concept
of community rating and we'll find out
when the insurance department gets up
here but I it sounds like we would have
to be they would have to be creating new
product for those groups of people who
are in this category who are trying to
switch back why would there be new new
product you have Medicare supplementals
already exist but this but you but
Medicare supplemental doesn't have a you
know is the the it's it was for people
who signed up initially to someone
coming
back so if you make I guess what I'm
trying to figure out is and and let's
have the insurance department explain it
let's let's have them explain it to me
okay I I would just end with saying that
you know people make we make the best
choices we can the people in this room
know more information than in the
average person so I as a medical
professional for 20 years made the wrong
choice and I was in a very very
unhealthy way when I made that choice so
once could argue that I was very much
taken advantage of at that time now
knowing better I have no way to undo
that damage I will possibly pay for it
with my
Michelle did did I get a card from you
too TJ
or sorry on mine okay okay all
right thank you Mr chairman DJ Betton
Court commissioner of the New Hampshire
insurance department joined by Michelle
Heaton who heads our life and health
Division I want to start by saying that
there's one fundamental premise that I
certainly 100% agree with
with all of the folks who have come to
testify which is all of us need to do
far better in educating the public about
the choices they make when it comes to
their Medicare options you know I joke
with you sometimes about not getting
your Medicare Advantage advice from Joe
Amoth and William Shatner and it's a
it's a bit of a laugh line or chuckle
but I think what you've come to
appreciate from the folks who have
testified
is that it has real consequences to it
and I think that to the extent that all
of us can do better in making it clear
to the public that it's a really big
decision to make and you've got to weigh
out a number of different factors prior
to making that
decision it is in fact true and I will
tell you it is of great frustration to
me that this department does not have
any oversight whatsoever of Medicare
Advantage I have begged the federal
government I have worked in concert with
other insurance Commissioners across the
country through the National Association
of insurance Commissioners in lobbying
the federal government to give the
states back oversight Authority just of
the marketing of Medicare Advantage not
the programmatic features not any of The
Blocking and tackling of the program
just the marketing of it and the federal
government has politely declined our
offer to
help and I've put ideas on the table for
shared
oversight if they were not inclined to
give us back that Authority and we have
not gotten anywhere with that and it's a
shame because I believe that the states
would do a far superior job in providing
that oversight in being responsive to
Consumer issues as they arise and we
have seen very unfortunate situations at
the outset where a senior was
tricked that's about the best word I can
put to it tricked into a Medicare
Advantage plan unknowingly had their
entire world turned upside down and we
have gotten involved in working with
that consumer and the federal government
to unwind that decision but it is an
absolute bear of a process it's very
difficult and very timec consuming and
that senior is left hanging in the
balance and so I am in complete
agreement with a lot of what you have
heard from those who have testified in
terms of doing a better job of alerting
the public to the seriousness of the
decision the different considerations
that need to be taken into account as
they make that
decision I did have the pleasure as did
Michelle and some others in our
department of working with the
stakeholders from my perspective it is a
policy decision for you all to make I
always try to be help helpful when
somebody comes to the department asking
for assistance and for feedback and one
of the things that I shared with the
stakeholders is having testified in
front of this committee quite a bit now
that one of the questions that was
likely to be raised was what might the
impact be in terms of cost and they
agreed that that was probably something
that we needed to look into again
assuming that it was going to be raised
at some point in your deliberations and
so we did the best that we could to
gather the data that was available
within the time frame that we had and I
know some of the sponsors have expressed
some skepticism of that data that's fair
enough I wouldn't bet my house
necessarily on what we were able to find
again given the time frame that we were
given to look into it it was not our
typical Deep dive analysis as we've done
for say the ambulance report or things
of that nature
um but we can certainly look into it
further depending on what the committee
decides to do um but again at the end of
the day from my perspective it's a
policy choice for you all to make uh but
I did want to seize on this opportunity
to again raise some public awareness of
the fact that people really need to be
careful and thoughtful when they make
their decision and that collectively all
of us as public servants need to do our
part to increase awareness and
education about again the pros and cons
of the decision of one over the other
and what the
potential consequences of choosing one
over the other might be and with that
I'll turn it over to Michelle for
anything she'd like to
add thank you um just some things I
wanted to clarify because we've heard a
lot of different testimony when we're
talking about medic these Medicare
products there's um kind of three
different products there's traditional
Medicare which are your Medicare A and B
that is what um most people are entitled
to and you do have to Once you turn 65
start paying the premium for Medicare A
most I mean for B most people get a free
assuming you've been paying into the
system and you meet those
requirements now if you do nothing you
should at least sign up for the Medicare
B and you have a and b a is going to um
cover your um hos hospital and then B is
more of the outpatient type
services in addition to that there are
other products you can purchase to
supplement that traditional Medicare
coverage and that's where we get into
Medicare Advantage and Medicare
supplement or Med metag
Gap metag Gap has been around for a
while and that's to bridge that Gap so
traditional Medicare is going to cover
roughly 80% of your cost and the P the
um patient is required to pay that
additional
20% that's your cost sharing co-pays all
of that stuff um what Med up has done as
a product is it bridges that Gap and it
covers that those parts that are in that
20% now there's a number of different
plans and those are the lettered plans
you know that some of you may have seen
and they have different ranges of
coverage amounts so some of them will
cover almost everything others will
cover you know a percentage of that
20% the other plans that we're talking
about here are Medicare Advantage
Medicare Advantage Works a little bit
differently and these are some of the
plans that you can get where you're not
paying any additional
premium sometimes if you want richer
benefits you do have to pay more these
plans look and operate more like the
traditional hmos or po plans that most
people have had throughout their lives
um under either employer coverage or if
you were on more recent exchange
plans those operate very differently in
that you're going to have out-of-pocket
Maxes you're going to have deductibles
co-pays and co-
Insurance all of these plans though
cover the same benefits essentially
they're all going to cover what a
traditional Medicare A and B cover the
difference for Medicare Advantage is
that you're now in a network you may be
subject to um prior authorization there
could be um different mechanisms in
place to ensure that the care you're
getting is medically necessary and
appropriate and that's to bring down
overall costs and those are the same
types of um ideas we see in you know
other insurance products like for the
small group Market yes so basically
you're you're not getting no questions
asked versus the advantage is it's going
to be the same thing you had through
your whole working life very similar yes
um they look similar but they do have
differences but I think when we're
talking about benefits here um I think
there's some there were some reference
to things not being covered like your
Cancer Treatments not being covered they
are covered under all of these plans
they should be covered however if you're
in a Medicare Advantage plan you may
need to go to in network providers you
may need to pay more in cost shearing
there's different um things and you
would have to go with what's in your
plan but all of those same services are
going to be covered under these plans
assuming that they're medically
necessary and appropriate they're not
going to cover things like experimental
that's the same across the board so
that's kind of the big differences
between the different um plans you do
when you turn 65 you need to make that
decision about which route you're going
to go if you go to Medicare Advantage
and then you decide you don't want
Medicare Advantage you can always go
back to traditional Medicare okay now
this is where the rubber meets the road
yeah when you go back what's the
consequence the consequence is you're
back on traditional Medicare you have
that 8020 where you're responsible for
paying the 20 at that point you could
try to purchase a med set policy
however when you're outside of that
initial enrollment period from when you
turn
65 the um those products are allowed to
do underwriting so they can look at your
health history and they can deny you
coverage they can also um require you to
pay an add like a higher premium than
what you would have paid had you signed
up for it when you were 65 and for some
people with um you know significant
medical issues they may not underwrite
you for Med up and at that point you
will be stuck paying that 20% if you've
opted out of your Medicare Advantage so
the big difference here is the outof
pockets among the um different products
and how much you would end up
potentially having to pay depending on
your health needs and as they change
over time so but the coverage is all
very similar other than you may need to
stay in a network you may have some um
restrictions on your ability to access
the providers you want to access whereas
under traditional Medicare with Med step
you can go wherever you want and see
whatever providers you want which is one
of the advantages to those products
right so to understand what why we're
here okay is that so you've you've made
that decision you want to go back and
notwithstanding that they you you have
cancer and that and you can't there's
there all the supplemental plans
say we're that's a pre-existing
condition we won't cover that at all so
that just means you won't get cover for
the 20% yes you have to do the 80 is
going to get but the 20% they're you
know you can't find someone who's going
to pay the 20% yeah and every company's
different so some may want to take on
that risk they can use that as a factor
to deny you so then um given I know a
little bit about health insurance um we
have a uh we we have a we you we used to
do it age band but the premium
difference how much can they rate up if
they were going to accept you as the
pre-existing condition this I assume
this is where the community rating
conversation came in that how much can
more can they charge you from that
supplemental plan or is the sky the
limit at the end of the day they need to
be charging rates that are actuly sound
so if it is a huge um increase in the
risk they're taking on then yeah the
rates will go up proportionately so I
think part of what um when we were
looking at this bill we did draft a
fiscal note I'm not sure it's posted yet
but in our fiscal analysis fiscal note
analysis we're estimating that if people
are allow if you can't underwrite for
health conditions anymore then um rates
are going to go up and that's why we try
for the supplemental for the
supplemental products technically it
wouldn't affect the advantage plans no
it's only going to go after the ones
everybody wants to get into you get back
to the supplemental and that means that
it will affect all the people who are in
the supplementals yes now which we're
going to be raising all the people who
made the right decision we're going to
raise their premium for to take care of
these people who made a mistake and
shouldn't have done the supplemental one
of the issues that I had raised was in
theory what you could potentially see
are the elements of um adverse selection
in the sense that you could have a large
flow of people people who
have
expensive conditions moving into med sub
it's obvious we can only assume the
reason why you're moving is that you
really did have a medical crisis and
that you were not and that the turns out
that the advantage plan didn't have
somebody in network which is a violation
right don't we we have Network
requirements for all Insurance network
aacy requir advantage are not within our
jurisdiction and they are different
requirements than what we we don't
regulate their network adequacy no and
they no we do not and as Michelle
mentioned their standards the standards
set by the federal government in terms
of network adequacy are much different
from what we have our H that's one that
can be a critical issue yes so one of
the things that as I mentioned we tried
to look into was for the states that
have gone down the pathway of what the
bill proposes to do what has their
experience been again we were only able
to get so far with that analysis
uh there are probably a number of
different things that need to be looked
into uh in addition to trying to drill
down into did they have any adverse
selection um elements or Consequences to
it you know I think boiling down what
you've heard the problem with Medicare
Advantage amongst a number of things is
the networks can often times be lousy
for the types of doctors and Specialists
that people need when they have very
complicated unique yeah things
conditions that's right
okay so if I make sure I understand the
problem so we all is when someone
switches
back um
the the financial consequence is that
they can't just switch back and get what
they should have had should have signed
up for in the first place okay right
there's a penalty there you know there
there's got to be a penalty from
switching from the advantage come to
come back and the government the federal
government hasn't set a penalty rate
there's no there's no standard of what a
penalty is other than the fact that the
the supplemental insurance companies
will now get a choice to decide whether
they'll even take you and what premium
they'll offer you if they offer you
anything and the odds are it's going to
be very high because you are in a very
unique class that you're switching over
to them the the big the biggest penalty
you speak of Mr chairman is being
subjected to underwriting at that point
and not guaranteed issue which is back
way back when when I first cut my teeth
on 7-Eleven and if the situation is dire
enough the Medicare supplemental carrier
at that point can choose not to write
you at all right you have to find
someone who's is willing to write you
that's right yes and generally speaking
the older you are when you purchase that
mud St you're going to pay higher rates
typically but there's a lot of factors
that go into it the type of plan goes
into it and when we were doing some
analysis and looking at some of the
other states we didn't see any other
states in our initial analysis that have
done what's being proposed in this bill
there's a lot of variations to it and
caveats to that and just looking at the
rates in those States um you know they
are higher for the most part than what
we are currently seeing here there's a
lot of other factors that go into it
other than underwriting because this
bill just simply says they got to carry
the same rate right is that what this
bill does no this is still allow to do
some medical underwriting or they what
was the community rating what are we
having a community we creating a new
insurance product a community of people
who are switching back no fundamentally
what it does is it says that guaranteed
issue rights are extended throughout the
individual's
life when they're looking to go into
meds up yeah you can't use Health
factors as a basis you're Banning the
medical underwriting
yeah which was a fundamental you can we
do that I mean isn't that a fundamental
part of the we have jurisdiction over
Medicare supplemental products okay
that's a a Nuance in our jurisdiction
that we have no oversight of Medicare so
if we were to pass this bill do we run
the risk of that these supplemental
companies will pull out of the state
well that was what I was trying to look
into that's what I was trying to
determine and as I've said you know some
initial data points that came back
suggested that there is upward pressure
on premiums but again we didn't have the
time or the ability to do the Deep dive
to to factor in all of the different
components that went into why things
were the way they were in the states
that have done this or some something
similar to
it got it representative Gibbs thank you
Mr chair um do Medicare Advantage plans
in fact have a higher uh denial rate
than the combination of traditional
Medicare and Medicare supplemental
totally we don't have any data on
Medicare Advantage because we have no
authority to regulate them so I don't
know exactly how their claims are
administered um we also don't have
claims data necessarily on traditional
Medicare um Tri uh
Medicare
sub operates a little bit differently so
we would have to do some digging but we
could look into that potentially and see
what data we do have available to us and
in terms of Medicare and Medicare
Advantage that data is maintained by the
federal government we would have to see
if the federal government would make it
available to us maybe it is maybe it is
in some places I'm because we don't deal
we have someone here who claims that
he's got he's got the DAT bring on up um
again because this because Medicare
Advantage is not a lane we we typically
operate in because we don't have
regulatory Authority we just don't
maintain data the way we do the products
that we do representative sesa yeah
quick question uh thanks for the
question uh so do people take Medical
Advantage is because the premium is
lower much lower or zero it's
zero it's
nothing okay very
appealing and they send you lots of
mailing and uh followup question
followup question please quick so when
when they sell this Medical Advantage
plan do they do they advertise that once
you take this you cannot go back to
traditional I think that speaks to the
marketing piece and again very very
problematic there some have higher
ethical thresholds than others in terms
of making that information known to the
consumer but I have to say for myself
personally it was this is not rocket
science when when when someone else is
say you charging you okay you're
supplemental and they break the
supplemental into two because they put
the drug is kept separately so you have
two different
supplementals okay and then they said
and then go over the advantage well well
we're going to cover everything drugs
everything for nothing I mean come on
buyer beware I mean where's the
catch well yeah the catch is you're
locked into it and it's and and you say
is well people were buffaloed or scared
or but it's a simple consumer beware
when when you're when you're looking at
paying over $100 and you know I think
the first year I did it I did it the
normal way and I did it for my wife cuz
she she turned over before me
but I pay like $160 a month and then
Advantage is nothing so it's I mean it's
not rocket science to say to what's the
catch
here represent um just okay thank you
thank you for taking my question um my
understanding now is if I'm in a lower
tier supplemental plan I might not be
able to go to a upper tier plan correct
no I've been told that by
my yeah that could be the case
but this might change that and make it
possible so the way this bill is
currently written is not going to change
that I think we've been talking about a
lot of different ideas here and I don't
think all of those ideas made it into
this bill um so I if that's what I think
it comes down to the policy makers if
you guys can tell us what you want to
achieve we can help draft it in a way
that that's going to happen we got to
figure out the
problem I think there's the way this
bill is currently drafted I think there
are some some technical issues with it
we did raise those issues to the sponsor
um some of them being that we have no
authority to regulate Medicare Advantage
so some of that needs to be cleaned up
but I think um what we would need from
the policy or the decision makers here
is like what policy do you think is
appropriate and how can we help you
achieve that and that's why we are
dedicated to you know doing additional
research on these issues so that you
have a better understanding of you know
if you pull this lever what is that
going to mean in terms of Premium what
is that going to mean in terms of the
market stability all of those issues but
we're just not able to do that in the
short amount of time right now for you
guys to act on this bill we would need a
many months to do that the question I
posed to you I believe is correct that
uh you you might not be able to qualify
for a a higher tier program so just uh
maybe make sure of that thank and I had
made a commitment to the stakeholders
that I'll reiterate today which is we're
happy to work with them to get this bill
to do what they intend for it to do what
I also said was we needed some direction
from all of you as to where you wanted
us to go and what you wanted to focus on
what you had an appetite for what you
didn't have an appetite for so sorry to
put the ball back in your court you ran
for these as it should
be most of the times most bills we've
had uh the department takes no
position okay thank you uh chair we'll
call on Rebecca sky from New Hampshire
hi thank you for your time today uh my
name is Rebecca Sky I'm the executive
director for the New Hampshire State
Commission on Aging the New Hampshire
State Commission on Aging is part of
state government we're a 26 member
commission um uh created to with a key
charge to advise the governor and the
legislature on issues related to aging
and this is in response to the uh to the
rapid uh permanent transformational
demographic shift our state is
undergoing so um I'm primarily going to
address two uh parts of this bill the
change in number one the change in uh
rating methodology for Medicare
supplemental policy so in HRA from
maintained age at time of purchase to um
uh rating to community rating
and the second part about um the to the
requirement for Medicare supplemental
policies to cover pre-existing
conditions so the New Hampshire State
Commission on Aging recognizes the high
cost of Medicare supplementum plans and
the burden felt by New Hampshire's older
adults to afford the product uh as
healthc care costs go up so so do the
costs of these plans the challenges is
that at a population level as we age our
income declines the commission
recommends public policy like Community
rating that keeps plans from being the
costliest when people can least afford
it so at at one point uh continuing the
conversation about uh the rating
methodology at one point the New
Hampshire insurance department rules
required issue age rating for all
Medicare supplemental plans sold in New
Hampshire annual increases for this
rating model are only subject to general
cost rising cost of the of providing the
plan with this me methodology moral
hazard is limited um as there is still
an incentive to buy a a robust plan
while younger as changing plans at older
ages results in a person having the same
uh plan as their same age neighbor but
paying more for it as the neighbor
purchased their plan at a younger age in
comparison the current methodology in
used attained in use attained age
results in plans with annual increases
subject to two variables a person's age
uh increased age and the general riseing
cost of of um of providing the plan this
makes plans most costly when when people
are of more advanced ages when they have
the least resources to pay for the high
rates if the commi if this committee
decides against Community rating the
Commission on Aging highly recommends
legislating a requirement for issue age
rating for Medicare supplemental policy
sold in New
Hampshire so moving on to talk about
regarding uh guaranteed issue the
coverage of preexisting conditions
advocates for the status quo uh suggest
that changes in this bill would in
increase uh will introduce increased
moral hazard more people may choose
cheaper products with fewer benefits
when they are healthier and opt for more
expensive p uh uh products which will
become more expensive under this bill as
they exchange uh as they age and
experience more health conditions this
is not uh limited to moving between
various medic uh Gap plan options but
also includes opting for Medicare
Advantage rather than traditional
Medicare Medicare Advantage is alluring
as is in that as you as we've already
discussed here today there's no need to
purchase a Medicare supplemental plan uh
and that it also includes often includes
benefits such as prescription drug
coverage dental and vision
care the commission questions how
significant the moral hazard the lack of
incentive to guard against risk where
one is protected from consequences in
this market choosing coverage is
complicated fully understanding the the
consequences of the choices is
complicated it is so complicated that
the federal government provides public
resources in every state for options
counselors to help people make informed
decisions yet this resource is extremely
limited appointments during open
enrollment periods at our aging and
disability Resource Centers book out
very very
fast the commission has heard from
people who have chosen Medicare
Advantage plans not realizing that when
they made the choice um uh two about two
distinct challenges with the product
number one we've discussed already about
network adequacy uh networks of care
providers are significantly Limited in
comparison to traditional Medicare
providers especially in the more rural
areas of our
state and and I say this in particular
um we many examples have been brought up
but uh one common example has not and
that is um post hospitalization needing
for skilled nursing facility care try
and find one up in the north country and
Network and and when you're post
Hospital you want to be close to your
home community and your family and
friends who can support you um to get
you back into your your your everyday
life um and as was already mentioned uh
network adequacy uh when somebody was in
an HMO plan when they were younger our
uh New Hampshire insurance department uh
overseas to make sure that there's an an
adequate Network the federal government
as um uh commissioner Ben Court said
does have different standards of network
adequacy and that's where we've heard um
we've gotten the most uh feedback um
from uh from the
um uh and the second part of it Beyond
Network AC the Second Challenge I just
want to raise is is that face value
Medicare Advantage plans seem like the
most cost-effective option yet according
to Kaiser Family Foundation analysis
traditional Medicare beneficiaries with
metap are less likely to report cost
related problems than similar Medicare
Advantage uh
enrollees Medicare Advantage uh share of
the market has grown substantially in
New Hampshire in in the past few years
in 2018 it was uh just they had just
133% of the market share as of September
2024 it was 35% of the market share
guaranteed issue uh could provide a
level of consumer protection though it
does raise the Spectre of increasing
product costs and reducing uh providers
in the market to that to that point uh
ADV Advocates of the status quo argue
that the best way to keep rates low are
to have a healthy market for Medicare
supplemental policies they suggest that
these changes will uh cause Medicap
providers to discontinue sales in New
Hampshire as it as it increases their
exposure uh to risk the question is how
do you define a healthy um Market what
is the
um what what is the threshold with
enough providers enough products uh for
a healthy Market the Commission on Aging
really does not have a a solid answer to
this question uh we can say that as of
March 2024 the New Hampshire Ins
Insurance Department listed 20 different
companies selling Medicare supplemental
plans in New Hampshire each offering at
a minimum four offerings three for
people who were eligible after TW uh
2020 uh um with a majority of the uh
companies offering uh more options with
one company offering up to to 10
different options
um and there is also in addition in this
bill there is a requirement for Medicare
Advantage plan providers um to also
offer medic um um Medicare supplemental
plans so so the question of of of of you
know will this disrupt the market that's
a question for for you all to decide so
um I thank you for your time today and
happy to take any
questions uh well we so
am I understanding you correctly that
even though I'm not paying with my
advantage not paying anything now when I
anymore in what part are you referencing
are you talking so my medicare I'm I'm
Advantage so in Medicare Advantage you
are you are if you stay with Advantage
you have what you have um but so I will
have my zero for the for my entire life
so if I lived be 90 years old I still
would be at zero for my advantage plan
so I I will say that that there's people
in this room who are better able to
answer that question but I am saying in
the very beginning is is is that um when
you go to buy um Medicare supplemental
policies the older you are with the way
the rating is done now um well and it's
but it's significantly um more costly it
will go up in other words if I stayed in
the traditional the one that everybody
wants to switch back to yeah as they get
older it's going to get more and more
expensive yes yes because you're not
doing a good job of tell telling us the
disadvantage but
okay when I was talking about the
disadvantage I where I was talking about
is the network adequacy adequacy is
definitely an issue we deal with that in
this committee we're very very much in
tune to that problem okay represent is
Speer
you said it uh thank you you said it
very quickly so I just wanted to make
sure I heard what you said you talk
almost as fast as I
do she might be from Brooklyn too no no
no did you say that it is possible that
we might create or somehow get created a
Medicare Advantage
supplemental oh I'm so sorry if I was I
confused folks I'm not talking about
Medicare Advantage does if you have
Medicare Advantage you have no need to
purchase a supplemental policy um it's
uh if you have traditional Medicare you
may you don't you do not have to choose
a
supplemental but there are no caps on
out-of- pocket payments with traditional
Medicare so so that is why people choose
to buy a supplemental product um a and
what this bill is seeking to do is
change the way that product is is um
constructed so that it it's about the
rating how they set rates for it so
right now it's attained age so every
every year you go um age your the cost
goes up it goes goes up by two variables
one is because the cost of the product
goes up claims are costs are going up
the cost of healthcare is going up and
the other is that you've gotten a year
older if you if this if this was there's
three ways that Medicare supplemental
plans are are are rated so that's one
way that's how our state is currently
doing it at one point in the past New
Hampshire did do um um um issue age
rating so when you were 65 age banding
we called it age banding okay okay so
when with the traditional Community
rating was that New York when they first
did it did the true Community rating and
that means there was no age banding no
matter how old you were you paid the
same premium price we in New Hampshire
battled over from 3:1 4 to one I think
we're you know maybe we got six to one
but that meant the Young youngest the
lowest premium uh compared to the
highest premium of the person who's the
oldest what what's that band and I've
always said our problem was that we
could never get the right
ratio yeah I I think you need a
whiteboard in this room because it's
best done on a on a chart to be able to
look at the way um the different rating
mechanisms work so and the Third Way is
community rating so there's the yeah the
issued age the attained age and
Community rating but Community rating is
one flat number for everybody regardless
of your age and like I said um you know
we we never went there in New Hampshire
we never went to a true Community yeah
it makes it more um expensive for
younger folks the the 65y old but it
makes um but it makes it less expensive
for the 85y old and and what we're
suggesting with the chart here with the
um chart on the first page is well your
income decreases the population on
average so that the income decreases as
you age so it should be we would call
that reverse age banding because the way
we did our an was the youngest paid the
lowest premium the oldest paid the
highest and you want to flip that yes
yes yeah whoa what a radical idea a
radical radical but you know by 2030 um
close to 30% of our state is going to be
um over the age of 65 so we're coming
from your position in commission of
Aging I think that's a wonderful
suggestion for us to think about but um
that is a big tough pillow to swallow
because they have you have to then
decide what is the where's the this is
the bell curve where's the where's the
the B you know are we going to go to the
top of the curve but yeah yeah so that
that that's the advantage of community
rating and and that would be a benefit
but it but as I said um um issue AED
would be better than even issue aged
would be better than what we have right
so representative
Gibbs thank you Mr chair um you
mentioned that the um cost of the
premiums goes up as the policy holder
ages um does it go up just for new
enroles that is when you enroll if you
hadn't enrolled when you were 65 it's
now going to be higher um if you're
older say if you're 80 or 90 um or does
it go up continually or periodically for
current policy
holders so I I'm first going to say that
I am sure the folks at the New Hampshire
insurance department could answer this
question much better than I about these
various um um rating mechanisms and how
that works but it to my understanding um
with with the current attained age
rating your rate goes up every year
because the cost of the product goes up
the of providing the product goes up but
also because you're a year older so so
it goes up every year um um by those two
factors if it was issued age and you
bought it when you were 65 it would only
go up because of the cost of Health Care
um and and and and the cost of providing
the product it wouldn't go up because
you you got another year older so that
benefits somebody who buys it at 65 at
75 if I you know so my neighbor bought
it at 65 and they got at this rate so
their price for that particular product
is this the same product I'm choosing at
at 75 oh I want to switch to that
product it's it's I'm buying it at 75
that's my issued a issued age it's going
to be for the same product it's going to
be more money but it but it it it um
sort of takes away that that um that
question of of of um moral hazard away
that you know I'm not just going to get
a cheap when I get a cheap product with
little little benefits when I'm healthy
and then I'll buy something more
expensive later that's you know there
there's you know for the people who are
concerned about a gaming of the system
but the community rating will keep it so
that uh the product price will still go
up every year because the cost of
providing the product goes up but it
age great thank you okay thank you I
think I got it I did that okay insurance
department
people right you know basically we're
when I say it's a bell curve because
right now our age banding it goes to 65
because the Medicare 65 kicks in so we
are your premium is lowest when you are
a young person and then it's highest
when you get to 65 what she suggesting
is at
65 that you either we go Community
rating a flat rate for everybody in the
supplemental or if we're really going to
try to entice people to say supplemental
is not such a bad idea that we would do
the reverse bell curve where the premium
would be higher when you just turned 65
but then would go down
as you got older did I get it
right that's not yes but that's not
possible I recognize the the boundaries
here there's three different types of
rating that's what you were we got we
got to choose between those three okay
thank
you uh all right so um we have uh four
James fresher
fresher yeah and your name is on here on
top so I'm calling you because
but I know it's James Fisher what is
your name sir Fisher oh this is okay
yeah and and actually if it's okay with
the chair I would uh I would like to
defer yes that's fine I wasn't sure I
was I was just guessing CU he's numers
so Dapper and his dresser that he that
was and I was looking at the handwriting
so I had the wrong person but I somehow
I I think you guys been here before I
think I've seen you before so I should
thank you so all I can say is we we'
really I think we've all got what's
going on here so please don't repeat
anything we've already heard I'll try
not try to be right to the point maybe
you can answer that question that she
had sure so let me introduce myself if I
might um and thank you to yourself uh
representative hunt and this committee
for really
tackling a a major consumer affairs
issue that's what you guys do so thanks
I am a
geriatrician I've practiced and still
practicing in New Hampshire for the past
43 years a geriatrician takes care of
elderly patients that's what I do the
old old that's my the nature of what I
do and I will say that there's been
compelling testimony from younger people
as well as older people about the
reality of the necessity for reform it
may or may not be exactly as this Bill
proposes um so the reason for this
legislation just to
review is the inability of ill
beneficiaries to disenroll from Medicare
Advantage plans that don't meet their
medical or financial
needs so that seems to fall within the
province of this committee thank you um
and this bill facilitates uh allowing
those uh medical um Insurance products
to exist right now people cannot even
just rate them they're not available
many of my patients who try to leave
Medicare Advantage will not find a
supplemental Bill they're just not
offered forget the fact that it's that
it's U medically underwritten that they
can't afford it they're not offered so
if I might um this bill guarantees it at
least is a effort which you guys may
work out further details on um to
guarantee that metag plans are available
beyond that initial period of
Eligibility This is complicated not
everybody in this room has gray hair
here so you haven't been through the
process as we've heard so I have some
background here as as representative
hunt has also
described to to be aware there's an
initial enrollment period when someone
turns 65 or becomes eligible for
Medicare um at that period metag Gap
plans the these supplementals are also
called metag Gap are
guaranteed at um uh um
various um formats through all states by
the way you can have both um age and
Community rating simultaneously you
could have a tained age you could have
age at issue um every state has decided
to do this in a different fashion that
benefits its population and I think New
Hampshire has not um tended to be as
directive as other states in offering
Community rating which makes it
affordable I I do want to say um that we
were talked a little bit about the
responsibility of the senior um but you
know if you're um living paycheck to
paycheck you've turned
65 um free is free zero premium sounds
pretty good if you're having trouble
putting um you know food on the table
and forget Joe neth pushing this on you
it is really hard to resist free ice I
do this to you know I see you wrote 10
minutes but some I think would you're
been really have we've covered already
we we all get these problems okay okay
well let me thank you well let's talk
about get something real tell us
something we haven't heard yet okay well
the question was how often do people um
uh disenroll or F so a couple of issues
Nationwide 177% of seniors disenroll
from Medicare Advantage due to lack of
clinician coverage or financial
burden but that doesn't account for the
many others who wish to disenroll but
they can't because they don't have a
supplement available to them so let me
just understand that it's a disadvantage
now the disadvantage is that I'm not
paying anything but the disadvantage is
because the physician they need they
want to go to is not in network and now
they're paying out of pocket for out of
network care and it's more than that
representative hunt so let me explain
why people let's get into that that has
not been discussed yet yes that is
correct so we have 17% of people
Nationwide disenrolling for Medicare
Advantage um why um Medicare Advantage
plans have benefits as we've discussed
that are structured to provide
incentives and advantages to a lowcost
and profitable enrol that's where they
make their money it's why they're
advertising the gym membership the
person's healthy they're 65 they're not
going to have many medical needs so um
why not so the so instead of updating
original
Medicare Congress elected to Foster
tax-funded Medicare Advantage contracts
with private insurance insurers that
enables these very low premium costs and
as mentioned incorporates the Medicare
Part D drug coverage into the same plan
it's very honorous as a senior to have
to select out Medicare Part D and your
individual supplemental plans so the
promise to Congress was that
efficiencies and managed care plans
would provide more services at lower
cost but as we've discussed services and
choice of doctor uh are demonstrably
less by the way it's important also to
realize as Citizens although we cannot
affect Medicare Advantage from where we
sit today there overpayments of anywhere
between 88 and 140
billion dollar per year that is actually
um this has been um presented by midpac
the congressionally authorized group
that analyzes and makes recommendations
to Congress 88 to $40 billion per year
of overpayments to Medicare Advantage so
why do people trying to disen so not
only are people trying to disenroll
because it's harming people but it's
also costing us enormous um loss so
three issues prior authorization denial
of service outof pocket cost for issues
and limited networks or why people leave
somebody asked about actually
representative Gibbs asked about denial
of service so there are 3.2 million
denials by prior authorization by
Medicare Advantage plans in
2023 unfortunately we're talking about
people being Savvy about what's going on
in the insurance World well this is
pretty complicated only 11.7% of those
denials are appealed but if you happen
to appeal no that's not right I should
be this is a care I should be getting if
you do appeal that denial 82% of the
appeals are
overturned so if 82% of the appeals are
overturn it demonstrates that these are
initially inappropriate
rejections um one in seven denials by
the way for for services which are
denied by Medicare Advantage are
actually legally required by Medicare
and this was something from the office
of Inspector General that was determined
and TW and more importantly I talk with
hospital I people who work in the
hospital all the time 20% of inpatient
care issues this patient needs a
particular medication this patient needs
an additional stay in the hos in the
hospital 20% of inpatient services are
denied by Medicare Advantage which is
way above any kind of denial rates in
Medicaid and Commercial Insurance and of
those 70% of those are are um appealed
on uh are reversed on on
appeal we so so those are some
statistics on again Medicare Advantage
but there's another important issue
which is cost and so it's not just
Networks cost sharing fees kick in for
the person who is ill as um Jen cofy
mentioned there's 20% she has a 50% it
varies by by plans 20% is typical Co
insurance for an inpatient stay a
Skilled Nursing Facility stay medical
equipment and outpatient chemotherapy
that is not the case in traditional
Medicare and you need co-pays if you are
at home getting physical therapy after
your stroke you have a you have a co-pay
um and it's free and traditional
Medicare there's and uh again even there
is a
cap of
8,850 on expenses and Medicare Advantage
but if you have any care out of network
and you have an HMO plan you're going to
be having astronomical costs above
that um anyhow we we I don't need to
reiterate limited uh clinician networks
but I would say that in rural areas this
is an important statistic um rural areas
uh 35% of enrolled leaves if you live in
the North country are in plans that only
cover 30% of the doctors who live in
that area forget the folks who live in
Boston who want to go to to Mass General
if they happen to have an exotic or
unusual cancer if you're in a rural area
and you're not looking for exotic care
you're just not getting the care you
need ghost networks was also mentioned
so you have a listing of psychiatrists
Mental Health Counselors dermatologists
but you cannot find them actually when
you come to look for them so these are
the reasons why people disenroll from
Medicare Advent Vantage among many
others um as mentioned earlier states do
do not have the capacity to alter
Medicare Advantage policies they are
congressionally written and administered
by
cmms but we do have as a state uh you're
and this committee has the capacity to
regulate um um Medicare supplement plans
so the or the Omnibus budget
reconciliation Act of 1990 determined
the plans a through n it has to be
within that framework but states can
direct what kind of um rating is used
whether it be Community rating age
attained or whatnot and and I do have a
graph in your chart of um the fees
Associated so the average monthly
premiums associated with various types
of different plans I'm sorry when I when
and and that might be interesting when
we are worried about the costs of
premiums going up you will see that it
does not
L that's the premiums of the
supplementals yes supplemental so the
problem we're I'm just saying I'm having
okay is that I thought the purpose of
this bill was the
disadvantage plans but now you you often
switch into talking about problems for
the supplemental plans and and and
that's and that is where you guys want
Community rating you want to change the
rating system sure and so the the fact
that you're trying to solve two
different problems with this one bill
is is frankly a little
overwhelming all I can say is I get it I
understand that there is no perfect
plan okay I get it and that you're oping
the state of New Hampshire will step in
and try to
fix both of them for those folks trapped
in Medicare Advantage this doesn't used
to be a problem it's a new issue right
don't talk about the supplemental then
if you only no no they're trapped in
they're trapped in Medicare Advantage
because they cannot afford or find a
supplemental plan so the the whole
intent of this bill is to alter the the
guaranteed issue many so five states
offer guaranteed issue remember I
mentioned that we will absolutely be
looking at what these other states are
doing this is going to be a long drawn
up I would I have to say right at this
moment there is no way we're getting
this bill out too quickly this is going
to be retained we're going to have to
work on it we're going to have to find
out what all these different states are
doing and see what's the right way to go
but that we absolutely hear you that
there there's a disadvantage to both
plans regardless of whether advantage or
not disadvantage that even the you know
the the supplementals is a problem too I
appreciate I'm sorry to cut you off I
got a lot of people out in the hallway
you know anxious to get in here thank
you all right James you have something
new
something new offer I hate going so late
but uh sure um a couple of things just
to mostly I really introduce yourself
sorry I'm I am I'm James Fischer I'm a
retired primary care doctor living in
Dober New Hampshire um I have over 30
years experience treating patients in
both private clinics uh private clinic
setting and the VA system in New
Hampshire and I'm testifying in support
of HB
774 um I wrote a nice wonderful we would
love to submitted we'll get I'm not
going to submit it um why not because
it's mostly what you've already heard
before okay and and I don't want to
waste any more time but I have been
sitting here for hours I feel bad about
that would like some time I I want to
point out just a couple of things
that it's sort of been mentioned but
sort of Lost in some of the
shuffle uh one is that uh under Medicare
Advantage Plans by the way I want to try
to avoid using the word disadvantage
because I think that's where a lot of
confusion comes from right in the
Medical Care Advantage Plans some of the
some of the tricks that they've used to
increase their profits has been
something called upcoding I think you've
heard that expression before where a a a
certain Pro problem like high blood
pressure heart problem whatever uh will
be somebody will come in from the
Medicare Advantage plan and make it seem
like a more uh dire problem than it
actually is so that they can get more
money from the government but that goes
on the patients record and that makes
that puts them in a higher category when
they then try to go on to one of these
supplemental or metag Gap plans uh so
one of the advantages of having a
community rating is it it wipes out that
that uh false or or misleading diagnosis
that patients often have uh when they're
on a Medicare Advantage plan and then
try to go on to traditional Medicare and
get the supplemental plans so this bill
addresses that this bill does not
address Medicare Advantage per se it has
nothing to do with that it only allows
the option of patients to switch over to
traditional Medicare which has only a
one or I'm sorry 2% um administrative
fees um the other thing is that under
Medicare
Advantage uh there's a high rate of
we've discussed High rate of uh denials
of of Prior authorizations um in 2021
one uh the rate of um denials in New
Hampshire was
19% which was the highest in New England
the average in New England at that time
was 9% and it's the second highest in
the country uh so again these Ken
mentioned reasons for switching out of
Medicare Advantage you know the the the
premiums the the are low or zero uh but
and and so you know the Medicare
Advantage plans are front loaded you get
all this advertisement nobody advertises
for traditional Medicare nobody
advertises for metag Gap plans and so
that's not that's hidden more or less
from public View and so people don't get
a very fair chance to to choose what's
between the two of them uh so uh I think
people need to have the advantage or
have the the ability to change their
minds once they experience Medicare
Advantage and decide that they don't
like it and that may take more than a
year to do therefore you need a bill
like uh 774 to allow people to make
those changes and change their
mind um chairman H you didn't hear most
of that but does anyone have any
questions I'll see the tape okay very
thank you very
much
okay I'm on
did hello Hi how are you pretty good
sorry to hold you up for so long here oh
no no we came together I uh Dr Ahmed kti
I've not practiced in New Hampshire but
I retired to New Hampshire 11 12 years
ago uh but I have practiced 50 years
from
1962 to
2012 as a cardiologist mostly so let me
just give you if you would indulge me I
was a first year Cardiology trainee
resident after internal medicine in
July at University of Missouri
Colombia and uh uh President Johnson
came in person to deliver the first
Medicare card to Harry Truman who lived
in Independence Missouri 60 miles from
my University Hospital on July 4th and I
got wind of it and a few of us young
residents went to that event held in
front of Truman's residence Independence
Missouri where now they have a Truman
Library so I was there so from that
point on Medicare has been a blessing to
American seniors and this products and
all the stuff that we were talking about
we heard all day or afternoon 19 uh
2003 uh President Bush introduced that
legislation called Med Medicare
modernization act that's what brought in
Medicare Advantage until then Medicare
was very simple program A and B and
chairman hun you mentioned that and when
I turned
65 the enrollment period is 6 months
prior to your 65th birthday anytime in
that period you don't have to enroll all
they did was so Security office called
me just to show up my face so that they
know I exist and had me sign up for
Social Security and Medicare and a is
part of what you paid for into it okay
so part A of Medicare is free free in
the sense that it's not free because you
are paid into it but B Part B which is
the doctor's part needs to be a premium
that's optional you don't have to so
when when you said oh they made me buy
no Medicare A is available to all
seniors B is available to all seniors
soon as you paid in pay a premium but me
and most of us allowed our social
security to detect that you know so that
corre so that you don't know noce it
it's already
deducted you know you notice it it is
there you know but you don't pay it
monthly okay or you can say it paid
quarterly right wait a minute well the
re last because when I turned
65 the uh and signing and signing up for
my my a andb benefit you know getting
Med the uh they said don't you want to
now get Social Security start claiming
Social Security and that way you don't
have to make those payments you'll be
that payment will be deducted from your
social security check and I go no I want
to hold out until I'm what was it 62 and
A2 or whatever the 67 and a half so yeah
that's why I'm laughing yeah I did
pretty much the same thing yeah I I took
out Social Security 69 and a half
because after that there's no difference
so what do you really want to say about
why we should pass this uh because C is
what uh um medical modernization act
introduced that Medicare Advantage
incorporate C okay got it that is the
supplemental yes whereas traditional
Medicare andb people like me and Ono all
have or should have um a Medicap plan
and if you have Medigap and Medicare 80
and 20 well we just heard that Medigap
has a problem too because the premiums
keep going up as you get older I know
that's what I'm getting to so Medigap
plan is not perfect but it is the most
States the issue is guaranteed as well
as Community rated okay at at age of
issue yeah when you are 65
whereas when you disenroll from Medicare
Advantage ma back to TM traditional
Medicare then they make it hard for you
to pick up a supplemental plan that
supplemental plan when you pick up go
going back to Medicare traditional
Medicare no we got it we got it we
understand I know I know but they they
make it difficult by two reasons one no
guaranteed issue and they they to they
did it to my wife uh medical
underwriting meaning that they ask you
individual questions about your health
whereas uh if you have sub U medic Gap
plans Community rating means all people
living in that Community say I'm from
Peterboro so Peterboro area you know
they will take average risk pool is
larger and you are in that pool and then
you pay the rate true and myself I will
give you one more figure and then I'll
be very brief my own medic uh uh
supplemental coverage say from Mutual of
Omaha I tried Anthem once I moved to New
Hampshire and I found it higher and so I
went back to where I was about $10 to
$15 uh goes up the uh supplemental cost
so age related uh increase does occur
with supplemental plan but I am still
happy with uh traditional Medicare with
the supplemental plan so anywhere I can
go anywhere in the country as long
including Hawaii and so on you
know United they are our 50th state yeah
United States anywhere in the world um
within United States Medicare coverage
is there and my data is accessible if I
go to La even during fire they can look
up my ECG because it comes up whereas a
Medicare Advantage makes it very very
difficult for
seniors because they're trapped they
only trapped in the sense that they
cannot get back out into traditional
Medicare they can traditional Medicare
will always welcome them but traditional
Medicare will not will not sell them the
supplemental insurance at a community
rating and guaranteed issue that's the
crack and that's what this bill is
asking for us to or you guys to help us
uh reverse that problem or help the
seniors for that problem not you know
regular people 65 and above those who
got into Medicare Advantage as you said
when they were younger Young Junior um
senior healthier takes Medicare
Advantage sure because however as you
probably know
2200 dollar per enrol more cost to
Medicare trust fund so Medicare
Advantage is uh charging or losing money
from the Medicare trust fund but we
individually no control over that we're
we're worried about the New Hampshire
consumer and I know you newshire New
Hampshire the US taxpayer and we the
medicate advantages that is way over our
our I know realm of but the same applies
because the people are no Hamshire
people also are seniors so Medicare
Advantage
overcharges thank you very much
appreciate coming in thank you very much
very nice hope to see you in Peter bro
sometime okay
Weston you're really going
to really GNA do that she's representing
the medical
society am good afternoon Mr chairman
members of the committee for the record
my name is Mara Weston I'm here today on
behalf of the New Hampshire Medical
Society uh I will be brief I have
written testimony that was drafted by uh
Dr Travis Harker that I will hand in for
the record uh we um are here today uh in
support of House Bill
774 the medical society envisions a
state in which uh personal and public
health are high priorities and all
people who live here have access to
Quality Healthcare we believe that this
bill is a step in the right direction
and I will rest on the record of the
written comments thank you so uh the one
question I will have you can survey your
members um is there any any Hospital in
the state that is not in the network of
US Health what is United Health United
Healthcare would you find out that for
us so I'm we're hearing about the
terrible networks but you represent the
medical society the Physicians you know
the Physicians so I'm saying anyone in
your practice are who are not
in United
Healthcare Network I have made a note
and I will follow up that' be great
thank you thank
you any other questions from anybody
else seeing none thank you thank you
Paula as I always like to do to have you
word thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee thank you for an
opportunity to speak and I'll be very
quick um I'm here on behalf of ahip
which is America's health insurance
plans and some of the member plans are
here in the hearing room as well I've
listened a lot and I have to admit to
something I know not a lot about metag
Gap Med sub Med Advantage but knowing
the bill was coming up I did some
research and I thought we have sort of a
tiger by the tail here
because there
are seniors and others that feel that
they are uh trapped when they elect a
met Advantage plan and later change
their mind just because they want to
change their mind or because they are
having to struggle with a health
insurance issue and they would feel more
comfortable with Med up or Med Gap that
they didn't chose the first time around
and there is a gap for that person they
face the possibility and probability of
medical
underwriting and I guess in some
instances they may be rejected I did not
hear a lot of that today so you're
sitting there and listening and thinking
well what what do we do what can we do
well you had a presentation by the
insurance department which I think was
very helpful and the commissioner
brought up one thing that I think has
been lacking and that is some
way to educate around the issue of what
you're choosing when you first go in to
make a
choice while I was sitting back there I
thought well how many people are going
into metag Gap versus Med advantage and
what is the enrollment and I quickly
came out with some figures that suggest
that Nationwide there are more people in
Medicare Advantage plans than they are
than there are in metagal
plans so we have a matured Market that's
been going on for quite a few years with
people that have sorted and found their
ways to go in different directions we
have friction between those two markets
we have a federal regulator that does
the Medicare Advantage largely we have a
state regulator that has more control
over the med
issue and we have a challenge
and I thought well New Hampshire can't
be the first state that's had this
challenge presented to them so I'm going
to recommend a couple of things to you
kais and I think representative lontine
mentioned it the Kaiser Family
Foundation has something online and if
you Google around and look for Gap
Kaiser Foundation Medicare Advantage
you'll find it and it's actually an
excellent snapshot of what the national
picture is because other states have
faced just what you're facing and some
have made movements in various
directions and the market issues are
probably in their minds as well well
what if you do if you allow everybody
that's not served well and is may be a
higher risk to come over to the med Gap
Market what are you going to do to the
rating over there and so there are lots
of questions that come up and I thought
well somebody out there must have done
um a
recent
um Actuarial analysis for another
legislature that has looked at these
issues and I pulled one up and it's
Minnesota it's done a mandate review of
a proposal
before is it Minnesota yes it's
Minnesota before their legislature and
they have an immense amount of
information within that now that doesn't
mean that you could take that item and
decide that that's going to be truly
informative for our Market Market we
have a smaller Market I'm sure the
insurance department can get you
statistics and
I'm I guess I'm saying I'm relieved to
hear the chairman say there's enough
going on here that we need to retain the
bill because I don't know a lot but I
know that there are challenges and the
question is what would this state like
to do about it what can they do about it
and then of course what should they do
about it that's where I am perfect thank
you having no more cards we close the
public
hearing
okay
right okay all right right for the
committee members um I'm I'm hoping that
we will uh we've gotten rid of the heavy
load and um obviously we know how liquor
bills are easy for us because we we all
know
liquor we all
drink so uh but there's one one more
there's one more bill here and it's
going to be quick right it's GNA be
quick okay everybody wants that yes
three cheers luckily for you some of
people that want to testify had to leave
shape go ahead yeah all right um thank
you uh chairman hunt and committee
members uh for the record my name is
Alicia Greg I represent Nasha award 7 um
I am pleased to be before you to
introduce uh House Bill 706 which
prohibits insurance companies from
conducting audits of Provider Services
after Services have been delivered but
before payment has been made to such a
provider several weeks ago I testified
before this Committee in support of
House Bill 507 a bill that will improve
the credentialing of mental health care
providers thereby ensuring Granite
Staters receiving these services without
unnecessary delays like House Bill 507
House Bill 706 takes modest steps to
improve the delivery of critical Mental
Health Services to patients in New
Hampshire house bill 706 will improve
improve outcomes for patients and mental
health care providers by ending needless
delays in the billing process caused by
prepayment audits prepayment audits
often require one that providers um
submit full patient records two to do so
in paper format and three to specify
Avenues within the pray system that are
outside the normal course these
requirements typically result in
providers having to either take um away
from clinical work to respond or hire
outside resources at additional costs to
respond importantly these costs are not
paid for by the payer regardless of the
results of the
review additionally if a provider does
not respond in the timeframe required by
the by the payer they will simply never
be paid for the services already
provided to the member these delays
threaten the financial viability of many
small providers as most of them have no
sources of income other other than
payment from the insurers this means
delays of even a week or two in payment
for services already provided can result
in missed rent payments unpaid
electrical bills and other Financial
hardships no one is questioning the
right of payers to conduct reasonable
due diligence to ensure proper
procedures are followed but there must
be a balance too often paers insist in
on exhaustive time intensive audits that
overly burden providers keep them from
getting paid paid for their essential
work and work and away from providing
their important Services House Bill 706
seeks to strike that balance providing
necessary Financial Security to
providers by simply requiring that no
insurer May conduct an audit of Provider
Services after Services have been
delivered but before payment has been
made to such a provider as I noted in my
testimony a few weeks ago our state's
mental health challenges are nonpartisan
and demand all of our attention
as Governor aat concluded when
addressing behavioral health during her
inaugural speech seeking care for your
mental health is just as important as
going to the doctor when you're feeling
sick or dealing with a physical injury
we all need to work together on this and
take care of each other I'm happy to do
my best to answer questions um Rebecca
sarter from Life stance Health was
unable to still be here so I do have her
testimony which will save time uh that
I'll pass around to you but great thank
you thanks so
much thank you wonderful this is going
to go to a subcommittee so we'll yes
absolutely we'll do the de few people
that will be there that had to leave
today that'll be there for that thank
you right but just let them know that
we're not taking testimony we'll be it's
a conversation you know when we do that
okay uh Michelle Heaton from okay uh
Anthem thank you Mr chair and members of
the committee I I will do my best to be
brief um and not repeat what Peter
already said U so my name is Sabrina
Dunlap I'm senior director of government
relations for Anthem thank you for the
opportunity to speak we are opposed to
hb76 for a number of reasons we find the
bill extremely problematic um and I
would just like to to briefly cover what
Peter T touched on that grounding the
conversation that auditing is part of
payment Integrity so that is about
preventing fraud waste and abuse that is
about protecting our members that is
about protecting employers who are
clients of ours um and we have a
fiduciary duty as Peter mentioned to
make sure claims are being properly
build by providers
um and I will just add ensuring payment
Integrity is industry Norm this is
something CMS does something state and
federal government does because there's
a lot of waste in our Health Care system
so we have a team dedicated to ensuring
claims are being build and paid properly
they do this for a number of means um it
can include data analytics it includes
finding patterns that are sort of odd
for the type of provider and if we
identify billing patterns outside the
norm we might request additional records
to make sure that the billing makes
sense um and I just want to get into one
detail in part of why the bill is so
problematic most of what we consider
auditing is done after payment so we've
made the payment and then we conduct
some of this analysis you get into a
distinction and it's unclear to me if
the bill would cover this this where
we're up a level where it's an
investigation so that is a very high bar
uh it means we've seen something very
irregular and billing and it's very
concerning and so that sort of issue of
whether it's prepayment or post-payment
is very important and I just want to
note that the prepayment review is
extremely important because by the time
we get there it means it is an extremely
concerning billing pattern um or
something else that suggests you know
something abnormal not necessarily fraud
um but could be so um I also just want
to point out out that as far as I know
no other state has a bill this
restrictive I think Maine passed a bill
I talked to one of my colleagues there U
not nearly as broad or restrictive as
this but um we have not seen something
like this in other states and and I just
want to say you know we have to be able
to use the tools that we have to look
into billing patterns to do our part
meet Our obligation of preventing fraud
waste and abuse and I think this bill
fundamentally alters and interferes with
that ability so happy to take any
questions thank you very much for the
opportunity to speak
represented miles thank you Mr chairman
thank you for taking my question so um
did you say that you Anthem actually
allows for the service and then makes
the payment and then they will do the
audit that thank you for the question
that is part of the bigger picture
payment integrity and audit can be done
after the payment is made to look at uh
but that's what you said that cor does
okay so in this bill it's it would be
the opposite so you'd be allowed to just
the person would have the service but
then you would do the audit before the
payment so might even change your entire
auditing
process in the negative thank
you okay I'm not sure I understood by
okay sorry my brain is still pred from
your two hour hearing bill says this
bill says you know went terms giving a
time rign for the audit and the and the
audit can't be before the payment but
you were saying that you were saying oh
oh we pay and then we do the audit
correct but I just wanted to highlight
um that the bill gets at what we would
consider the investigative phase of
audit and and so it's unclear to me you
don't call that an audit you call it
it's an investigation but it's sort of
part of the bigger picture okay we have
a whole new definition we need to be
putting in the bill okay okay any other
questions representative
Gibs thank you Mr chair um if you do a
prepayment audit or
investigation um and decide that
something improper happened and decide
not to pay does that leave the patient
liable for the
Bill thank you for the question um I I
need to think about that I I don't know
head you'll get back to us so yes I will
I will look into
forget about that I want to say no but I
I do want to make sure I'm giving you
the correct information and there's this
this issue with in network and out of
network and as Peter mentioned when a
provider is out of network and we've
paid the claim the only way to and it
was improperly paid because it was build
incorrectly um basically you have to go
to litigation to bring that money back
and again that money is not the carriers
that is the members money that is the
employer
money right followup
question um okay
um I um had surgery and I do not have
Medicare Part B because I kept my um
Federal retiree Insurance um
and Medicare uh I have Medicare part A
of course and Medicare part A and Blue
Cross were sending the bill for that
surgery back and forth that one would
send it the other one would send it to
the other both refusing to pay and
eventually the hospital decided that I
was liable for the bill and they sent me
a bill for
$37,000 after considerable argument Blue
Cross did pay but in that case uh the
hospital decided that the patient I was
liable for the uh
believe we've heard this story
already okay thank you very much okay
thank you all right Paula you want to
up okay good don't need it close the
public
hearing mov right along all right all
you health insurance people out of here
now we'll take
okay in a perfect world we would have
been
okay we'll open up the public Hearing in
565 and here from representative na
thank you Mr chairman and good afternoon
members of the committee this is a very
simple straightforward bill is brought
about because um sometimes they have
trivia at the VFW and we can't bring the
baby inside because babies aren't
allowed and the bartenders afraid
they'll they'll lose their liquor
license also if there's a special event
like um I bought um my son's and my
husband's names to go on the wall in
front of the VFW it was cold out we were
waiting for this ceremony so we tried to
go inside to wait in the canteen but we
had again we had the babies with us so
we couldn't go in so this bill would fix
that for special occasions it's it's not
going to be an issue I already talked to
the The Liquor Commission and that's
not would you be opposed that we change
the minor or miners have to be a family
member what Bes sign in has to be both
so and family has to be a family member
yeah you okay with that of course yeah
okay this is the minor miners we don't
know who they're bringing in but we
family is you know family might be the F
so yes represent
W okay I don't think that representative
n is aware of this but yesterday we
talked about um Bill HB
276 yeah I just mentioned out in the
hallway yeah so so we're going to do the
same thing with that bill okay because
yeah
section no person under the age of 21
okay so you fix that as well I'm going
to fix that now you know I I I had 24
hours to think about this is why we
don't do things too quickly in this
committee I had 24 hours and that that
that um the best way to handle this is
to say family members cuz if you you if
your family you you know especially the
VFW you
know
so we're all set thank you thank you all
right
uh Henry
glasson no we got one more person to
testify
are you are you I don't see you on the
Glo okay good yeah welcome to the
Congress committee thank you um thank
you Mr chair honorable members of the
committee uh representative Henry gas in
Hillsboro 29th District I want to speak
in favor of this bill um and then I'd
like to caution you on that Amendment
real quick but first in favor of the
bill um I am a lifetime member of the
BFW and of the mvet 24 years in the
military retired combat veteran and I
can tell you circumstances where I
personally was affected by this uh by
this policy not being in place by this
law not being in place uh about probably
eight months ago I was honored by an
organization called quilts of Valor and
they presented me my quilt at the
conquered VFW that I'm a lifetime member
of and you know they were not in town
but had they been in town my nieces and
nephews would not have been able to go I
have friends with kids that would have
liked to have been there they were not
able to go um because a lot of these
places do have a function hall but
unless it's something that's significant
enough to open up the function hall then
that's just a giant expense so anything
that happens in what's considered to be
the canteen or the bar section has these
restrictions so the and we're also not
talking about you know we're not talking
in this instance I don't know about the
other bill that was referenced about
public bars we're talking about people
where you are either a registered member
a signed in guest or a trespasser those
are pretty much the three options so
everybody knows the people that are
there through membership and you know
parents or
Guardians um should have the ability to
make that judgment call as to whether or
not an event is safe for their family to
be at and to participate at will because
at the end of the day you know our our
our job is to defend the rights of the
people and that would be a parenting a
parenting right
decision now with your Amendment the
caution that I would give you is that
there are circumstances where somebody
who is not direct family may be a
guardian
um whether it be adoption system whether
it be a uh a dating relationship that is
unwed where one has a par a kid that
they co-parent so there are
circumstances where that may be too
narrow now with that said if that's the
only way that this would pass I would
support it but I would be concerned that
that may narrow it down too much to have
um the guardian or parent make healthy
decisions for their family um we can
certainly work with the enforcement to
you know make sure Guardian the family
some family is not the right word but
yeah we're it it have to be your first
example about you know let's say your
your children have friends who want to
come in no no I I no uh yes go do it in
the banquet hall okay make sure they but
that in terms of you know that what the
idea is family you know or you know
Guardian that you know they're uh
because we're not saying that you got to
show ID because they don't have IDs
right they're under age you know so it's
not it's not like a thing it's just that
um it has to be show showing you know
I'm sure family or Guardian will come up
with a good expression to to
get nieces and
nephews but we'll figure out something
like that thank you Mr chair pending any
questions thank you thank you okay chief
anything thank you Mr chairman uh I'll
be quick uh just because uh for not only
time but also uh what has been
eloquently spoken in front of all of you
uh first of all for the record uh Chief
Mark armaganian director of enforcement
licensing for the Liquor Commission uh
we believe that the bookmarkers are on
this issue and and no reason to restate
all the obvious here uh we're neutral on
this um and and see this as a positive
movement
forward and are open to
any conversations of narrowing this down
yes we we can help out with that okay
well and and if nothing else I want to
be consistent with what we do with the
TA I want these two bills to be the same
absolutely did you you supported it I
you said so many we're neutral we're
neutral on it but the bookm marking that
was that we're maybe not too familiar
with that expression there there are
safety measures that are attached to
this that's all right you'll hear me say
that again here shortly right I mean the
reality is that the fundamental reason
why this is here and why the issue is is
because there is no food requirement for
the canteen facility which we heard
yesterday and which as with related to
The Tavern Bill and is the tavern
license that that that is
the the exposure of how and and and how
we want to be consistent in what we're
saying absolutely Mr chairman okay any
miles sorry this is just for special
occasions this bill is that what yes
representa n said okay so it's not like
every day they're going to have to try
to decipher who's who and how old they
are
okay thanks yeah it's not too often you
BFW
theoretically okay thank you very much H
do fill out a pin card just so we have
have for the record okay anybody else
want to speak on
565 see none we close the public
hearing next up
467 defining social districts enabling
fine
yeah okay you're on Bill thank you Mr
chairman uh good to see you
again I thought I was so smart put
scheduling on the same day I didn't
realized it would be six hours
difference I I brought work with me and
then it's worked out quite fine so thank
you uh again Mr chairman through you to
my esteem colleagues of the Commerce and
consumer affairs committee again my name
is Bill Boyd I represent District 12 the
town of marac home of the tomahawks I'm
the uh proud sponsor of House Bill 467
which defines social districts and
provides a local option to create those
social districts in your hands I've
provided written testimony I've actually
provided a copy of the checklist that is
currently utilized by the state liquor
enforcement agency and I've also
provided a sample guide of what they do
down in the city of Raleigh North
Carolina what they call the Sip and
stroll uh which kind of explains program
in a in a in a broader in a broader
perspective um what I do want to say to
amplify my written
testimony is that this is enabling
legislation that if a community wants to
have a social
District they have they will have the
ability to implement and likewise if the
community doesn't they don't have to
implement that um there are several
States two states come to mind with with
robust social District legislation the
state of Michigan the state of North
Carolina um have done a very good job I
think the state of North Carolina has
provided as you take the opportunity to
look at the guide um they've provided a
really good example of of how it would
work in a particular Community House
Bill 467 mimics that particular
legislation used down in North Carolina
the legislation provides specific enough
guidance for a municipality to implement
the social District yet
provides uh a level of flexibility with
it within it for a local community law
enforcement in their State Liquor
Commission and the State Liquor
Commission to be able to address some of
the more Salient points that I'm sure is
going to cause concern liability
District boundaries hours of
operation um enforcement um the way that
the bill is designed is going to allow
those communities that do want the
social District to get granular with
their appropriate uh jurisdictional part
Partners to find and create a um
basically a business plan a working
model that makes sense for their
particular Community uh and then the one
last thing that I would point out um is
that the what started out as as a
response to the pandemic and and a drive
to get people to come back out and to to
socialize and be able to be able to get
a a beer or a glass of wine on the go
and be able to to congregate and in
public um these social districts have
emerged and have become more of a
permanent fixture they they are really
doing a great job promoting economic
development in the in the communities
that um these districts exist really in
in um expanding the local fabric of that
particular Community
um the one LA and then lastly um as it
relates to the outline this outline uh
that was provided to me by um state
liquor enforcement commission chief
fanian who's here today um is is the
outline that they've used to create a a
similar program at Tuscan Village down
in Salem that has been um relatively
successful um it it the liquor
enforcement I and I hope I'm not
misrepresenting uh Chief armaganian and
the and the uh in the department but
that really is that this outline has
served as a model as to what uh can be
used in in creating social districts in
a in a in a given in a given community
so that's basically the gist of it in
enough shell um I provide like I said I
provideed the written testimony and I'd
be happy to answer any questions that
the committee may have and I thank you
Bros thank you for taking my question um
first of all it sounds like a really
interesting idea um my question is you
talked about that there wasn't an
increase in in crime and intoxication do
you know if there any increase in in
traffic I mean not traffic um car
accidents as in these
districts I can't speak to that because
I I was focing focusing merely on on the
concept and and fostering the
conversation so that like I said this is
a local option um as it relates to some
of the you know as I explained like the
liability issues you know and those
particular enforcement issues that may
be out there that I regret that was not
one of the pieces of information that I
looked at when I was looking at North
Carolina and the state of Michigan thank
you uh would you
believe that um I just uh after learning
more about it because I I had it totally
wrong what the bill was about but was uh
I was thinking about how uh one of one
of the first bills that I was led liquor
bill I was ever involved in and it was
sponsored by Steve Avery of Dublin and
the issue was corking the wine bottle
that someone would you know order a
bottle of wine and instead of feeling
compelled to drink it all that they
could cork it put it in a bag and then
take it home and we had rules set up so
they had to be in the back of the car
you know Yad y yada but since then you
know it's practically every state has
now passed that statute but in this case
is the same issue in my mind is that
you're going to go in they're in you're
gonna get a pint
right you're not going to get a half
pint I you're not going to get you know
some wimpy size you're going to get a
pint and we don't want you to have to
feel compelled to drink the whole thing
before you can go out and stroll down
the street that we would just assume
have you take that one
drink and not have to
necessarily you know put it all down so
and to answer your question is yes I
would believe Mr chairman absolutely
would believe that um the one thing now
that I'm thinking about a representative
bar kind of uh I don't know if it kind
of gets to what what you're driving at
but the social districts and I want to
be very clear about this that that the
idea is that you go to a local
restaurant and you finish a meal and
you've got as as the chairman alluded to
you've got a half a pint remaining in
your your pint and they put it in a to
gotainer slap a slaper a sticker on it
so that you're able to walk in that
district with the with the with the
container piece it's it's it's really
meant to be you know I mean I know Sip
and strolls sounds kind of kind of
cliche but that's that that's the intent
is for people that that go to an
establishment to take it in a to- Go
container and then be able to stay in
that District they might browse a local
shop that's participating in the program
they might go to a local Boutique you
know they might find uh a bench to sit
down and just enjoy the rest of their
beverage and and take in the
surroundings and you know you know
basically enjoy enjoy the day of you
know of a particular common area that's
within that particular particular
District so
um you know it's like I said this is
going to be a local option piece where
they're going where if municipalities
wants it they're going to work with
local law enforcement they're going to
work with the Liquor Commission um this
is not like somebody and I and I I don't
mean this to sound glib and I apologize
to the committee it's not like people
are walking around you know with with
with the sixpack of this is somebody
that's actually going in they're
spending time having a nice evening and
instead of finishing their beverage they
take the beverage with them so they can
go outside and enjoy the district and
and see what that particular area has to
offer to me it's it's an economic
development piece um you know certainly
could be a part of any Community that's
looking to revitalize you know a
particular District that that may be you
know underwhelmed or blighted or know
whatever you want to use um certainly
can be a catalyst to uh reinvigorating
you know a downtown or a particular
neighborhood uh within a community and I
I would leave it at that so thank you
further
questioning in the store so yes if if
you take the opportunity to look at the
guide that I provideed you regarding the
city of Ry I don't mean to highlight the
city of Raley but I just I found their
guide very easy to read and it was very
very simple and and really got to the
essence of how the program works but
yeah you'll you could conceivably have a
social District you'll have
participating vendors you'll have have
some businesses that don't want to
participate but you know they don't
participate person leaves their their th
discards their beverage they go inside
or a participating retailer they
obviously going to allow somebody in
with the with the beverage and they can
shop while they're enjoying their their
beverage better than using Bourbon
Street or Las Vegas I I didn't want to
go down that that uh that rabbit hole Mr
so this is a a combo would you believe
plus a question okay so would you
believe that in Newbury port I think I
spoke about this before they have
witches night out which is a lot of fun
and it's the same thing Sip and stroll
and I just want to understand I think in
New Hampshire correct me if I'm wrong
you can because like salons do this
where you if they don't charge you for
an alcoholic drink you could have like
one drink so I'm wondering would that be
and perhaps representative isn't the
right person maybe I should be asking
the chief I'll defer to Chief arm but
shops do that as we don't want anything
given away for free no we want our rooms
and meals tax but I mean it's a neat
thing it's a theme and it brings people
it it generates you know Revenue it's a
pre market thing you know and what I
would say you actually have a lot
against that and representative Walsh I
would believe new Newberry Port um has
the has the geographic design that would
certainly be favorable to a particular
social District you know they obviously
they have the the Riverfest concert
there every summer which is also a huge
attraction there so I kind of would
Envision something like that happening
up here in New Hampshire for some of the
communities that you know that are
eclectic and like to do certain things
that like they do in in Newberry Port
and then the second question nothing
would surprise me that if you have a
social district and you have a hair
salon that that a couple women go out
they have a bike to eat let's go get our
hair and nails done and they bring their
they bring their glass line with them
while they have a have a have a spa day
that's not fur question now thank you
she's giving away free drinks right Sal
exactly right it wasn't really I used a
salon as an example but in newb Port it
stores obviously like you know clothing
stores or knickknack stores or whatever
would develop and it was kind of their
thing they had a certain drink that
night that they invented that they
created that they gave away that was
part of this theme of
this has been an ongoing issue many
years ago Eddie Edwards and I did go
over this idea because we do know there
are a lot of bridal shops that have a
glass of
champagne and yes there are certain
facilities that you know we'll want to
give you a free drink so I I don't know
we're still contemplating our Naval on
how we want to address this issue
because it means
lure and so we're we're right now there
is you know the the law the law does say
you can't give away alcohol for free but
that it is true we are not enforcing any
you know at the bridal shops we're we're
not raiding it to see if they're giving
away champagne or not but represented
sesa I'll be quick thank you for the
taking my question so uh what do you
believe that I mean the F you describe
for one drink you know social strolling
sounds like fun and good but this can
also lead to people I mean nothing
restrict them to have multiple drinks
going around drinks would you believe
that this is going to increase law
enforcement requirement in the
streets
so what I believe not
actually I think it I wouldn't I'm going
to say respectfully representative and
thank you for your question I wouldn't
believe because I think you know the
whole idea of of a social district is
just that it's meant to
a social Gathering it's it's meant to
people that go out that that go shopping
or if they go out for bik Te then go
shopping having a a a social beverage
within the context of a district and and
conducting their businesses is really
what the what the intent is and quite
honestly would represents a little bit
of the success that um the states the
states of North Carolina and Michigan
have had in that particular regard but I
think it it it hearkens back to the
previous question from from from
representative bars regarding the data
and I think you know absent the data
it's very difficult to believe that it
that this is going to increase
um nefariousness for the lack of a
better word yeah I I would say that um
that was my initial concern with this
legislation it's certainly a burden on
the law enforcement in the community to
allow this to go forward and that's
obviously they they'll have a chance
weigh in when their Community votes to
decide to do it but at the end of the
day we have not changed the fundamental
structure how we have in our laws and
that is that when that that drink is
being
sold the uh the waiter bartender has an
obligation to ensure that that person is
not
intoxicated and not giving it to someone
who's under 21 so that that you have we
haven't gotten away from our our
uh enforcement issues uh in terms of
that who is buying it and so yes he
might get one you get two but they start
doing a little too many and they better
hold their liquor really really well
because otherwise they're going to get
cut off but but they might not buy from
Barton they can just bring from home all
the all the drinks themselves and they
well in case in this case this the drink
you're walking around with it has to be
these special cups okay there is a
special cup they drink them walking
around with okay okay thank you yep
anybody else seeing none thank you very
much thank you Mr chairman and always a
pleasure to have Drew Klein visit us and
evidently seems like liquor is uh his
favorite issue with our with us
committee thank you Mr chairman it's
funny I don't even really drink very
much so it's not it's not even my in my
top hundred personal issues um but it's
an economic freedom issue as the sponsor
said so I'm Drew Klein I'm president of
the Josiah Bartlett Center for Public
Policy um I I handed in written
testimony I made copies enough for
everyone this time so I'm not going to
read it um but I just want to give you a
couple personal antidotes to highlight
the testimony uh so I'm wearing a tie
that I bought at the shopping mall in my
hometown of Hickory North Carolina about
30 some years ago the shopping mall that
was supposed to destroy downtown
Hickory the last two years I've visited
my hometown the mall's actually doing
surprisingly well but has empty
storefronts every time I've been in it
downtown does
not I'm not
exaggerating my downtown that has a
small movie theater uh clothing shops
that were supposed to be destroyed and
go out of business is thriving the
entire downtown area has not a single
vacant storefront and that is not an
exaggeration um that's not entirely
because of social districts there were
other um efforts to boost down Town um
they built a stage for outdoor
performances they completed a walk to
downtown but in researching this bill I
found out that my hometown adopted a
social District two years ago so I
called the business development director
to ask um hey how did it go what did you
guys do he said look we tried to
increase foot traffic to downtown by
doing things like festivals that were an
October Fest right and it worked for the
October Fest but the problem was only on
that day would it bring people downtown
and it brought people who wanted to
drink a lot in one little footprint and
it's all rubbed off and they couldn't go
out of that footprint to the other
stores so it didn't work to help all the
businesses
downtown it wasn't bringing the kind of
Economic Development they wanted so they
applied for pre-social district there
was a law that allow them to create an
Entertainment District but the city
itself had to get a permit and be the uh
the lensey so like City staff had to get
fingerprinted all that stuff um they
tried that it actually worked fairly
well except the city didn't want to be
the lensey that wasn't the point the
city didn't want to sell the liquor they
wanted the bars and restaurants to get
the business so when North Carolina
passed this law they put in for it
transformative in the last three years
they've had this for two years um I just
confirmed this this week with the city
statistics and I have the contact info
in there so you can call and verify if I
get the wrong uh their traffic to
downtown in the last three years has
been up almost 177%
you talk about saving small town
downtowns even places you know that are
city downtowns in New Hampshire this
kind of stuff is working I ask
specifically look police crime
intoxication trash tell me about that he
said nah I haven't had a problem I
called Raleigh same thing tell me about
your trash problem no we we don't have
one tell me about the public
intoxication they were like no it's not
it's not a problem so how is that
possible and they both said well the
reason is you're attracting a certain
type of person that wants to come down
and Shop like they're coming just a shop
they're coming to browse and stroll
that's why Raleigh calls it Sip and
stroll that's a very Southern kind of
thing that's what you're trying to do
Savannah Georgia has this in its
historic district they actually
advertise it there's a direct flight
from Manchester to Savannah they
advertise their historic district and
the public drinking in their historic
district to people in Manchester to come
to Savannah because we don't have it in
Manchester they really do that so in my
research on it um you'll see some states
you'll see some cities I haven't found I
mean maybe there's a city somewhere
where the intoxication has gone up but
because you're not going after that
crowd because it's highly regulated
municipalities can set the hours most of
them set 10 to 10 and the reason they
set 10: in the morning is because they
want to have the same hours every day
and they want to cover Sunday brunch so
people aren't really drinking at 10: on
a Tuesday but you need the Sunday brunch
so they want the consistent hours you
cut it off at 10: it's one plastic cup
it's got a sticker on it that tell or
you can put a sticker on the can you
know the person got that drink for this
one thing you cannot bring in outside
drinks doesn't work that way it's been
very successful a lot of the little
dying small towns that we used to make
fun of growing up that surround um the
area where I grew up are adopting social
districts to save their downtowns um
it's working and I think it would be a
really good option for small towns in
questions questions oh yes
R thank you chair for giving a yeah sure
my question is uh do you have any uh
statistics on the crime rate after this
kind of event so I did they didn't have
statistics um I asked the folks I talked
to at those cities if crime had
increased and they said no they said
they're police departments have actually
embrac this and don't have a problem
with it now and they said their police
were wary people were wary at first um
but if you want to call them I included
the contact uh names on here if you want
to reach out to some folks and ask about
the actual data I didn't get numbers
they didn't have them they said it just
hasn't been a
problem yep okay represent sh I'll be
quick so how how will you stop a minor
to get a drink because he's outside and
I can just hand over to a minor well I
mean that would be the same case in any
restaurant right so in restaurant they
check your ID correct but you're not so
you're buying the drink in the
restaurant you're not buying it outside
so um the social dist just allows you to
walk around with it in an open container
just like you would walk around in in
the restaurant or anywhere else so the
adult buys it gets carded and then you
just walk around to the other shops
follow up quick yes so an adult friend
can just go buy two drinks and walk
around and give it only can buy one at a
time oh is that is that a provision buy
one at a time okay thank
you all right okay thank you thank you
all
right anybody
else you want Chief you want to we only
got 15 minutes we got to be out of here
we got one more Bill
[Laughter]
left I will uh thank you Mr
chairman uh again for the record Mark
armaganian uh Chief enforcement
licensing for the Liquor Commission um
so it's always good to be third in line
or last in line when you have thorough
people that have uh vetted out uh issues
that are before you um we feel that this
uh this model is a very thorough model
it has again a phrase I keep using
bookmarkers um and those bookmarkers are
legal bookmarkers to to make sure number
one there's local control there's local
op
in uh to include from the police
department to the representatives uh
issues um but the the enforcement
efforts or compliance efforts if you
will as a uh relate to this uh type of
service are going to be ex exactly the
same as they are right now um they will
be the establishment will be responsible
for that service of that one drink uh it
will be
identifiable uh to us in enforcement
efforts uh God forbid there's a negative
incident that arises uh but like Mr
Klein said uh in the uh research that we
have done phone couple phone calls that
we have made um we haven't seen the
negative uh data that that you're
thinking about so so with that in mind
um I open it up to any questions that
you may have on how we do I know all of
you know how we do business every day of
the week so uh I'm here to answer
questions now I know you don't you want
guard rails not no bookmarkers okay Mr
me don't okay thank you very much thank
you okay with that we will close the
public hearing and we open up the public
hearing on House Bill 496 and here from
the prime sponsor
Committee all right thank you Mr chair
thank you members of the committee I I
appreciate you saving the best for last
um the very long drum roll uh leading to
that
um I I I will briefly mention why why uh
this might look familiar to to Chairman
hunt
um uh but let me uh first start off so
obviously I'm here to introduce House
Bill 496 uh a bill acquiring New
Hampshire state liquor stores to
distribute information on identifying
the signs of alcohol use disorder or AUD
as it's called and how to obtain help um
before I dive into the bill itself just
a little bit of background um the sale
and distribution of alcohol in our
society is inherently tied to some level
of addiction these should not in my
opinion be viewed as two separate
phenomena but addressed together roughly
10 to 11% of the non-child population in
the country has AUD within any given
year um the New Hampshire
uh sorry the National Institute of
Health defines it as a medical condition
characterized by an impaired ability to
stop or control alcohol use despite
adverse social Occupational Health
consequences the Niah also says no
matter how severe the problem may seem
evidence-based treatment can help people
with alcohol use disorder achieve and
maintain
recovery there are validated screening
questions that help PE people identify
alcohol use disorder and that factors
into the bill um our state has existing
crisis lines um for referral and
treatment already in place um and
efforts are made to promote these
broadly in the public um when many of
the people that need this information
and services the most are literally
coming through the doors of State um uh
facilities on a regular
basis um I'll briefly touch on what the
functional idea behind this it it
touches on What's called the stages of
change people go through it's been
validated about six stages between
basically before they seek any help and
when they actually achieve um achieve uh
the termination of use um
precontemplation contemplation and
preparation are the first three steps
and that accounts those first two pre
contemplation and
contemplation account for 80% of the
atrisk population so we are trying to
get those people who are in the stage
before they take action to actually uh
take that next step um so let me dive
into the bill itself um oh I forgot to
could you send around those papers one
thank you sorry I I brought a couple of
copies of just documents um with some
information yeah there's two for each
side people can look them over if you
want I didn't bring copies for everyone
but happy to provide them afterward so
the bill compels the state liquor stores
to make use of their inherent ongoing
contact with much of the population
that's at risk by providing information
on two things one identifying the signs
of alcohol use and two providing either
the 211 or 988 numbers um where they can
seek help and that will connect them
with existing treatment
resources um it says that the
information should be posted in the
store which which is fine but most
importantly and probably most
consequentially
um provided with each purchase um so
that uh and this came up last last year
um the video that I'll speak about a
video in a minute when they're in the
store they're in there for a short
period of time they're in there for a
specific purpose um it's a very limited
window um in which they're going to
absorb any information this allows them
to take this information home where it
can be absorbed at you know later dates
by them or family members um I I want to
make a point this is not in my opinion a
nanny State bill it in no way seeks to
stigmatize the People based on their
drinking habits and it no way uh
negatively portrays the use of alcohol
it's literally a uh identification and
referral to treatment uh
initiative the bill when we drafted it
uh I tried to be as open-handed as
possible about how this is accomplished
um to minimize the cost and
burden there are several ways to satisfy
the with every purchase um requirement
in the bill um the most prominent of
those which we talked about and I'll
mention the last year's bill in a moment
um is pre-printing on is printing on the
receipts and I I will I will Mr
representative pus shake his head I'm
actually going to call you out because
you last year mentioned one in your your
would you believe mentioned that these
could be pre-printed on the back of all
the receipt paper in the store and
completely satisfy that requirement I
personally think that's a great idea um
but um but again uh I I I defer to The
Liquor Commission in terms of how they
might achieve this they were overwhelmed
with the cost yeah the cost so I I
should mention that because again um the
the uh fiscal note that came out on this
bill only showed up I just noticed it
was there today um it only came out two
days ago
um I don't know why the cost to program
the receipts is that much but last year
I discussed this they print a lot of
receipts they do I know so I discussed
this with a more last year and I don't
want to speak for the licker commission
anyway my dialogue about that um he
questioned folks what was the
incremental cost so the paper's already
being purchased what's the incremental
cost in pre-printing on the back the
estimate was $40,000 000 um so well
below what the fiscal note says but
again I don't get to write the fiscal
note um I just wanted to put that out
there
um did did what's it say in the fiscal
note now I it's it says that the cost of
programming this to be printed on the on
the receipts through which would be the
front of the receipt correct in excess
of 100 and less than
$500,000 is what is it just came like I
didn't know it was there until
today um but any rate uh that research
was done last year I think that's a
great solution but again not my call I
defer to the folks that all I know is I
had used to use down on my Sumer home in
Rhode Island Stop and Shop used to have
on the back they always had all that
stuff on it yeah gone okay I mean I
evidently it's really expensive to put
stuff on the back okay well I don't I
don't want this is the policy review of
the of the bill um I know the fiscal
people have might have their way with it
later on um I just wanted to put it out
there that that was a number that we got
last year for pre-printing and I totally
acknowledge since you raised it that
most people don't look at this on the
back of their receipts but we're not
talking about one you know stop at CVS
to pick up you know toothpaste the folks
that this is aimed at are making
repeated visits by nature of the problem
that they have are making repeated
visits to the state liquor stores these
will pile up these will be things that
will be lying on the back seat of the
car these will be things that their
friends or their family members might
pick up and say hey these couple little
questions on here sounds like maybe you
do you want to think about taking taking
a step toward that it's not an an State
it's just offering information but again
I I'm not here to I'm not here to debate
the merits I'm just here to present the
bill um so again it natur Al targets the
atrisk population these are folks who
are coming in repeatedly by nature of
the problem they have um and it allows
the information rather than to focus on
the store to be absorbed over time so
let me let me spend a couple of minutes
on last the the bill I had had last year
you got five minutes oh okay I didn't
know I had a time oh yeah you didn't
know about the rule that we have to shut
the state this building down at 5 o' I
did not know that I I I okay well then I
won't delay um House Bill 1621 last year
very similar bill um it took an
interesting we will be going to subc
commmittee so what we will be going to
subcommitte okay so suffice it to say
there was a bill last year um it went to
interim study but the Liquor Commission
liked the content the commissioner put
together a a a grant-funded
professionally shot video that is now
intended and is running I've seen it uh
on all the screens in all the state
liquor stores um not on a not not on a
continuous basis but it's a 30 second
video and it's on a loop in between the
advertisements that run on those same
screens um so my goal here is basically
to reintroduce this bill to solidify
that success because it is not anywhere
mandated it was a same onetime Grant
funded initiative and to deepen this you
know I think initial and successful I
think hopefully others would agree
collaboration between the Liquor
Commission and our Public Health
Community um and it doesn't compromise
the mission of either group it actually
enhances I think the mission of both
groups um so a quick couple of numbers
for New Hampshire which is in the
information I sent around so we are a
control State one of depending on how
you count up to up up to 18 but a lot
less that do it the way we do it um our
rate of alcohol use disorder in New
Hampshire most recent numbers for the 18
plus
population um is around 12% it's above
the national average it's above the New
England average uh Northeast average I
should say we're 36 in the country as
far as uh alcohol use disorder rates um
I'm not going to estimate the human cost
in terms of lives in terms of families
in terms of careers and um and in terms
of people's Liberty um the cost New
Hampshire for for actual dollars however
is estimated um it's in the document
that I sent around um
uh I won't read the whole title but it's
from 2017 that's the most recent we have
direct costs for things like police
courts jails property damage uh
treatment of addiction Health
consequences is about $800 million
that's roughly the same as the gross not
net proceeds for our state's liquor
sales so a small impact would make a
huge difference if you include loss
productivity in that docu in in that
estimate it goes up by an additional
over a billion dollars to 2.3 billion
that's not born in any way in the cost
of the sales but it's being born at our
counties and our towns and our police
departments and our health insurance so
all I will say is treatment treatment
programs work it also estimates that
there's $3 benefit for every $1 of
treatment um that's provided so again
I'm hoping to build on what's happened
last year not supplant it not say that
it wasn't a good thing it was a really
good thing
um it imposes minimal
costs and if you believe that fiscal
note they said there's 10 million
transactions that take place in New
Hampshire so if we can for maybe the
cost of $40,000 pre-print this
information scientifically proven
information on the back of of each
receipt if we could make a half a
percent
difference we we we would make a huge
impact and I think we could do a lot
more so thank you I glad to take any
questions
I'm sure Aiden's ears are
burning okay and and I didn't mean to
imply anything other than what we
discussed in the past thank you very
much we're all set we good thank you
because Linda's got two minutes or one
minute we're all supposed to be leaving
the building one
minute sorry to hold you up I really
thought we could get through today but I
was wrong thank you Mr chairman
colleagues and Friends friends I am one
of those victims of alcoholism I am not
an
alcoholic I lost my mother at 47 I lost
my niece at 50 and my nephew at 35 I'm
very grateful to Eric for bringing this
bill forward it's a tiny step we're
going to need a lot of efforts to stem
the tide of our national disease I run a
support group for loved ones of addicted
person so I hear these stories every
time we meet spouses children loved ones
who suffer from alcoholism this is a
tiny step but it's one that we can do
and because we can I think we should I'm
not going to take up any more of your
time obviously I support the bill and I
thank you for staying this long to hear
it thank you very much
oh I'm sorry Linda H Haskins Rockingham
exitor thank you and with that and the
fiscal node is now being passed
out thank you all very much we're all
down to one last bill uh that we'll take
up to in two weeks otherwise it's
another liquor one more Bill left for
for hearings otherwise we've done we've
heard heard